SERVICE- IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS NORMAL PRACTICES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC IT'S
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS LIST OF
THE PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING AND WE ASK. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PRESENT
HERE IN OUR ROOMS TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR
QUORUM A BEGINNER HEARING. I
THINK OUR TERROR MERECE FOR
BEING HERE AND I KNOW OTHER
MEMBERS ARE ON THEIR WAY- TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN
THE HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO IS TO
TESTIFY TODAY NOW FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE THAT'S
877-226-8163 THE ACCESS CODE IS. 736-283-3736 TWO EIGHT THREE
THREE. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
AND OR- COMMITTEE WEBSITE. NOW
WE MADE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR DIAL ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR FOR
OPPOSITION- PRESS. ONLY ONE TIME
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR
TO. ASSIGN YOU TO A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
AWAY IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER
AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE A MUTED
YOU'LL BE NOW READY TO ADJUST
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
TO AVOID. ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
PLEASE MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON FOR A
PRIOR TO. GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WE'RE GONNA
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THIS THE
HEARING. HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND I SEE SOMEONE
REALLY INDIVIDUALS HERE ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE. REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE AND HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED- NOW WE'VE GOT
SEVENTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WITH THREE BILLS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM YET- SO WE WILL START
MOVING OUR- CONSENT COUNTY ALL
THAT LATER ON BUT WE DO HAVE OUR
FIRST AUTHOR HERE. CENTER
WIENER- IS HERE TO PRESENT SB
NINE TWO TWO SO WE CAN START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE WE'VE CHECKED
WITH A MINORITY STAFF THERE OKAY
WITH THIS. AND WILL. PROCEED
FROM THERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND- WELCOME TO OUR HEARING THIS
MORNING CENTER- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I WILL SITUATE
MYSELF AT THIS TINY- LIKE DURING
. SHORTLY SMALL I'VE BEEN
ASSURED- BY MISSING FOR US THAT
IT IS GOING TO BE ADDRESSED AND-
ALL PEOPLE WILL NOT BE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST ANYMORE-
SO- I THANK YOU I MISS OR THANK
THE CHAIR AND I COMMITTEE FOR-
WORKING WITH US- IN THE PAST
SEVERAL WEEKS ON THIS BILL- AND-
I WON- CHU COOLEY I THANK THE
CHAIR FOR TAKING A LOT OF TIME-
HAVE DIALOGUE WITH US- AND SO
THE- THAT THE COMMITTEE IS NOW
HAS ISSUED A REVISED AMENDMENTS
THIS MORNING THEY'RE NOT THE
AMENDMENTS OR ANY ANALYSIS NEW
AMENDMENTS THAT WE- ARE WORKED
OUT WITH THE COMMITTEE-
INCLUDING- WHICH ARE IF YOU'VE
GIVEN US I ASSUME THOSE HAVE
BEEN GIVEN TO THE MEMBERS. YES
THE THIRD VISIT ALL THE MEMBERS
OFF HIS AND- IF ANYONE- WOULD
LIKE COPIES PLEASE ALLEGE. BUT I
KNOW THE FOLKS INVOLVED IN THE
BILL HAVE THEM YEP- AND- AND.
AND THOSE ARE REVISED- COMMITTEE-MEMBERS INCLUDING THE NEW NUMBER
EIGHT THAT'S LIKE A SUBSIDIARY
TO NUMBER SEVEN- WERE WILL BE
EXCEPT WERE ACCEPTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS- REALLY APPRECIATIVE
SHARE FOR WORKING WITH US- ON ON
THESE AMENDMENTS AND I THINK-
THEY WILL- THE BILL IS STILL
GOING TO BE AND VERY STRONG
FORMS OF THANK YOU. ON THE
COLLEAGUES ARE SB NINE TWENTY
TWO. IS AN ACT EXTENSION AND-
AND- LIMITED EXPANSION- OF
LEGISLATION THAT I AUTHORED THAT
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW IN TWENTY
TWENTY WHICH IS SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT SO THAT ADDED TO
YOUR SUNSET. AND SO- WHAT WERE
POSING AS UNDER THE MEMBERS FOR
ACCEPTING TODAY A SEVEN YEAR
EXTENSION- THAT SUNSET- AND SOME
MODIFICATIONS- WHAT- SB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT AND NOW SB NINE
TWENTY TWO- DO- IS TO EXPEDITE-
THE APPROVAL AND DEPLOYMENT OF
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS- IN CALIFORNIA BY
CREATING OUTSTANDING- A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION. FOR BUS RAPID TRANSIT
PROJECTS LATE ROUTE PROJECTS-
BIKER BLASTER PROJECTS ALL IN
EXISTING. RIGHT OF WAY- TO MAKE
THAT THE SYSTEM TRUST PROJECTS
CAN BE A- QUICKLY- SICK WHY
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT LAW- WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT EMPIRE
MENTALLY STABLE PROJECTS- ARE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD IN THE
EXPEDITIOUS. WAY AND WE HAVE
GUARDRAILS IN THE BILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE PROJECTS ARE-
AND BY ENVIRONMENTALLY
BENEFICIAL- WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
A TRANSPORTATION ISSUE- IT'S
ALSO CLIMATE- ISSUE- WORKERS IN
A CLIMATE EMERGENCY AND IT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH TO TELL PEOPLE WE
DON'T WANT YOU TO DRIVE. TO GET
PEOPLE ACTUAL OPTIONS OTHER THAN
DRIVING IS SO IMPROVING BUS AND
RAIL SERVICE. I AND MAKING BY
WALKING SAY. IS ONE WAY GET
PEOPLE- THOSE- THOSE OPTIONS- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WE ARE SEEING
SIGNIFICANT NEW FUNDING. FOR
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION FROM
THE- FEDERAL- BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE- BILL- THAT MONEY
IS COMING OUR WAY THANKFULLY I
WE KNOW THAT- IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AND THIS YEAR THERE WERE
ALSO SEEING SIZABLE INCREASED
INVESTMENTS. IN OUR SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION AND WE HAVE
PLENTY OF LOCAL AND REGIONAL-
MEASURES OUT- HAVE PROVIDE OR
PROVIDING YOUR FUNDING. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT FUNDING CAN BE
DEPLOYED ON THE GROUND ARE WE
ARE NOT HELD UP ON APPEALS AND
LITIGATION- SO- THE BILL- AS
WITH SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT-
REQUIRES A LARGER PROJECTS OF A
HUNDRED MILLION OR MORE. THERE
IS A- OUTLINE COMMUNITY PROCESS
IN TERMS OF COMMUNITY MEETINGS
ON A RACIAL EQUITY ANALYSIS AND
WE'RE NOW ADDING A DISPLACEMENT
ANALYSIS- INTO THAT- AND WE WILL
OF COURSE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ALL. OUR STAKEHOLDERS- AND WE
NOTICED SOME WORK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DO WITH THE COMMITTEE UP
TO TODAY IN TERMS OF- CLARIFYING
THANKS. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT WORK ALSO COLLEAGUES- THIS
IS- I THINK AN IMPORTANT- BILL-
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN THAT WITH SB
TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THURMOND- A
NUMBER OF SB THREE AID PROJECTS.
IN THE FIFTEEN MONTHS SAID IT'S
BEEN A FACT AROUND THE STATE-
BOTH THE NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE PROJECTS AND LOS
ANGELES AND ELSEWHERE THAT ARE
IN THE PIPELINE. SO IT'S
EXCITING SITUATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. DO YOU FOLKS ARE BEST
FRIENDS OUT OF Y APOLOGIES-
WITH- WITH ME BURKE. TESTIFIED
BY PHONE. OUR JEFF TOM WHO'S AT
THE CAN. SAN FRANCISCO AND
MICHAEL TURNER. THE DEATH EXACT
EXACTLY THE EXACT OFFICER OF LOS
ANGELES METRO. MISTER MISTER
THOMAS. ALL RIGHT GREAT THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CAROLINE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JEFFREY COME ONE AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. PAVMED
APARTMENT THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND WE OVERSEE THE
CITY'S GROUND TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. I INCLUDING MUNY WHICH
IS THE CITY'S PUBLIC TRANSIT
SYSTEM AS WELL AS TAKING PARA
TRANSIT PARKING TRAFFIC WALKING
AND TAXIS AND I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY. IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE TWENTY TWO AM SHARE HOW THE
BILL'S PREDECESSOR SB TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT. HELPED HUNDREDS OF GO
DEAL WITH THE EFFECTS OF COVERED
NINETEEN. DURING THE PANDEMIC
THE INTERIORS WORK TO KEEP OUR
STAFF PUBLICSAFE WHILE STILL
MEETING THE CENTRAL PROBLEM
NEEDS OF SAN FRANCISCO. THE
START OF CHILDREN PLAY IF THE
EFFECT HERE TO WORK QUICKLY TO
DEVELOP RECOVERY PLAN AND MEET
THOSE CHALLENGES WHILE MOVING
FORWARD WITH PROJECTS REQUESTED
BY THE COMMUNITY. BEFORE
GOVERNMENT. ENACTMENT OF SB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT O'CLOCK TO EXTEND
KEY TRANSPORTATION RECOVERY
PROJECTS ON PRIORITY TRANSIT
ROUTES- AND CREATE FLOWCHARTS.
WHILE IMPLEMENTING QUICK BILL
PROJECTS IN THE TENDERLOIN
NEIGHBORHOOD ONE OF OUR CITIES
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
RESPOND TO COMMUNITY TRAFFIC
SAFETY CONCERNS. SB TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT ALTHOUGH A LOT OF TO
QUICKLY IMPLEMENT PROJECTS
RESULTING FROM COMMUNITY
PLANNING EFFORTS SUCH AS THE
BAYVIEW COMMUNITY BASED
TRANSPORTATION PLAN. BUT
ACCORDINGLY SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
REMOVED UNNECESSARY DELAYS AND
ALLOW US TO GET OUR CENTRAL WORK
DONE QUICKLY WHICH IS WHAT THE
COMMUNITY WANTED AND NEEDED.
CANNOT GO BACK TO WORLD WAR ONE
PERSON CAN SUE AND HOLD UP
SAFETY PROJECTS CONDUCT A
REDUCTION PROJECTS AND PROJECTS
REQUESTED BY THE VAST MAJORITY
OF COMMUNITIES. IN FACT THE
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT PROCESS HE'S
OUTLINED IN SB NINE TWENTY TWO
OR MORE EFFECTIVE THAN SEE WHAT
PROCESSES. IT LIKE A WHOLE
COMMUNITY TO BE INVOLVED RATHER
THAN JUST PEOPLE WHO CAN AFFORD
LAWYERS. NOW IS THE TIME TO
CHANGE THE WAY WE BUILD
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS AND ALLOW AGENCIES TO
DO WHAT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF OUR ENVIRONMENT. OUR
RESIDENTS AND VISITORS ALIKE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
I HEARD HER AYE VOTE. ON SB NINE
TWENTY TWO. THANK MISTER. I
THINK YOU MISSED CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF IS MICHAEL ON BEHALF
OF THE L. A. K. METRO TRIP
AUTHORITY OF DIRECTORS ME LIKE
THAT. THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH THIS THINGS WE FOR- CA TO
WORK WITH. AS A PART THIS NORTH
COLLABORATION SB NINE TWENTY TWO
WILL KEEP IN PLACE THEN
COMPLETELY EXEMPTIONS THAT WILL
HELP US EXPAND OUR BUS RPID
TRANSIT NETWORK BUT ALSO HELP US
CONVERT THE STATE'S LARGEST
ATHLETE TWO ZERO MISSION THE
BILL WILL ALSO ALLOW US TO
EXPAND OPTIONS- FOR BIKING AND
PEDESTRIAN ACCESS OPTIONS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THESE PROJECTS
ALL REDUCE CONGESTION IMPROVE
OUR AIR QUALITY THE MOST
IMPORTANTLY GIVE US ALL A CHANCE
TO GIVE ANGELENOS A CHANCE. TO
GET OT OF THEIR CARS AND FIND
ANOTHER WAY TO GET AROUND TOWN
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR WORKING WITH US AND- WE LOOK
FORWARD AND I WOULD URGE THE
COMMITTEE. TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MICHAEL. OKAY APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR INPUT. ONE WEEK NOW OPEN UP
THE FLOOR TO FOLKS WHO WANT TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT HIM OUT
HERE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
CENTER WHERE THIS MICROPHONE
WORKS A LITTLE BETTER ACCESS TO
SHORT. MATT ROBINSON ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT WERE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE LEGISLATION I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR HE
STOPPED GENEVIEVE AND THE STAFF
TO KNOW FOR ALL THE WORK THEY'VE
BEEN PUTTING IN ON THIS BILL.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS UP
UNTIL THIS MORNING- AND AGAIN-
DRIVER THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WE
DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
TODAY ABOUT A WEEK AGO THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE TO TAKE A
SUPPORT POSITION ON THE BILL SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING A
FORMAL POSITION VERY SOON IN
SUPPORT. VETERANS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR- NICOLO DELUCA
BEHALF OF THIS CITY OF BERKLEY
IN THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
SCIENCES IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MARIN CHAIRS
MEMBERS OF PERSONAL COULD ALSO
BE HAVE A LAWCENTER CITY MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI IN SUPPORT. A GOOD
MORNING SEE WHAT CAN BE AFTER
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
RECORDED TRANSPORTATION. THE
ARMY TO CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT- THE NAPA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND THE
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IN OKAY- I
KNOW THE PRESENCE OF A QUORUM
WHY DON'T WE- TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SERGEANT THURMOND
GENEVIEVE BY WITH YOU IN MIND TO
PLEASE ONE PLACE- CALL THE- ROLE. ALAN HERE. EIGHT ALI YOU'RE A
GONZALEZ SKINNER STERN HERE ARE
CASTING HERE OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE. INDULGES
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WHO WANT TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER MOON DOUBLE
PUBLIC IF IT'S NOT ALREADY DONE
SO FAST ONE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE'S
KEYPAD WELL PRETTY WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER YOUR
LINE NUMBER CALLED THE STATE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION. FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE RECORD AND WE'LL
START WITH LINE NUMBER THIRTY
NINE LINE THIRTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING MR KAREN MEMBERS AREN'T
ABLE PAIR REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. MAX'S ONE FORTY THREE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. SORRY ONE FORTY
THREE ONE MOMENT LOOKING BACK
WITH. ONE FORTY FIVE GO AHEAD
WILL COME BACK LINE FORTY THREE
ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS AND THAT
THE CONSOLIDATES WITH
CHRISTIANITY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE TAGS IN SUPPORT
OF NINETY NINE TWENTY TWO THANK
YOU.
I'M STE I NEED A NICE YEAH. OKAY
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. I THOUGHT
THIS IS. ALTHOUGH. ARE THERE ANY
MORE WITNESSES MURDER. NO
WITNESSES WATER IT NO MODERATOR
ZERO THERE ARE THERE ARE
WITNESSES TO THAT POINT TWENTY
SEVEN GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. MISTER GENEROUSLY OF.
I'M SORRY- HE LOOKED UP. HE
KILLED HURTING ON BEHALF OF THE
VALLEY INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION WITH SUPPORT SB NINE
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. OUR NEXT WITNESSES LINE
NUMBER SIXTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
BEEN HELD SHALL YOU INTO
SCHMELZER LAYING HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON BREED
SLUGS MODERATELY ATTRACTIVE IN
SUPPORT RIGHT UP. THE LINE FORTY
THREE LINE IS NOW OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF
OF SAMBAR ANDY OKAY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND
SACRIFICE AT LEAST THIRTY OR-
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MESSALINA BIRTH M. LINE TANGLED
UP THIS. GOOD MORNING ALLEN AND
IN THE PULLS UP BE HAPPY OUR WAY
THRILLED BECAUSE AND SUPPORT
NINE TWO THANKS WE FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. NINE TWO. THANK YOU
AN ESSENTIAL FOR FOUR GO TO USE
. AND GOOD MORNING TERM ALAN AND
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
CUYLER WALKER CALL BEHALF OF THE
METROPOL TRANSIT COMMISSION
SPONSORED OF S. B. NINE TWENTY
TWO THANK YOU FOR MUCH.
MESSALINA BEFORE TWO. I DIDN'T
THIS IS STUART COHEN ON BEHALF
OF TRANSFORM WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT. A NICE LINE THIRTY ONE
YEAR OPEN GOING ON. GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND A TEAM
MEMBER MY NAME IS DANNY TORONTO
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CLIMATE PLAN AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB NINE
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU.
NONALIGNED NUMBER TWENTY SIX
POINT TWENTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE
. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATIE
MURRAY I REPRESENT THE NORTH BAY
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND WE'RE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF NINE TWENTY TWO
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY ONE
AIRLINES OPEN GLORIA. GOOD
MORNING HAPPY MONDAY JERRY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RYAN JOY
CALLING ON BEHALF. VIEW OF
CALIFORNIANS NEED TO SUPPORT SB
NINE TWENTY YEAH THANK YOU.
MAKSOUD LINE NUMBER TWENTY THREE
WATER PLEASE. SHARE MEMBERS
TRUMP'S WALKS ON ON BEHALF OF
BART THE BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND THAT'S WHERE MY NUMBER FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
SHOULD BE A MATTER OF THE EAST
BAY TRANSIT RIDERS UNION AND
SUPPORT. LINE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT FORTY EIGHT- OPEN PLEASE
GO TO. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ANDREW THOMAS OF THE CALIFORNIA
DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE TWENTY
TWO. THANK YOU. FIVE MINUTES
FROM LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO ONE
TWENTY TO GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING I'M WILL KRIEGER ON
BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. I'M NOT
SURE THAT LINE NUMBER FORTY ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
SHARON MEMBERS THIS IS MARK FOR
EXCELLENCE FROM STREETS FOR ALL
CALLING IN SUPPORT. OUR NEXT ONE
IS MY NUMBER NINETEEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. BAKER GROUP WHAT
PRACTICAL SPONSOR SB NINE TWENTY
TWO WE WANT TO THANK STAFF FOR
ALL THE WORK ON THIS AND
ENCOURAGE YOUR EYEBALLS-
EXTREMITIES FROM ONE FIFTY THREE
FIVE THREE WHO'S GOING TO. YEAH
MORNING JULIE MALINOWSKI BOTTLE
AND THEY HAVE BEEN ADMITTED INTO
THE REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. IT'S GOT A LINE
FIFTY FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS INCLUDES. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS- WHO
ONCE IT WAS THERE ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO COME IN AND TESTIFY
WITH A CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OR OPPOSITION- WE DID HAVE A
LETTER WITH STAFF FOR THE SIERRA
CLUB WERE WORKING ON A NUMBER OF
THE- AND THE NUMBER I THINK OF
NUMBER THE CRITICAL ISSUES HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED BY THE- BY THE-
AMEND STUFF BUT NOT ALL BUT-
BUT- I MIGHT EVEN GO SO FAR AS
HIS MOST- ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
EXPRESS CONCERNS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR. ONE
EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU HAVE NOT
DONE SO YET FIRST ONE ZERO FOUR
COMMENTS. AND WE HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP THE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
AIRLINES OPEN. GOOD MORNING
KAREN MEMBERS DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
WE CURRENTLY HAVE BEEN ABOUT THE
NINTH AMENDED PETITION ON THE
BALLOT PRINT BUT WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH DOCTORS OFFICE THE
BILL SPONSORS AND THE COMMITTEE
TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS. PART
OF THE BELT CALLS TO REDUCE THE
ANTI AND INCENTIVIZE ACTOR
TRANSPORTATION AND TRANSIT. WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
EXEMPTIONS ARE AND IN A WAY THAT
ACCOMPLISHES THESE CALLS WITHOUT
HAVING UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
AND THAT STILL ALLOWS PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AND TRANSPARENCY
IT APPEARS THAT AMEND THE
AMENDMENT. TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THEM AND MARK DETAIL
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE THE
CHAIR AND THE SPONSORS BURKE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MISTER SURE OF NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTERS IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THE MATTER IS NOW
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE ETCETERA
CASKEY. SO MR CHURTON AND A
CENTER WIENER I'M LOOKING AT
PAGE EIGHT OF THE STAFF REPORT
MAY TALK ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
PROJECTS CAN HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF LIGHT RAIL MAY CAUSE
ADVERSE- NOISE AND AIR QUALITY
PUTTING IN BIKE LANES MAY IMPEDE
THE DRIVER'S VISIBILITY THEN IT
POPS DOWN TO THE NEXT PAGE AND
NINE. SUBTITLE SIX ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PLAN SOME
PEDESTRIANS AND YOU KNOW THE I
SEE THE NEW AMENDMENTS THAT JUST
WAS HANDED THIS MORNING TO FIND
PEDESTRIAN PLAN. AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PLAN WHICH VERY
GOOD THEN THESE TALK ABOUT
SACRAMENTO HE JUST HAS A DRAFT
ACT ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PLAN
THE- BAY AREA METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION IS IN THE PROCESS
OF DEVELOPING WANTS TO THERE
AREN'T REALLY THESE. ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PLANS. AROUND ME
PEOPLE FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT BUT
THEY DON'T REALLY HELP TO FIND
THEN YOU'RE A THIRD COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NUMBER SIX IT SPECIFIES
THAT. ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PLANS END OF THIS YEAR PLANS IS
NOW DEFINED. ARE NOT ARE STILL
SUBJECT TO SEQUEL AND LESS A
SEPARATE APPLE POOL EXEMPTION
APPLIES. SO WHAT'S NEXT WHAT'S
LEFT IF YOU'VE NOW DEFINED THE
PLANS WE DON'T REALLY HAVE THESE
PLANS BUT THEN PEOPLE WOULD
APPLY SEPARATELY FROM. UNLESS
YOU GOT IN ANOTHER EXEMPTION
THAT IS NOT BEFORE US TODAY.
WHAT WOULD BE THE CHANGE IN THE
CURRENT LAW I MEAN IF WE HAVE AN
EXEMPTION THAT WOULD APPLY
DIDN'T WITH WHAT WE NEED THIS
BILL I'M GONNA MISTER CHAIRMAN
IF I MAY HAVE MISTER ROBINSON.
JR. FELL ON. SO ED CENTER
BECAUSE HE'S I UNDERSTAND THE
AMENDMENT THAT'S BEING PROPOSED
THEY TO BE PLANNED THE PLASTER
PLANS THOSE ARE PROGRAMMATIC
LEVEL DOCUMENTS MEETING THEY'RE
GONNA DESCRIBE ANY AN ARRAY OF
PROJECTS RIGHT THAT THE
COMMUNITY MAY WISH TO UNDERTAKE
AT SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE. AND
I BELIEVE WHAT COMMITTEE STAFF
IS REALLY GREAT TO IS THAT
THAT'S FINE BUT YOU MAY STILL
HAVE INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS THAT
YOU DO DOWN THE ROAD THAT ARE
ONE OF THE SPECIFIC EXEMPTIONS
LISTED IN NINE TWENTY TWO AND
THAT PROJECT WOULD REQUIRE OF
FUTURE SECRET ALICE IN LESS IT
WAS IN. THE PROJECTS IDENTIFIED
BY THE BILL. THAT MAKES SENSE-
THE- IT. IS IN THE PLAY. IT
WOULD NOT REQUIRE. FOR THE
SEQUEL I GUESS I WOULD LOOK AT
IT TWO WAYS OF IN THE PLAN AND
IT'S ALL OUR LIST OF STATUTORILY
EXEMPTED PROJECTS THEN IT'S FINE
BUT IF IT IF IT DIDN'T MAKE THE
LIST OF THE PROJECTS
SPECIFICALLY LISTED THE TYPES I
SHOULD FACE PATHETICALLY
LISTENING NINE TWENTY TWO. THEN
YOU WOULD NEED FOR THE FUTURE
SEQUENCES THAT MAKE SENSE RIGHT
SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THAT IF
WHO KNOWS WHAT SACRAMENTO'S
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PLAN IS
BUT IF THEY CHOSE TO LOOK AT
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS AND SAY THIS
IS THIS IS WHAT OUR PLAN IS
VERSUS A CITY WIDE. ROLLING AND
BIKING AND WALKING BACK TO
TRANSPORTATION PLAN THEY. WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO SEE WHAT WHAT. NO
DATE THE PLAN WOULD NOT WOULD
NOT BE EFFECTIVE THE PROJECT AND
I JUST WANT PLANTS OPERATED
INDIVIDUAL PROJECT WITH A KIND
OF PROJECT ENUMERATED IN NINE
TWENTY TWO IT WOULD NOT BE I
GUESS I GUESS MY POINT IS THAT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THESE LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION TYPES ARE DOING
RIGHT I MEAN THEY MAY PUT THE
TITLE. ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PLAN AND IN ALL HAS A BUNCH OF
PROJECTS IN IT. BUT IF THOSE
PROJECTS OR NOT. THE KIND
INCLUDED IN OUR TWENTY TWO IT
WOULD NOT BE. NINE TWENTY TWO IS
SPECIFIC ABOUT WHAT KINDS OF
PROJECTS ARE INCLUDED. IF THEY
PUT SOME RANDOM PROJECT IN
THAT'S NOT PART OF THAT THAT
WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT TO THE
EXEMPTION BUT OKAY SO PEDESTRIAN
PLAN NOW TO FIND UNDER THE NEW
AMENDMENTS WOULD BE A PLAN
DEVELOPED BY LOCAL JURISDICTION
THAT ESTABLISH A COMPREHENSIVE
COORDINATED APPROACH. TO
IMPROVING PEDESTRIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SAFETY OF
SACRAMENTO'S. ACTIVE PROPOSED
ACTORS AFTER TRANSPORTATION PLAN
DOES THAT BEEN THERE THERE THERE
BUT IF THERE ARE. ACTIVE PLAN
WHATEVER THE NEWSPAPER SAYING
INCLUDES A BUNCH OF INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS THAT SAY WE'RE GOING TO
SCOOP THEM UP. THEN I WOULD
THINK THAT PARAGRAPH SIX WOULD
SAY IF UNLESS ANOTHER SEQUEL
EXEMPTION APPLIES. YOU'RE NOT
COVERED. I MEAN AAIN I JUST GOT
THIS THIS MORNING SO I APOLOGIZE
YEAH I'M JUST TRYING TO MAKE
SURE I KNOW WHAT I'M VOTING ON
LET ME TRY TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE-
AND MAYBE THAT'LL SO LET'S SAY
IN THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PLAN IT SAID WE WANT TO ADD.
BIKE LANES TO. BAKER STREET
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO IN ORDER TO
RESTRICT THE PAVEMENT TO ADD
THOSE BIKE LANES. THAT SPECIFIC
PROJECT ITSELF IS COVERED UNDER
THE EXEMPTIONS IN THE BILL.
LET'S SAY THAT PLAN ALSO SAID.
AND WE WANT TO BUILD A BRAND NEW
. BIKE PATH THROUGH FARMLAND.
THAT ISN'T CURRENTLY IN THE
PUBLIC RIGHT AWAY AND IS A MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WITH A BRIDGE
OVER A CREEK. THAT WOULD STILL
REQUIRE FURTHER SEQUIN HOUSES
BECAUSE IT'S NOT AN EXEMPTION
SPECIFIED IN THE BILL DOES THAT
MAKE SENSE. YEAH I MEAN I THINK.
THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A PROJECT ON A PLAN AND AN H.
JURISDICTIONS HAS A VERY LIBERAL
APPLICATION OF WHAT THEY THINK A
PLAN IS VERSUS A PROJECT. NO THE
OLD FASHIONED PROJECTS. I THINK
I UNDERSTOOD WHAT THAT WAS SO
I'M GONNA. AND JUST. ANYTHING
THAT WAS MY QUESTION IS IT JUST
JUST SEEMS TO BE THAT WE'RE ONE
WE DON'T HAVE THESE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PLANS THAT EXIST
TWO PEOPLE ARE DEVELOPING RIGHT
NOW IN AND THEN WE'RE HAVING
RIGHT NOW WE'RE DEFINING THEM
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN STATE
STATUTE RIGHT YEAH AND SO IT'S
NOT LIKE IT'S BODIES AGREE SO
WHAT THEY ARE BUT THREE THREE
FOR THE FIRST OF ALL IN TERMS OF
WHAT ATP IS ARE WE HIGH IF YOU
LOOK AT WHO'S SPONSORING THE
BILL AND WHOSE ENGAGE IN THIS
BILL IT'S EXACTLY THE ENTITIES
THAT ARE CREATING THOSE. PLANS
SO IT'S NOT LIKE WE'RE JUST
RANDOMLY CREATING- AND THEN
EVERYONE'S GONNA HAVE TO LIVE
WITH ITS BEING THIS IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT DOES EXIST AND
YES WE'RE GONNA WILL BE GREAT TO
WORK TO BRING A PUT A SPECIFIC
DEFINITION IN THE BILL- AND I
THINK RECORDS THAT'S OVERDUE BUT
IN THE END A SPECIFIC PROJECT IF
THEY'RE NOT THE TYPE OF PROJECT
ENCOMPASSED BY NINE TWENTY TWO
AND THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE BUILDING
A BIKE LANE THROUGH THAT'S NOT
ON THE EXISTING RIGHT AWAY THAT
WOULD NOT BE COVERED BY THE BILL
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S AN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. PLAN IN NUMBER
THREE THE TERMS. IS TASK IS.
PROVIDE THE FROM THAT WE'VE- NO
AND IT SAYS IT'S A- SO THAT
LOCAL. COULD BE. THE MTC IN THE
BAY. OR COULD BE CITY AND CAL OF
SAN FRAN. FOUR AND ALL THAT DOES
IS IT PROMOTE AND- TO CHOOSING.
TO CHOOSE WALKING BIKING ROLLING
STOCK THROUGH CREATION OF A SAFE
OF. A FOR A COMFORTABLE A
CONNECTION AND ACCESSIBLE
ROLLING. ARE WALKING ROLLING AND
BIKING NETWORK SO IF YOU HAVE.
THE IT SEEMS TO ME THAT YOU IF
YOU HAVE MEANS SOME CITIES AND
I'M- FROM FREMONT THEY HAVE A
BIKE. NETWORK RIGHT SO THAT
WOULD BE. THE IF THEY CAME IN
AND SAID THIS IS NOW GOING TO BE
OUR ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PLAN-
THAT WHOLE THING ILL BE
CORPORATE RIGHT WELL THREE. TO
BE CLEAR WENT UP LIKE THAT. SB
TWENTY BUILT ON EXISTING ORDER
ALREADY EXEMPTIONS FOR BIKE
LANES BIKE NETWORKS SATURDAY
WITH I WAS AND WE BALLOT TIED.
WITH THAT IN THE BILL- BUT THAT
ALREADY RIGHT THAT'S THAT'S SIX
THAT'S WHAT I GOT THIS THAT'S
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR IS WHAT'S
THAT. NEW STUFF THAT'S COMING IN
FOR ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION OR
PEDESTRIAN PLANS. BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT WE'RE THERE'S A WHOLE
SERIES OF THEM SUCH. A BAD IDEA
TO EIGHTY EIGHT ALREADY
EFFECTIVELY A CALL LIKE A
COMPASS TO ALL THAT I THINK WILL
BE MORE SPECIFIC IN DEFINING IT.
IN THIS BILL SO IT'S TIGHTENING
MAKING MORE CLEAR WAS ALREADY AN
INTEGRATED. THANK. YOU MISTER.
AND GIVING IT A LONGER. SUNSET
YEAH YEAH. OKAY BUT CERTAINLY IF
YOU GOT. CAN ARE ADDITIONALLY
THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE TO
TIGHTEN THROUGH THE PROCESS I
LOVE TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS
UNDER. I SENT DOLLY. THANK YOU I
JUST WANT TO. HAVE SOME KIND. I
FIRST I KNOW YOU DO WORK IN THE
AREA AND I. TYPICALLY AGREE WITH
WHAT YOUR GOAL IS BUT- I'M I'M
HAVING A MAYBE A LITTLE.
EXPANDED MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE
ON WHAT. SENATOR WIENER WAS
TALKING ABOUT IS THAT YOU KNOW
IT CAN BE ENVIRONMENT PROJECT
LOOK WITH THIS IS GOOD TO GET
PEOPLE OFF OF THE- TO DO
DIFFERENT CUT TYPES OF TRANSIT
WHERE WE CAN MOVE PEOPLE. IN A
MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
WAY BUT SEQUEL WAS. DEVELOPED
FOR. TO MAKE SURE THAT IMPACTS
WERE MET SO SOME COMMUNITY GETS
IMPACT IN A DIFFERENT WAY YOU
HAVE TO ADDRESS THOSE IMPACTS
AND SO. WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THE-
WATERING DOWN OF SECRET FOR.
CERTAIN CARVED OUT PROJECTS AND
TYPICALLY I HAVE SUPPORT OF
THOSE BECAUSE I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE. MAYBE A- DEEPER
CONVERSATION ABOUT SEQUEL AND
NOT JUST IN THESE AREAS WHERE WE
HAVE- MAYBE IT'S MAYBE IT'S THE-
KINGS ARENA OR IT'S- SOME OTHER
INFILL PROJECT THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO. BASICALLY PROMOTE BUILDING
THROUGH EASING OF REGULATIONS SO
IN THIS CASE. THERE'S A%
STATEWIDE THIS ISN'T A CARVED
OUT ONE PROJECT THIS IS FOR
EVERY CITY THAT HAS A TRANSIT
SYSTEM OR MAYBE A WERE ALLOWING
SECRET EXEMPTIONS AND SO WHEN
THERE'S IMPACTS HOW DOES IMPACTS
GET DEALT WITH UNDERNEATH THE
LAW BECAUSE THERE IS NO NOW
YOU'RE EXEMPTING THOSE. YEAH SO
A COUPLE OF THINGS AND I WOULD
SAID I THINK THAT THE ARGUMENT-
CENTER THAT YOU'RE MAKING
ACTUALLY. MEANS THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING YOU SHOULD SUPPORT
BECAUSE I CAN UNDERSTAND I
UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION WHEN
A SPECIFIC PROJECT GETS
ACCELERATOR CARD THAT USE YOUR
SPORTS ARENA- I YOU KNOW I'VE
I'VE SUPPORTED- THOSE BUT I
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW I THOUGHT
FRUSTRATIONS ABOUT WAY WHY ARE
WE STREAMLINING SPORTS ARENA BUT
NOT HOUSING AND WE CAN AND-
THOSE ARE SUBJECT TO CRITICISM
WHATEVER ONE'S VIEW. THIS IS NOT
DOT THIS IS A STATWIDE POLICY
THAT CITIES CAN AND TRANSIT
AGENCIES CAN USE OR NOT USE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO EVER IN BOCA AND
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT THIS IS
DEMOCRACY BECAUSE THAT MEANS THE
CITY COUNCIL OR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OR TRANSIT BOARD CAN
MAKE THEIR DECISION ABOUT WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO. AND IF YOU HAVE
ONE NEIGHBOR WHO'S UPSET ABOUT
IT AND THEN FILES A SEQUEL
LAWSUIT THERE ARE GONNA BE ABLE
TO DO THAT SO I THINK THIS IS A
THIS IS PROMOTING. DEMOCRACY AND
ALLOW AND A CITY CAN IGNORE IT
SO WE DON'T WANNA PUT BIKE LANES
AND WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE YOUR
BUS SERVICE IN THIS AREA THEY
MAKE THAT DECISION UNDER THE
BROWN ACT AND UNDER DEMOCRATIC
PRINCIPLES SO YOU KNOW I LISTEN
I WAS YOU KNOW I I'VE MADE
COMMENTS ON THE SENATE FLOOR IN
RECENT WEEKS ABOUT. THAT THERE
ARE SOME STRUCTURAL CHALLENGES I
THINK AND SEE WHAT IN THAT
SEQUENCE TO BE MORE FOCUSED YOU
KNOW TO ALSO MAKE SURE IT'S
ALWAYS CONTEMPLATING CLIMATE
CHANGE- BY THE DOCTORS. AS YOU
KNOW THAT IS A- THERE'S A BIG.
ISSUE AND IT AND IT'S CONTRA. ON
HOPEFULLY IT'LL HAPPEN SOME
POINT. BUT I DO. THAT THERE ARE
CERTAIN PROJECTS THAT ARE THAT
ARE CURRENTLY ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY IN THE CITY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
WELL I 100% AGREE IN THOSE
DECISIONS TO BE MADE BUT SEEK
WAS A STATEWIDE LAW. YEAH IT IS
NOT IT IS NOT THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OR- THE CITY COUNCIL
DOESN'T GET TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER C. BECAUSE IT IMPLIED OR
NOT UNLESS WE ALLOW THEM THROUGH
LAW THROUGH LEGISLATION WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE ATTEMPTING
TO DO RIGHT NOW. AND SO. I THINK
THE BGGER CONCERN IS THAT. IS
THAT IS SEQUEL. REALLY
LEGITIMATE OR IS IT BEEN ABUSED
AND I THINK THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE ABUSES OF SEQUEL- I
ACTUALLY LIKE TO SEE WHAT I
THINK IS A GOOD LAW. BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS PEOPLE WHO ARE IMPACTED
BY DEVELOPMENT TO BE. YEAH
MITIGATION AND TO BE MADE AT
LEAST SOMEWHAT HOLE. FOR THEIR
IMPACTS AND SO WE CONTINUE TO GO
DOWN THE ROAD OF. CARVING OUT
FOR THE THINGS WE CARE ABOUT OR
THE OR THE ABILITY TO GET A LAW
PASSED THROUGH THIS. THROUGH
THIS LEGISLATURE. I THINK WE
REALLY SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT THE
SEQUENCE ALL AND I KNOW YOUR SAY
WELL THAT DOESN'T TO PERTAIN TO
THIS BILL. IT DOES BECAUSE WE
JUST CONTINUE TO NOT HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT SEQUEL. AND
THAT ONE PERSON WITH THE-
ATTORNEY OR ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
WITH ATTORNEY OR BUSINESS WITH
AN ATTORNEY THAT WANTS TO SONST
SUIT AND STOP A PROJECT HE SAID
THAT IN YOU'RE- ACTUALLY IN
YOUR- THE- PRESENTATION OF YOUR
BILL. SO THIS IS GONNA ALLOW
THAT ATTORNEY OR THAT LOCAL
GROUP NOT TO BE ABLE TO SUE IN
THE SITUATIONS IN THE PROJECTS
ARE GOING TO GO FORWARD. SO IT'S
REALLY ADVERTING THE LAW. AND
CARVING OUT SOMETHING FOR A
STATEWIDE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
SO THAT'S MY POINT IS THAT. WE
NEED TO HAVE A LONG WE NEED TO
HAVE A BIGGER DISCUSSION ABOUT.
SOME ONE ENTITY BEING ABLE TO
STOP A PROJECT AND THAT'S QUITE
FRANKLY NOT GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT IS NOT GOOD. AND
MAINLY IN HOUSING WE NEVER HEAR
WE NEVER HEAR AN EXEMPTION
BROWSING THEY CAN'T GET OUT OF
HERE FOR SOME REASON WE NEVER
HAVE ANY WE DID IT WE DID FOR
INFILL. HOTELS I DID FEDERAL SO
THAT'S MY POINT IS THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO. KICKED THE CAN DOWN
THE ROAD AND DO ONE OFFS AND NOT
YET LEAVES POWER FOR THE
LEGISLATORS BUT IT DOESN'T
EMPOWER CALIFORNIA DRIVE THE
COST OF LIVING DOWN THERE. NICE
SO- RISK RESPECTFULLY ASK FIRST
OF ALL I I'M A BIG FAN OF NOT
MAKING THE PERFECT THE ENEMY OF
THE GOOD. AND YES THERE A LOT OF
AREAS WHERE WE SHOULD DO
STRUCTURAL I DON'T THINK. THAT
THE WHOLE SYSTEM THESE THREE
FAXES AND ARGUMENT AGAINST.
MAKING INCREMENTAL PROGRESS IF
WE CAN DO THAT'S MY PERSONAL
PERSPECTIVE- TERMS OF HOUSING WE
HAVE STREAMLINED. HOUSING THIS
COMMITTEE IS TYPICALLY THE THIRD
REFERRAL AND THE SENATE HAS NOT
BEEN HAVING HEARINGS IN THE
THIRD COMMITTEE BUT- SEVENTY TWO
COMMITTEE PROVIDES FEEDBACK
BECAUSE TYPICALLY TO HOUSING
COMMITTEE. AND GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE- STREAMLINING BILLS AND
WE PASSED. LAST YEAR SENATE BILL
NINE THAT WAS A- THAT CONTAINS
SICK WITH STREAMLINING BECAUSE
WERE FAVORING ONE DUPLEXES TO BE
BUILT- SO I UNDERSTAND. YOUR
CONCERN BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A STOP-
AND IT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP. AN
NHS. WE JUST OF THE CONVERSATION
. YOU KNOW WHAT PROJECT THIS IS
NOT AN APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARISON- YOU KNOW. WE
BUILDING A MASSIVE MANUFACTURING
PLANT. NEXT TO IT A SCHOOL IS
VERY DIFFERENT THAN BUILDING A
BIKE A BIKE LANE THE GOOD LOOK
STRIPING ST FOR BIKE LANES OR OR
OR A OF YOU KNOW- BUT WALKING
INFRASTRUCTURE A MASS TRANSIT
LINE I MEAN THESE ARE THINGS
THAT ARE SO UNEQUIVOCALLY
BENEFICIAL FOR THE ENVIRONMENT-
THEY THEY I THINK THEY MERIT A
DIFFERENT TREATMENT UNDER THE
SENATE COULD UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA VINYL QUALITY ACT
THAT'S MY- ATTITUDE THAT HAS TO
DO WITH THE TYPE OF PROJECT IN
THE TYPE OF. BENEFIT THAT IT
BRINGS TO SOCIETY AND TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT OR NOT. ALL RIGHT SO
I JUST PUT I JUST PUT THE TYPES
OF PROJECTS THAT ARE AGAIN
CONSIDERED UNDER UNDER SEQUIN
UNDER VERY DIFFERENT AND
CATEGORIES FOR CONSIDERATION AS
THE MASS TRANSIT IS A IN IN BEEN
BEEN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION IS
JUST A VERY DIFFERENT WHEN IT
COMES OF OUR MENTAL. BENEFITS
SENATOR. THANK YOU MR- IN AND I
WILL SAY THE OTHER THING IS WITH
EXCEPTIONALLY ONE BILL EVERY
HOUSING BILL THAT'S BEEN HEARD
THIS COMMITTEE ON SEA QUEST IS
GONNA COMMITTEE. SO THEY DO NOT
DIE IN HERE. OKAY SO MY
QUESTIONS ARE RELATED TO TWO
FACTORS- ONE IS HOW TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE GETTING GOOD. FOR LACK OF
BETTER WORD CROWDSOURCING OR
COMMUNITY INPUT ON THESE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PLANS ARE
PEDESTRIAN PLANS AND I WANTED TO
OFFER MAYBE A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE
AND JUST SEE HOW THE BILL MIGHT
APPLY OR MAYBE EVEN HOW THE
IMPLEMENTING AGENCIES MIGHT BE.
APPROACHING IT TO SORT OF GET A
BETTER SENSE IN MY EXPERIENCE
WE'VE ACTUALLY GOT A REALLY GOOD
OUTCOMES FOR PROJECTS- THAT SAY
THE ENGINEERS AT DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION OR CALTRANS FOR
PLANTING THE MEAT OUT OF THIS
REALLY APPROACH- PURSUITS ATP
GOALS ARE V. M. T. REDUCTION
GOALS ARE GHG REDUCTION GOALS.
BUT- BUT WHEN WE KIND OF GOT
THAT OUT IN THE PUBLIC SPACE
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO REALIZE
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES THAT SORT OF
INTUITIVELY THE COMMUNITY
UNDERSTOOD THE MAYBE THE
ENGINEERS DIDN'T UNDERSTAND. SO
EXAMPLE IS THE STREET OVER
CROSSING IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY GOING TO BE TORN DOWN
BECAUSE IT WAS SAGGING IN GOING
TO HIT THE FREEWAY AND SO IS OUT
OF COMPLIANCE WITH SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS. CALTRANS IS GOING
TO- JUST TEAR DOWN THE
PEDESTRIAN OVER CROSSING AND-
HADN'T BUILT INTO THAT PROJECT.
WHAT THIS SORT OF COROLLARY.
WALKING BIKING ACCESS ISSUES
TURNS OUT. TWO BLOCKS AWAY
THERE'S ANOTHER- BRIDGE THAT
COULD BE UTILIZED BUT WE COULD
MAYBE TAKE SOME. SHOP FUNDS
RATHER EIGHTY P. FUNDS IN SORT
OF UPGRADE. THAT NEIGHBORING
STREET AND SORT OF GET BETTER
OUTCOMES MAYBE ON BOTH FRONTS.
THAT ALL CAME OUT THROUGH THE- I
GUESS THROUGH THE SEQUEL PROCESS
REALLY AND IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
BECAUSE IT WAS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT WAS EVALUATED PER SE. BUT
MORE OF A THROUGH THAT NOTICE
PROCESS NOT- THOSE COMMENTS WILL
BE ABLE TO BE ACCEPTED- AND WE
WERE ABLE TO FIND SORT OF. MORE
CREATIVE- YOU KNOW THE MORE
PROGRESSIVE OUTCOMES SO I'M
WONDERING. I KNOW METROS ONE OF
THE SPONSORS. I DON'T THINK THIS
IS WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
THOSE ARE MORE CALTRANS PROJECTS
AS PEDESTRIAN OVER CROSSING
PROJECTS BUT- TRYING TO GET A
SENSE FOR HOW. ON THE GROUND
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD WORK IN
THAT KIND OF CASE CONSUMIR THIS
. THIS BILL DOES NOT TAKE AWAY
THE ABILITY TO HOLD COMMUNITY
MEETINGS AND SOGDIAN EXAMPLE
WHEN I WAS ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SAN FRANCISCO WE
DID. SOME MAJOR FLIGHT UPGRADES
AND PART OF. A PART PARTS OF A
DISTURBING ACCOUNT CUSTOMER
MARKET AREA IN GLEN PARK IN SOME
OTHER AREAS. WE WERE NOT
REQUIRED TO HOLD COMMUNITIES
SEEK WITH THE NOT REQUIRED AT
ALL. WE HELD COMMUNITY MEETINGS
A COMMUNITY THREATS TO GET
BECAUSE THAT'S LIKE. THE GOOD
THING AND RIGHT THING TO DO WHEN
YOU'RE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT. AND
YOU KNOW I WOULDN'T WANT TO JUST
GOING OUT AND PUT THAT OUT THERE
WITHOUT TALKING TO MY
CONSTITUENTS AND GETTING. THEIR
FEEDBACK. HI AND I AGREE HAVING
THOSE MEETINGS WHEN YOU'RE A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS IMPORTANT
AND IF YOU'RE CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS- LOCAL OFFICIALS ARE
LIKE NOT ENGAGING WITH THE
PUBLIC. THEY SHOULD BE THROWN
OUT OF OFFICE THAT'S DEMOCRACY
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT DOING THEIR
JOBS- BUT WHEN YOU BRING
SEQUENCES IT DOESN'T REQUIRE
COMMUNITY MEETINGS. BUT WHAT IT
DOES DO IS IT ALLOWS PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT REPRESENTATIVE TO
COMMUNITY. TO DELAY OR KILL YOUR
PROJECTS WE RESULT IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE OUR BIKE PLAN.
GOT SUED UNDERSEA QUOTE NOT FOR
ANY ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS BUT
FOR THE REASONS THAT PEOPLE
DON'T WANT TO PROMOTE BIKING I
GOT HELD UP AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT CREATED THE
SEQUEL EXEMPTION. FOR BIKE
LANES- AND SO I YOU KNOW I THINK
WE NEED TO YOU KNOW. FOCUS ON
LIKE HAVING GOOD LOCAL
DEMOCRACY. AND YOU CAN NOTHING
SICKLE REQUIRES COMMUNITY
MEETINGS AND NOTHING THIS WILL
NOT TAKE AWAY THE ABILITY TO
HAVE COMMUNITIES REQUIRES A FOR
LARGER PROJECTS- BUT OF COURSE.
LOCAL OFFICIALS SHOULD ALWAYS BE
ENGAGING WITH THE COMMUNITY AS A
MATTER OF BASIC DEMOCRACY THEY
SHOULD BE THROWN OUT OF OFFICE
WHO CAN I ASK I DON'T KNOW IF
ONE OF THE SPONSORS ON THE LINE
OR- MISS ROBIN CENTER WHO'S
RIGHT FROM THE LINE BUT JUST.
THE INTENT OF METRO AND HOW THEY
PLAN TO PURSUE THIS LIKE YEAH IS
THAT BECAUSE IT'S AN OPTION ARE
THEY INTENDING. TO IMPLEMENT.
OUR DOCTOR PLAN THAT THE WAY. I
MEAN. BECAUSE IT'S JUST. NOW
WITH THIS IN AND WE WERE.
REQUIRED UNLESS YOU OVER A
HUNDRED. IT WOULD HAVE TO KNOW
YEAH AND SO MISTER TURNER IS ON
THE LINE FROM ELEMENTARY YEAH.
YES THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER US
MICHAEL TURNER FROM ELLIE MET
FROM WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PROJECTS
THAT WE PURSUE THAT ARE. ORISHA
SHOULD SAY WERE EXEMPT UNDER-
LITTLE SEQUEL BEFORE SB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT- EVER EXISTED AND
WE HAVE ALWAYS PURSUED VERY
AGGRESSIVE COMMUNITY OUT REACH
ON THOSE TYPES OF PROJECTS- FOR
EXAMPLE ONE OF THE PROJECT WE'RE
LOOKING AT- SOME BUS SPEED
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE NORTH SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. THAT WERE
EXEMPT BEFORE SB TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT EVER EXISTED AND WE HAD-
EXTENSIVE NUMBERS OF PUBLIC
MEETINGS ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT
SEQUEL WOULD HAVE EVER REQUIRED.
SO IT'S A REGULAR PRACTICE HERE
FOR US TO ENGAGE IN VERY
EXTENSIVE COMMUNITY OUTREACH.
BUT REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE
SEQUEL REQUIREMENTS ARE DO YOU
MIND IF I ASK ARE YOU BOUND TO
THAT REGULAR PROCESSES THAT JUST
SORT OF A MATTER OF PRACTICE OR
IS THE- IS THE INTENTION SAY OF
METRO I MEAN I THINK OF THEM THE
BIG METRO. PROJECT AND IS IN THE
NORTH SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WORK
IS THE ORANGE LINE SO FOR SO YOU
WERE ONLY DOING ONE OVER
CROSSING RIGHT NOT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT BUT A-
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR- OVER
CROSSING WHICH WE WANT TO SEE. A
LOT MORE THOSE AND SORT OF GET
THAT THAT BRT LINE GOING. BUT
LIKE DOES THAT. WITH IF THIS
BILL WERE LAW. WOULD YOU WHAT
WOULD YOU HAVE TO DO WHAT WOULD
YOU HAVE TO DO UNDER METRO'S
CURRENT SORT OF. PROCESS FOR A
PROJECT LIKE THAT. WELL I THINK
WHAT I'D SAY IS THAT IF WE WANT
THE PROJECT TO SUCCEED IN AS
SENATOR WIENER MENTIONED IF YOU
WANT THE PROJECT TO BE ACCEPTED
IN THE COMMUNITY BE SUCCESSFUL
YOU HAVE TO HAVE COMMUNITY BUY
IN- YOU KNOW SEE WHAT HAS SOME
VERY SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS
RELATED TO HEARINGS AND- SCOPING
SESSIONS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
BUT WHAT WE'VE FOUND IS THE ON
GOING- LADY COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT IN A PROJECT IN
CONSENSUS BUILDING AROUND THAT
PROJECT IS WHAT ULTIMATELY
GAMES- THE ACCEPTANCE. SO IT IS
SOMETHING WE DO ON YOU KNOW OUR
MAJOR PROJECTS FROM THINGS LIKE
SIMPLE TO PASS ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO- THINGS THAT YOU KNOW SMALL
PEDESTRIAN CROSSINGS- THROUGHOUT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BUT IT DO DO
DO BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO OR
BECAUSE IT'S A GOOD WAY TO MAKE
POLICY I'M JUST WONDERING IF
YOU'RE OBLIGATED TO DO SO IF YOU
WOULD HAVE THE DISCRETION
WHETHER OR NOT TO TALK TO THE
COMMUNITY ABOUT IT. IN THEORY ON
ONE OF THEIR THERE L. WITH
OTHERS THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED AT
ALL BUT THEY THEY ARE I WOULD
SAY THEY ARE NECESSARY IN ORDER
TO GET A PROJECT TO BE ACCEPTED
AND SUCCESSFUL IN THE COMMUNITY
DID YOU COULD ARGUE THAT IF YOU
DON'T DO THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THAT KIND OF CONSENSUS BUILDING
THAT'SONE OF THE FACTORS THAT
LEADS TO LAWSUITS UNDER CEQA
WRIT THAT WITHOUT ANY RECOURSE
FOR A LAWSUIT UNDER SEEK WITH.
AND WITHOUT ANY HARD REQUIREMENT
THAT YOU HAVE THAT INTERFACE
INTERIOR AGENCY COULD CONSTRUCT
A YOU KNOW A NINETY NINE MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT AND NOT HAVE ANY
COMMUNITY MEETINGS OR TAKE ANY
PUBLIC. INPUT IS NOT RIGHT UNDER
THE BILL. IN THEORY CORRECT
YEAH. BUT SOME COULD STILL
THROUGH FOR UNDER THE- UNDER THE
SEAT FROM XIN. IT WOULDN'T BE
BAY ON CERTAIN ON THE OUT. BUT
RIGHT BUT JUST AS A MATTER OF
ROSS SAYS HE WOULDN'T HAVE TO
WRITE IF I. ADD THAT. YOU KNOW I
THINK. IF IT'S GOING TO BE
EXCEPTION NOT THE RULE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO CONFRONT THE
RATE WE'RE NOT TALKING TO
ANYONE. RIGHT THERE MIGHT COULD
THERE BE A RANDOM CITY WITH WITH
THAT LOCAL OFFICIALS HAVE DUBBED
THE SURE YOU CAN ALWAYS HAVE.
BAD LOCAL OFFICIALS BUT IN MY
EXPERIENCE THAT THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN THERE'S THERE THERE IS
ENGAGEMENT. BUT AGAIN THE
DOWNSIDE OF NOT HAVING THE
EXEMPTION IS YOU HAVE A PROJECT
WE'VE ALL SEEN THIS WERE 90% THE
COMMUNITY LOVES. IT'S LIKE
BROADLY EMBRACED AND ACCEPTED.
BUT THAT ONE NEIGHBOR WHOSE VIEW
IS BEING BLOCKED BY THE
PEDESTRIAN BRIDGE OR WHATEVER
AND HAS ENOUGH MONEY TO HIRE A
LAWYER SUITS AND TIES IT UP FOR
YEARS AND WE'VE ALL SEEN THAT
HAPPEN IN OUR COMMUNITIES NOT
JUST ON THIS KIND OF ISSUE BUT
OTHERS WELL. AND SO IT'S
ALWAYS A TRADE OFF. ALWAYS A
TRADE OFF AND I DO THINK THAT
OVERWHELMINGLY- LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO TRY TO
ENGAGE THE COMMUNITIES THEY
DON'T WANT TO HAVE. PEOPLE COME
OUT PITCHFORKS AND BE FURIOUS
THAT THEY'RE DOING THIS I WANT
TO TRY TO YOU KNOW GAIN AS MUCH
ACCEPTANCE IS POSSIBLE. I WOULD
JUST ASK FOR YOUR CAN. EITHER
YOU YOURSELF IS THE AUTHOR OF
THIS OR THE SPONSORS. IF THERE'S
SOME WAY TO- ACTIVELY AFFIRM FOR
PROJECTS REGARDLESS OF SIZE SOME
KIND OF- NOTICE OBLIGATION- IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE-
EXACTLY THE PROCESS YOU YOU LAID
OUT IS THAT SORT OF ALTERNATIVE
COMMUNITY MEETING PLAN FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION PLUS PROJECTS
BUT- I'M I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO. TO DO SOME OF
THAT GOOD. TO NOT JUST MAKE IT
AN OPTION TO SORT OF GIVE YOU
SOME ASSURANCE THAT WE WILL THEN
BE THUNDERY WE WILL YOU HAVE MY
CAN AND WE WILL GIVE THAT. OKAY
ON TO DO SOME CREATIVE THINKING
OKAY REDRESS FOR CONCERN I
PROCEED TO AND THE ONLY OTHER
ONE I JUST WANTED YOU TO
CONSIDER POTENTIALLY IF THE BILL
IS FOR BEFORE THE FLOOR. I'M
MORE APPROPRIATIONS OR WHATEVER
MAY BE- IS. IN IN THE IN THE
SORT OF FACTORS ANALYSIS I KNOW
THAT RACIAL EQUITY AND
DISPLACEMENT WERE WERE
CONSIDERED WE'RE BACK TO HEAR
LEGISLATION THAT YOU TALK ABOUT
SOCIOECONOMIC IMPACTS- AS WELL
BE SORT OF A- A CONSIDERATION
GOING FORWARD. I'M JUST TRYING
TO I'M WONDERING. THE IT DOESN'T
SAY ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IT
SAYS- TO ENCOURAGE CONSIDERATION
OF ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS IN
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PLANS
INDUSTRY AND PLANS- AND THEN IT
ALSO HAS THAT SORT OF COROLLARY
PEACE AND RACIAL EQUITY AND
DISPLACEMENT- THIS. SOME
CONSIDERATION OF. SPECIFICALLY
THE ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE NOT
JUST- SEE AN ECONOMIC ONE BUT-
BUT IF THIS COMMITTEE OF THIS
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY HAS HAD IS
TAKING THE LION'S SHARE OF
INDUSTRIAL PROJECTS AND THERE'S
A WEALTHIER COMMUNITY EXTORT
THAT. HOW TO FOR SAID TO GET
FLUSHED OUT IT THIS BILL DOESN'T
INCLUDE INDUSTRIAL PROJECTS BUT
AS YOU KNOW I KNOW YOU AREN'T
SUGGESTING- BUT STILL IT'S FOR
HIGH HYDROGEN STATION OR
LICENSES TO RID RID WILL REQUIRE
COMMUTING TO TRACK AT ANY LEVEL
TO TAKE A MOMENT WORK SOMETHING
FROM THE COMMITTEES BUT WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE KINDS
OF PROJECTS SOLICITORS DOESN'T
INCLUDE DIESEL THIS IS ABOUT YOU
KNOW IT'S A FAIR INDICATOR ABOUT
CLEAN PROJECTS. AND SO THE IDEA
THAT WOULD REQUIRE SPECIFIC THAT
KIND OF CONTAMINANT IN ALICE'S-
ON EXISTING RIGHT OF WAY RIGHTS
NOT ABOUT BUILDING A NEW RIGHT
OF WAY AND SO I- YOU KNOW WE
WE'VE WHEN AT OUR OUR SPONSORS
HAVE ENGAGE ENGAGE EARLY WITH
THEIR- BUYER MENTAL JUSTICE
VIJAY COMMUNITY AND WILL
CONTINUE OF COURSE ENGAGE WITH
THEM AND WE'RE HAPPY TO YOU KNOW
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD A RACIAL EQUITY
ANALYSIS PART IN THE BILL WE'RE
WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENT TO INCLUDE
DISPLACEMENT. ANALYSIS BUT AT
SOME POINT YOU END UP CENTER
HESYCHASM SYMBOL WERE REPORTING
EVERYTHING ABOUT SEE WHAT AT
SOME POINT THAT BECOMES A
CHALLENGE AND I THINK THE RACIAL
EQUITY AND DISPLACEMENT ALICE'S
COVERS AN AWFUL LOT ABOUT ABOUT-
WHAT IN MY EXPERIENCE IS A
ORGANIZATIONS YOU KNOW BUT FOR
THAT THAT WOULD BE REASSURING I
GUESS IF WE COULD I KNOW THAT
THERE NOW IS IT DOESN'T SAY
SPELL IT OUT. BUT TO UNDERSTAND
- WHAT THE- WHAT A RACE EQUITY
ANALYSIS WITH X. ENTAIL. AND HOW
MUCH OVER THERE MY BE WITH THOSE
ENVIRONMENTAL. FOR AND WHAT
MIGHT BE LEFT OUT MAYBE IT'S NOT
A CONTAMINANT IN ALICE'S FOR
INSTANCE BECAUSE- LIKE YOU SAID
IT IS NOT REALLY GERMANE TO
THESE PROJECTS BUT- BUT- I. I
ALWAYS AM JUST CONCERNED ABOUT-
YES THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
PIECE OF IT NOT JUST AT. SOME
SORT OF RATE- INDIRECT RACIAL
IMPACT I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT
THAT WOULD EVEN LOOK AT ME BUT
IF YOU. IF YOU ARE PROJECTS
DIRECTLY THAT WAS GOING TO BE
CAUSING SOME SORT OF MASSIVE
CONTAMINATION. FLOWING ON BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES RIGHT I'M
MORE THAT WAS INVOKING SB NINE.
TWENTY TWO THAT TO ME THAT'S FOR
RACIAL EQUITY. ISSUE AND SO THAT
WOULD BE. HELLO THAT WOULD BE
PART OF THE QUESTION I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE PROJECT WILL BE
RIGHT PERSONALLY BUT IF THE
RADICALLY SPEAKING- I THINK IT.
THE SPONSORS A SENSE OR OR THE
THOSE ONLINE HAVE A SENSE OF HOW
YOU WOULD A RACIAL EQUITY OR- OR
DISPLACEMENT OUT AND ANALYSIS
MIGHT LOOK LIKE THEY WOULD COVER
SOME OF MY CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PEACE ANY
REASSURANCE TO OFFER. AT THIS
EARLY STAGE I ALSO JUST ONE NOTE
YEAH PLEASE THAT WENT ABOUT THE
AGAINST. EXISTING RIGHT AWAY I'M
PART OF THAT YES WE ARE THIS IS
NOT ALLOWING SOMEONE TO BUILD A
LIGHT RAIL LINE. THE MONEY NEW
HOMES SURE EXISTING COMMUNITY
ALL OF THE CALLS ABOUT AND IT'S
AND IT'S WRITTEN NOT BE ABOUT
THE IDEA. UNDERSTOOD BUT ANY ANY
COMMENTS EITHER I DON'T KNOW AND
YEAH PLEASE PREVENT- THAT'S
ALRIGHT WITH THE CHAIR TIMELINE
FOR THE- WE HAVE YOU- SB TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT IN ORDER EMPLOY A
JUSTICE PLANS UNDER THE BAYVIEW
COMMUNITY BASED TRANSPORTATION
PLAN AS WELL AS WORKING VERY
QUICKLY WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ADVOCATES IN THE
TENDERLOIN NEIGHBORHOOD TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CHANGING
TRAFFIC AND SAFETY CONDITIONS IN
THAT NEIGHBORHOOD TO QUICKLY
REARRANGE THE STREET. CREW AND
OF ADVOCATE- PATH BEHALF OF.
JUSTICE ORGANIZER- SO. WE EAGER
TO ADVANCE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
SEQUEL IT IS EIGHT CLUMSY AND
LEGALISTIC COOL HOWEVER IN DOING
SO. THE COMMUNICATION PROPHECIES
THAT ARE SET UP AND SEE WHAT.
OUR LEGALIST THEIR DESIGN AROUND
LEGAL DISCLOSURES AND THEY'RE
DESIGNED FOR PEOPLE WITH
LAWYERS- WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS ACTUALLY WORKING DIRECTLY
WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN ORDER TO HELP
THEM PRIORITIZE WHAT ARE THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
INVESTMENTS THAT ACTUALLY NEED
THEIR REAL NEEDS AND THEN MOVES
VERY QUICKLY AND IMPLEMENTING
THOSE- SO THE KIND OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT WORK THAT WE DO IS.
IS NOT THE KIND OF ENGAGEMENT
THAT SEQUEL- ACTUALLY FOSTERS-
AND SO WE- OR YOU TO VOTE AYE ON. NINE TWENTY TWO. TO SEE THE
URGING RIGHT NOW I PRETTY YOUR
JIM MIKE MICHAEL WAS IF YOU
WOULDN'T BE OBLIGATED UNDER THIS
BILL TO DO ANY OF THAT
ENGAGEMENT YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT
YOU COULD SKIP THAT ENGAGEMENT
IS STILL BE COMPLIANT WITH THE
LAW. COULD YOU NOT. THAT IS
CORRECT HOWEVER SEQUEL IS NOT
DESIGNED TO FOSTER THE KIND OF
ENGAGEMENT THAT IS HELPFUL TO
KNOW I APPRECIATE THAT EVEN THE-
EVEN THE COMMUNITY MEETINGS THAT
ARE OUTLINED IN THE BILL FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PLUS
PROJECTS. FOR ANYTHING SOUTH OF
THAT YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TO DO ANY
OF THAT COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT-
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ENGAGE WITH EACH OTHER AND I
MEAN WOULD YOU LIKE I WE TALK
ABOUT TWO THINGS FIRST OF ALL I
THINK YOU BROUGHT UP AN
INTERESTING IDEA OF THIS NOTICE
OBLIGATION AND THEN THERE'S THE
THRESHOLD RIGHT I MEAN- WHAT.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE SENATOR AND THE CAN THE
COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT MAYBE
LOWERING THE THRESHOLD FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THE COMMUNITY
MEETINGS- YEAH THE HEARINGS AND
JUST HOW TO ALLOW FOR THAT
DISCUSSION THAT THAT THE SENDER
SO CONCERNED ABOUT. IT BECAUSE
I'M NOT MAKING ANY COMMITMENTS
TODAY ON THE UNDERMINE WE'VE
ALREADY ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WERE HAPPY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION IT WAS OF
INDICATED. AND TALK ABOUT THAT
AND I DO HAVE MY COMMITMENT THAT
WILL. IN GOOD FAITH HAVE A
CONVERSATION. BUT I JUST WANNA
BE CLEAR I'M NOT. LETTINGS NO I
UNDERSTAND CENTER BUT IT BUT- BY
ARE YOU ARE YOU. I THINK HE'S I
IDEA OF THE YOUR WITNESS GOING
TO THE CLUB NATURE OF A SEEK BUT
I NOT SURE THE CENTERS FOR A
FULL SEQUEL A REVIEW HE'S
LOOKING FOR MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR
DITCHED A MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY
FOR PUBLIC NOTICE AN INPUT YOU
CAN CHECK MY SAN FRANCISCO WHICH
IS A VERY ACTIVE AND ENGAGED
COMMUNITY THERE A LOT OF PLACES
IN THIS IN THE STATE THAT MAYBE
AREN'T AS MUCH MAYBE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE QUITE AS A
CONSCIENTIOUS. ABOUT ENGAGING-
THE PUBLIC ON ON PROJECTS THAT
MIGHT BE CONTROVERSIAL AND I AND
ONCE AGAIN WHAT HE'S ASKING FOR
DOES NOT NOT DOESN'T ULTIMATELY
GIVE A OF A KIND OF A TRUMP CARD
TO UNTIL TO SOMEONE TO A TO A
VEXATIOUS LITIGANT WHO CAN HIRE
A LAWYER BUT BUT ULTIMATELY JUST
PROVIDES FOR AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
MEANINGFUL PUBLIC. ENGAGEMENT
INPUT IN THAT WERE WERE OPEN
THAT CONVERSATION- AND SO WORTH
IT WILL GIVE THAT SOME THOUGHT
ABOUT WHAT THAT MIGHT LOOK LIKE
I'M NOT MAKING A YEAH I
UNDERSTAND- IS ALL LIKE YOU ON
THE FLY YOUR- BUT WERE WILL ROAD
OKAY CONSIDERING THAT I DO WANT
TO SAY I WAS REMINDED THAT- ON
THE RACIAL EQUITY ANALYSIS.
BECAUSE OF SB TO RADIATE OPR HAS
ALREADY PUT OUT GUIDANCE. ON
WHAT THAT MEANS. I PER- I
CONFIDENT THAT THIS PATH. AND
THE LAW. BILL UPDATE. BECAUSE OF
THIS. HE'S ADDED AT. THE OPR IS
ALREADY PUT OUT GUY- ON THAT
EACH CERTAINLY GO AND TAKE A
LOOK- AT THAT KIND OF. SO WITH
THAT I'LL- I'LL BE SO. THE
MEASURE TODAY- AND THE- GREEN
ISING SOME OF THESE ISSUES VERY
CAREFULLY BEFORE THE FLOOR SO
APPRECIATE THAT THE ENGAGEMENT
THERE AND- ESPECIALLY FROM. THE
LOCAL AGENCIES IN. IN MY
BACKYARD I SORT OF. I'M I'M
HOPING WE CAN DO SOME FOLLOW UP
THERE AND JUST GET A REAL. SENSE
OF. HOW TO. MAINTAIN THE TRUST
OF THE PUBLIC THAT. THIS IS THE
THESE KIND OF PROJECTS WE WANT
YOU TO KNOW ABOUT. I'M NOT THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO. SKIRT FROM
PUBLIC VIEW. OKAY WHAT WILL BE
AND- WILL BE IN TOUCH. THEM OKAY
YES. I'M OF THE- A THANK YOU
CENTER. I'M OKAY. HI LOOK I
THINK WE'VE WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
WORK ON THE BILL AND I I'D LIKE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE INPUT
FROM ALL OF THEM THE SENATORS
AND- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY. ON THIS
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PLAN ISSUE
I AGREED SENATE WITH CASKEY- WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO OPEN THE
DOOR TO SOME SORT OF. LOOPHOLE
OR OR WORK AROUND WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO FOCUS ON ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION AND YOU KNOW. IF
THERE'S ANYTHING WE CAN DO TIED
A BILL DEFINITION LANGUAGE THERE
CERTAINLY WANT TO WORK WITH YOU
CENTER WITH CASKEY AND- THE
AUTHOR. AND THEN I JUST KIND OF
REITERATING THAT THE- THE ISSUES
RAISED BY CENTER STERN AYE AYE I
DO HOPE WE CAN FIGURE OUT A PATH
CENTER WIENER- TO ENSURE THAT
THERE BE. LET THE COR CONCERNS
THAT HE RAISE NOT NOT NOT NOT
ALLOWING FOR. FOR PROJECTS TO BE
STOPPED BUT FOR THE YOU KNOW THE
YEAR. BASED ON ONE PERSON'S
CONCERN BUT THAT THERE THAT BUT
THAT. THERE REALLY BE MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT. THAT WOULD HAVE TO
INFORM THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. R. FOR PROJECTS THAT
ARE THAT ARE- A LESSON HOW TO
MILLION DOLLARS. AND SO LET'S
WORK ON THAT AFTER YOU GET A
CENTER. THANK YOU AND WITH THAT
THAT THE BILL'S REMOVED YOU MAY
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
. OKAY I CENTER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE ITEM NUMBER FOR BY
SENATOR WIENER SB NINE TWENTY
TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ALLEN ALLEN I
SPEAKS. IT'S NOT VOTING DALAI.
DOLLY NOT VOTING GRACIE HOLD
OFFENDERS SALAS. SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI HI BECAUSE THE I'VE-
OKAY THAT'S FOUR VOTES- IT'S OUT
WE HAVE A FULL. CONTINUE HERE
SO- HERE'S LENA CENTER ACTUALLY
SO IT WILL KEEP THAT OPEN FOR-
FOR CONSIDERATION. OH SURE OKAY
AS AS CENTER DRAWS APPROACHES
THE DICE WE HAVE- MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CONFERENCE CENTER WE
CASKEY SO MOVED CENTER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS ONE TWO AND THREE
ALLEN HI. ALLEN I'D BATES BATES
AYE DALI DALI I GONZALEZ.
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI AYE CASKEY
AYE OKAY I WILL HOLD THAT OPEN
FOR SENATORS US ALL RIGHT LET'S
GO NOW TO SENATOR RAZA WHO IS
WHAT'S HERE NOW IT'S GONE AS YOU
AS YOU THIS IS A GREAT GREAT
NIGHT OUT AT SEA SCOTT WAS
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE SIZE THE
DIETS. ME FOR HOW RIGHT OKAY
PERFECT. OKAY ARE SIMILAR
PROCEEDS SB TEN NINE FIVE ITEM
NINE IN YOUR MEMBERS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. A GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MR CHAIR AND- I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR ON THE COMMITTEE
STAFF- FOR YOUR THOROUGH
ANALYSIS- AND FOR ENGAGING WITH
US I KNOW THIS IS A BETTER MORE
FOCUSED BILL I ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED ON PAGES
NINE AND TEN OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. WITH HIS OF THESE
AMENDMENTS SB TEN NINETY FIVE
WOULD REQUIRE THE- CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS TO TAKE ACCOUNT.
OF THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
OF THE PROPOSED ACTIONS ON
RACIAL ETHNIC AND GENDER
SUBGROUPS THIS BILL ESTABLISHES
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR CARBS
SOCIO ECONOMIC ASSESSMENTS. IT
ALSO SETS CRITERIA FOR HIRING
THIRD PARTY CONTRACTORS IF TO
FALL PERFORM THESE ASSESSMENTS.
THE PROPOSED MINIMUM STANDARDS
FOR CARBON INCLUDE ASSESSING
WHAT IMPACTS THEIR PROPOSED
ACTION COULD HAVE ON EMPLOYMENT.
AND THE ECONOMY OF THE AFFECTED
REGION AND A BASELINE ESTIMATE
OF THE COST REVENUES INCOME AND
OTHER ECONOMIC FACTORS. SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT THINK THIS IS A
DUPLICATE OF. CARBS CURRENT
ECONOMIC ASSESSMENTS HAVE A GOOD
BASELINE OF ECONOMIC INFORMATION
BUT THEY DO NOT ALWAYS LOOK AT
THE IMPACT OF WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. LAST YEAR
THE STATE AUDITOR REPORTED THAT
CAR HAS NOT ADEQUATELY
ADEQUATELY DEMONSTRATED THE
SOCIO ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF ITS
PROGRAMS AND THAT CARP CANNOT
SUFFICIENTLY DEMONSTRATE THAT
IT'S PROGRAMS ACHIEVE
SOCIOECONOMIC AND JOBS BENEFITS.
CARP IS NOT COLLECTING THE DATA
TO ILLUSTRATE HOW BENEFICIAL THE
PROGRAMS MIGHT BE WE NEED THEM
TO FOCUS ON THESE COMMUNITIES
WHEN DROPPING NEW CLEAN AIR
RULES. THIS BILL ENSURES. WE ARE
NO LONGER MISSING THIS KEY
COMPONENT THE POTENTIAL HARMS OF
OUR ACTIONS ON THE PEOPLE WHO
THROUGH THEIR HARD WORK KEEP OUR
STATE MOVING AND THRIVING. IS
THE TEN NINETY FIVE CHALLENGES
THE NOTION THE TALKING ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF REDUCING PARTICULATE
MATTER IN THESE COMMUNITIES IS
ENOUGH WE MUST TALK ABOUT THE-COST ON THE SAVE COMMUNITIES WE
WANT TO PUSH THAT UP TO THE
SURFACE. IF THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
ON WORKING CLASS CALIFORNIANS
ARE NOT TALKED ABOUT THEN THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ADDRESSED.
FOR EXAMPLE CARP ADMINISTERS
INVENTIVE PROGRAMS FOR INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS FOR CLEAN CARS
INCLUDING THEIR CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL PROGRAM FOR LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS. THE STATE AUDITOR
FOUND THAT CARP MISSED CLEAR
OPPORTUNITIES TO ASSESS WHETHER
THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM
ACTUALLY PROVIDES SOCIO ECONOMIC
BENEFITS. IN A TWENTY TWENTY
SURVEY BY THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION REVEALED THAT
RESIDENTS OF SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
AND HIGHER INCOME CALIFORNIANS
HAVE GREATER ACCESS TO HOME
CHARGING. THE SURVEY FOUND
ADDITIONAL DISPARITIES AMONG
RACE AND ETHNICITY GROUPINGS
MOREOVER ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE COSTS FOR
NON HOMEOWNERS FOR CHARGING
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. FAR EXCEED
COSTS FOR CHARGING AT HOME.
AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE POLICIES ARE
OFTEN REGRESSIVE CLIMATE
POLICIES FELT MOST DEEPLY IN THE
LIVES OF LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
WELL WE TALK ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING
THESE COMMUNITIES. WE DO NOT
CONSIDER THE HARMFUL IMPACTS
THAT OUR ACTIONS WILL HAVE ON
THEM SUCH AS JOB LOSS RISING
COSTS NO ACCESS TO CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION. OFTEN AIMED AT
CHANGING BEHAVIOUR ARE AMBITIOUS
PROGRAMS HAVE PROFOUND
CONSEQUENCES FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ON THE OTHER HAND
ARE CLIMATE INVESTMENTS ARE NOT
ALWAYS REACHING THESE
COMMUNITIES. THE GENDER EQUITY
POLICY INSTITUTE HAS BEEN
LOOKING AT OUR CLIMATE
RESILIENCY INVESTMENTS THEIR
ANALYSIS OF OCCUPATION DATA
OCCUPATIONAL DATA INDICATES THAT
IF WE ARE NOT THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
OUR INVESTMENTS 92% OF THE JOBS
POTENTIALLY CREATED BY THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL GO TO MEN. WE
CANNOT MITIGATE THESE HARMFUL
OUTCOMES WITHOUT KNOWING THE
FULL PICTURE OF OUR POLICIES ARE
AFFECTING BOTH THE PHYSICAL AND
ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. FOR EVERY POLICY
COMES WITH BENEFITS AND BURDENS
AND WE MUST MAKE SURE THAT BOTH
ARE SHARED EQUITABLY. TODAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT ON TODAY WE
HAVE OUR EXPERT WITNESS ON THE
LINE ROXANA TIENEN SHE IS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR A NEW
ECONOMY THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
SENATOR- MISTIMED YOU MAY
RECEIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
THAT MIGHT. COMMUNITY ADMITTING
. I AM VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE
TODAY- MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT L.
A. ALLIANCE FOR A NEW ECONOMY.
HAS BEEN AROUND FOR ABOUT THIRTY
YEARS. I AND IT HEARING THAT
CRYING WE BEEN REALLY FOCUSED ON
FIGHTING FOR. CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN QUALITY JOBS RACIAL
JUSTICE AND SUSTAINABLE
ENVIRONMENT AND I'M REALLY HAPPY
TODAY TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY
ABOUT SB TEN NINETY FIVE AND THE
COURTS- YEAH WE KNOW THAT WE
CAN'T ACHIEVE OUR STATE REALLY
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS WITHOUT
ENSURING THAT. WORKERS IN THESE
INDUSTRIES AND THE COMMUNITIES
IN WHICH THEY LIVE PARTICULARLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE REALLY
BENEFITING- ALL OF THAT SAID
REALLY AMBITIOUS- THE PROPOSAL
THE STATE HAS HI AND GOAL STATE
BACK. FOR MANY YEARS WE WORKED
WITH ALLY LIKE I DEFINITELY ME
THEM GO IN SOUTH AYE FINANCIAL.
LOOKING AT- ARE FUTURE TWENTY
THAT IT WE TRANSIT QUICKLY CON.
BACK WE'RE NOT WE PEOPLE. THAT
PUBLIC AND SERVICES. ARE GETTING
ACCESS BY THOSE COMMUNITIES WHO
CLEARLY THOUGHT THAT THE WORK
AND OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND THAT
WERE NOT SUBSTITUTE BAD JOB FOR
ONE IN THE TRANSITION- YOU KNOW
WE NOTE THAT THOSE COMMUNITIES
WHO ARE DEALING WITH THE WORST.
IMPACT THE WORST AIR QUALITY
IMPACT WHAT THE BE BOLD DRIVING
THE SOLUTION. AND THAT WE CAN'T
GET THROUGH THOSE EQUITABLE
SOLUTION BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE FACTS ARE WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO ANALYZE THE IMPACT. OF
OUR EXISTING POLICY- YEAH I WAS
GIVEN THE HISTORY THAT THAT AS
MANY OF US ARE AWARE OF BUSINESS
EIGHT- OF RACIAL SEGREGATION- OF
RED LINING UP LACK OF ACCESS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND- INEQUITABLE-
THANK HARM. ALL OF THOSE HOLLOW
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THE COMPANY.
OKAY ACCESS- MORE SERVICE AND
THOUGHT AND TRANSIT AND I IN FOR
EXAMPLE ABOUT FIVE OR SIX YEARS
AGO WE WERE AT THE YOU CAN BUY-
LED THE- WITH SPENDING MONEY. ON
OUR DOORSTEP CITY. AND YOU KNOW
THE- FOLKS WILL BE SURPRISED TO
KNOW THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT THAT
PER CAPITA SPENDING RALLY RATE
PAYERS ON SOLAR. IN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES. I ABOUT THREE DOLLARS
AND TWENTY FIVE CENTS WITH BEING
SPENT PER PERSON AND IN WEST LOS
ANGELES. FIFTY THREE DOLLARS AND
SIXTY THREE CENTS WITH BEING
SPENT KIRSTEN- WE LOOK AT WHAT
WHERE THIRTY SEVEN THAN WITH
BEING SPENT PER PERSON UNTIL
INVESTMENT AND IN BEL AIR. WHERE
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS PER CUSTOMER
BEING SPENT SO THAT KIND OF
ANALYSIS. IS REALLY CRITICAL IN
ORDER TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT OF THE POLICIES THAT WE
ARE PROPOSING. COMING OUT OF
THAT LADWP CREATED COULD BE
METRICS THAT THEY HAVE TO REPORT
ON EVERY YEAR WHAT THEY'RE
ANALYZING HOW THEY'RE SPENDING
THEIR MONEY TO ANALYZE THE
TAKING ADVANTAGE IN WHICH
NEIGHBORHOOD SERVICES. AND THAT
REALLY HELPED THEM UIDAI RACK.
THEIR BUDGET. THAT HELP THEM SET
NEW POLICIES LIKE COMMUNITY
SOLAR. TO CREATE NEW AVENUES FOR
LOW INCOME RATES HAVE ACCESS TO
THE BENEFIT OF SOLAR AT THE TO
JUST HOP ON POP. THAT ALLOW
HOMEOWNERS TO. SPEND A LOT OF
MONEY UP FRONT WHICH LOWER
INCOME FOLKS DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THAT DATA THEY DIDN'T GET THE
BENEFIT THE CLEANER ENERGY. ACT
HARD WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
THE ADVANCED CONTRACT COOL AND
PUSHING ALONG WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND ENVIRONMENTAL.
ALLIES FOR HIGHER TARGET. BUT WE
HAVE BEEN THE- LASTING AS A WHAT
THE TRANSIT TO CLEAN TRACK Q. IT
WORKERS ARE NOT BEING. WHAT WE
WHEN WE PUSH TO CLEAN. A THE
THIRTY ABOUT THE POINT BOB
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH WITH THAT
. EXACTLY MY COURT TRUCK COOLEY
. BY 90% THE GREAT CITING BUT
I'M FOR. IN LARGE PART BECAUSE
BETWEEN OF THAT TRACKS WITH BORN
BY THE DRIVER THEMSELVES WHO ARE
MISCLASSIFIED AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. SIMILARLY A CARD.
WHILE WE ABSOLUTELY WANT TO PUSH
FOR THAT WHICH TO BE OUR MISSION
VIA COLD THANK THAT INCREASE-
THE END THAT NUMBER OF TRUCKS.
MANUFACTURED AND PUT ON THE ROAD
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
MISCLASSIFIED DRIVERS. ARE NOT
BEARING THE COST. OF THAT
TRANSITION AND WITHOUT THE KIND
OF ANALYSIS. THAT HAD THAT SB CA
NINETY FIVE WOULD CREATE.
FOREIGN WE REALLY HAVE ALLEN
CONSEQUENCES AROUND TRANS AND
UNDER MY THE POP. FAITH IN. IN
THE TRANSIT. WE'RE NOT DOING IT
RIGHT WE'RE NOT TAKING THE TIME
TO DO THE RIGHT KIND OF ANALYSIS
REALLY UNDERSTAND. WHAT THE
IMPACT- OF THE TRANSITION ARE
GOING TO BE ON THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND THOSE WORKERS WHO ARE MARK
STONE TEMPLE THAT WOULD VERY
EXCITED TO THE POINT THAT FLIGHT
PLACE. AND THAT BOB ANSWER ANY
QUESTION THAT MEMBER MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY
. I DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE IN
PERSON ONCE HAS FINES FOR THE
BILL- BUT IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES MODERATE WHO.
WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN NINETY FIVE- WHAT'S YOUR FOR
THEM. HELLO THANK YOU MISS
CHAIRMAN WITH NORMAL SPEECH FOR
THIS OF FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THE ZERO ON YOUR PHONE'S KEEP
OUT THE SUN NUMBER WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER ONE
MEMBERS CALLED SPEAKER NAME L.
AFFILIATION PRIVILEGE SERVER.
ONCE AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR COMMENT. IT IS ANYONE SPEAKING
OPPOSITION- PLEASE PROCEED TO
THE DIS- BUT MATTER ANYONE
ANYONE TURNING UP ON THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT. NOBODY CAN
REFER SUPPORT ANYONE COMING UP
IN OPPOSITION I MEAN I'M NOT
SURPRISES NO WE DON'T HAVE-
EITHER SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILED
FOR THE BILL BUT- ANYONE ANYONE
OPPOSITION. THE ROLE OF PHONE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
ZERO. NINETY FIVE. OKAY LET'S
MAKE SURE WE HAVE NOBODY CAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S RESPECT
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS CENTER STERN. THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
INSISTING ON- THE SPOTLIGHT
HERE'S SENATOR AS I JUST I
WANTED TO ASK YOU BRIEFLY- THE
ANALYSIS. NOW THERE'S A NUMBER
OF AMENDMENTS IN HERE. BUT I I'M
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT- WHAT'S
WHAT'S RETAINED IN. THERE'S A
THERE'S A THERE'S AN EXISTING
SET OF LAWS I THINK IT'S UNDER
SB SIX SEVENTEEN FROM BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THAT ANY
RULE THAT'S GOT AN ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF OVER FIFTY MILLION-
HAS TO GO THROUGH WHAT THEY CALL
A REGULATORY IMPACT ANALYSIS-
WHICH- WHICH TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
SOME OF ITS ISN'T IN THE HOUSE
AT LEAST IT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT.
THE HOW THE EFFECTS OF THE
REGULATION ARE DISTRIBUTED. BY
INDUSTRY INCOME RACE SEX OR
GEOGRAPHY. SO FAR ALREADY SORT
OF LOOKING AT THOSE EFFECTS IN
THE SOCIO ECONOMIC IMPACT
ANALYSIS REQUIRED UNDER EXISTING
LAW. WHAT WHAT WHAT MORE DOES
THIS KIND OF ANALYSIS GIVE US IS
THIS TRYING TO SORT OF PIN THAT
DOWN AND GET INTO. ACTUAL A
JUDGE I JOBS IMPACT ANALYSIS OR-
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT IT'LL LOOK LIKE- IN
PRACTICE IN ADDITION WHAT'S
ALREADY GOING ON YEAH WELL THERE
IS- AS I UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO
MINIMUM REQUIREMENT ACROSS ALL
AIR DISTRICTS. TO CONSIDER THE
IMPACT ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OF SPECIFICALLY
DURING THE- SOCIOECONOMIC
ASSESSMENT SOME DISTRICTS ARE
REQUIRED BY AB US SIX SEVENTEEN
OF TO WORK WITH- THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD OF AN EMISSION REDUCTION
PROGRAMS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THERE'S SOME ERROR
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE STAFF LOSE
THEIR OWN OF POLICIES FOR
ADDRESSING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE- THE- BUT IT'S NOT. IT'S
NOT A REQUIREMENT ACROSS THE
BOARD SO WE JUST WANT TO
ESTABLISH THAT- THEY DO FOR MORE
ON THAT FRONT THEN CARP DOES. SO
I THINK THAT'S THE- WHAT WE
WANNA- BALANCE OUT HERE AND MAKE
SURE IT'S DONE ACROSS THE BOARD
WITH THE STATE AND ALSO OUR
THRESHOLD WOULD BE TEN MILLION.
AHLERS NOT THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT ALL STATE AGENCIES
ARE. AS I UNDERSTAND ARE
REQUIRED TO DO. THANK YOU.
THERMOS KEEP I GUESS I'M I HAVE
SOME CONCERNS THAT I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS AS OUTLINED IN THE
STAFF ANALYSIS ABOUT THE
EXPANSIVENESS REQUIREMENTS HERE
OF THE OF THE BILL'S QUITE
LENGTHY AND THE ACHIEVABILITY OF
CREATED I KNOW THAT WE HAVE OUR
INITIAL AUDIT THE FIRST CITED
THAT WE'VE GOT FROM THIS STATE
OTHER ON SOME OF THE-
DEFICIENCIES OF THE SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS THE CARBS TO
AND IT'S A NEW THING THAT WE'RE-
WE'RE DOING. SO I DID STAFF
REPORTS SUGGEST THAT WE REDUCE
THE MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS OF. ECO
ECONOMETRIC ASSESSMENTS LISTEN
SECTION TO SOME LOOKING AT
SECTION TWO IS THAT. AS IT PICKS
UP IN THE BOTTOM OF PAGE FOUR
AND GOES IN THAT GOES FOR IS
THAT THE WHOLE SECTION TWO
THAT'S BEING DELETED. THE OTHER
THAN THE OTHER THAN THE
DEFINITIONS ON. TO BE ABLE TO BE
TO SEE GOES THROUGH A LOT OF.
OKAY ELEMENTS SECTION TO CHANGES
ASIDE. HAVE HERE. OF THESE A
SECTION TO CHANGES THESE
ELEMENTS NOW APPLY ONLY TO CARB. PURCHASE A LOCAL DISTRICTS
RIGHT RIGHT OKAY OKAY I GOTTA
KEEP. IT STILL FITS STILL THE
LEGAL THE LEGAL RISK IN THE
ACHIEVABILITY STILL EXIST RIGHT
YOU DO TAKING OUT THE LOCAL
DISTRICTS TO GET THAT BUT HALF
OF THE STATE WHY THEY STILL HAVE
TO DO THAT ANALYSIS BY ANY
REGULATION RIGHT. WELL THEY DO
DO SOME RIGHT WE WANTED TO BE
MORE FOCUSED ON BOTH ECONOMIC
AND RACIAL WEALTH AND ESPECIALLY
THE RACIAL BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
EXPLICIT RIGHT NOW PLAYING THE
DEVIL'S ADVOCATE IT'S MUCH MORE
PRESCRIPTIVE. YOU KNOW THEY'VE
THERE THIS IS I THINK CAL I
DON'T KNOW ANY OTHER STATES
THEY'RE DOING THIS FOR A SORT OF
SOCIAL ECONOMIC ANALYSIS ON THE
REGULATIONS THAT FIT
CALIFORNIA'S DOING SO WE'VE
WE'VE DONE IT WE'VE GOT THE
FIRST AUDIT THEY CAME IN AND
SAID THAT WE COULD DO A BETTER
JOB. THAN THIS IS TEN NINETY
FIVE IS AN ANSWER I FEEL A
LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE TODAY.
DURING THE BILL BECAUSE SEEMS.
IT IT'S SO PRESCRIPTIVE OF WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO THAT I DON'T
KNOW IF WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON
ALL THE- ATIONS OF THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT VERSUS THE BENEFIT OF THE
- CLIMATE POLICY THIS COULD GO
ON- I MEAN I THIS IS THE FIRST
TRY THIS IS IF. THIS IS IF
CALIFORNIA WAS EVER CUTTING THE
EDGE ON IN ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL POLICY THIS THIS IS
EMBRACED BY BY THIS BILL AND I
GUESS IT'S I'D LIKE TO SEE
IMPRINTED IS GOOD TO GO
JUDICIARY SAMBA SEAT AGAIN- SO
I'D LIKE TO I'M GONNA STAY OFF
THE BILL TODAY- TO LOOK AT THE-
CLIMATIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL.
CHANGES THAT THEY MAY BEFORE WE
GET TO THE JUDICIARY AND WHAT
YOU SAID THE COMMITTEE WITH ME
YEAH WELL LOOK YOU'RE RIGHT
HELLO I'M SO SORRY IT'S NOT
GOING TO DO HERE I REALLY
APOLOGIZE THE NEXT ONE THAT
HERTZBERG BILL I WAS CONFUSED
WITH. THIS ONCE IS GOING
STRAIGHT TO A PROBES. UP MY
SOLITARY CENTERVIEW SO. YEAH I.
YEAH I GUESS EVEN TAKING OUT THE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS IS ALRIGHT
BUT YOU STILL HAVE TO STATE
POLICY THAT IS GOING TO TWO VERY
SPECIFIC ECONOMIC IT AND
SOCIALIZE IT'S LIKE I'M READING
THIS AND I'M THINKING WE NEED
LIKE THEY'RE GONNA HIRE TEMA SIX
PHD SIGNAL TO DETERMINE ALL THE
ALL THE ECONOMIC AND- OF. BUZZ
RACIAL IMPACTS IT MAY HAPPEN ON
. REDUCING REDUCING METHANE
WHO'S WHO LOSE THEIR JOB WHO'S
GONNA PUT NEIGHBORHOOD IT IS
WHETHER THEY COULD BE LATINO OR
BLACK OR PACIFIC ISLANDER AND
ALL THAT IN IN FOR SOMEBODY
OBVIOUSLY SPONSORS THAT'S VERY
GOOD INFORMATION. I JUST DON'T I
AM. I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
DUPLICATE IT IF IT'S THE- THIS
SINCE IT'S GOING WITH THIS
VERSUS WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
ORGANICALLY AT THE AIRPORT AND
IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW THE
DEFICIENCIES ABOUT THE I GUESS
THE DEFICIENCIES THAT THAT EXIST
OTHER THAN WHICH POINTED OUT
WITH THE- WITH THE AUDIT SO.
THAT'S MY- THOUGHTS ON IT MISTER
CHAIR IF I COULD YES YES PLEASE
A QUICK OF RESPONSE TO THAT
YOU'RE RIGHT CALIFORNIA'S IS A
GREAT HEAD WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
DOING GOOD BUT WE HAVE NOT GIVEN
THAT FOCUS ON THE ECONOMIC AND
RACIAL. WHERE THEY COME TOGETHER
AND SO THAT'S THE PART THAT WE
NEED TO START PAYING MORE
ATTENTION TO BECAUSE AS OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES MOVE
FORWARD AS WE BEGIN TO DO MORE
AND MORE ARE INVESTMENTS GROW
WHAT ABOUT THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
ON THOSE COMMUNITIES SO NOW'S
EXACTLY THE TIME WE STARTED TO
DO SOME OF THAT. AMENITIES IT'S
GOING TO GET BIGGER AND BIGGER
AND BIGGER NOW'S THE TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY DON'T GET
LEFT BEHIND. I MEAN I I'M THIS
IS NOT A COLLOQUY MISTER CHAIR
BUT BUT RIGHT NOW THE AIRORTS
AND THE DISTRICTS ARE REQUIRED.
TO HAVE THEIR SEVERAL
REQUIREMENTS THEY HAVE ON SOCIAL
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS AND HOW TO
SUPPORT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IT'S THEIR THE AUTO
REPORTS SAID THERE'S ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT THIS IS TEN NINETY
FIVE WHICH- IS. SINCE THIS
BASEBALL SEASON A DOUBLE GRAND
SLAM OF WHAT THAT WOULD BE WHICH
BABY YOU KNOW YOU'RE THE AUTHOR
THAT'S OKAY THAT'S IT I'M I'M
LOOKING AT IT AND SAYING. IN
SAYING I NEED TO RE READ THIS
AGAIN SO I'M JUST IT'S JUST SO.
THE CHAIR UNDERSTANDS MY NO I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS I MEAN
HONESTLY I WOULD PARTICULARLY
WHEN THE BILL IS FOR SURE AND I
THINK I'M- IT WAS A QUADRUPLE
GRAND SLAM IN TERMS OF IN TERMS
OF- YOU KNOW A BOOK BUT BUT BUT
NOT ENOUGH NOT NATIONALLY
POSITIVELY I MEAN I THINK OUR
REAL CONCERN WAS IT WAS IT WAS.
THE KIND OF UP AND DOWN IMPACTS
IT WOULD HAVE ON. ON- ON THE
ABILITY OF FAIR DISTRICTS TO DO
THEIR WORK- I RECEIVED YOU KNOW
WE'VE WORKED HARD TO. FIVE TO
TEN. TO THE BELL BUT- AND OF
COURSE THE AIR B. HAS A LOT MORE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE TO DO THIS
SORT OF WORK THAT. IS OUT CALLED
FOR THE BILL BUT AND- BUT I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE WRONG I THINK
YOU'RE ON TO. SOME IMPORTANT
ISSUES. WITH THIS BILL I AM
CENTER CASKEY. SO OKAY- BUT YOU
KNOW. I FEEL I FEEL I'M- MOVED
BILL THE BILL OKAY THE BILL'S
REMOVED- I CERTAINLY THINK WE'RE
IT WE'RE IN A MUCH. STRONGER
PLACE- BUT BUT THINK THE CLASSIC
EARNED AS THE BILL MOVES FOR
SENATORS GOING TO IS SUCH THAT
WE YOU KNOW IT'S OUR JOB. TO
LOOK OUT FOR ENVIRONMENTAL. AND
AND I THINK THE CONCERN IT'S
ALWAYS GONNA BE THERE AROUND
THIS BILL IS THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE USED AS A TOOL TO MAKE IT
HARDER FOR. OUR AIR DISTRICTS TO
DO IT AND THEN THE AIRPORT TO DO
ITS WORK IN KEEPING OUR CLEAN. I
AND- YEAH THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT TIME HAS A HUGE
SOCIAL ECONOMIC IMPACT AS WELL
SO- WITHOUT AND WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO SUPPORT TODAY AND TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU AND-
HI IT'S THE MOVE BY CENTER.
SKINNER WILL COLLECT CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND- I'M YOU KNOW
EXCITES WAS RIGHT THERE YOU KNOW
RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO MY DISTRICT
EXCITED AND ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE IMPACTED BY EXCITE LIVE IN
THE DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT-
AND THERE EXAMPLES LIKE THAT
MAYBE NOT AS BIG AS DRAMATIC AND
HISTORIC YOU KNOW ACROSS MY
DISTRICT AND I WANT. CLEAN AIR
CLEAN WATER I WANT THAT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. BUT WE GOT TO TAKE IT
ALL INTO ACCOUNT AND IGNORING
FUNDAMENTAL INFORMATION BUT
ECONOMIC SIDE OF IT. IS ALSO
IMPORTANT TO MY COMMUNITY WE
CAN'T DO THAT. CAN DO THAT TO
THEM SO I BELIEVE WE'RE ALL
CAPABLE OF DOING BOTH AND THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT TO JUST ADVANCE
THAT. WE HAD FAR MORE AND WITH
YOUR HELP WE WERE ABLE TO ZERO
IN ON THE THINGS THEY WORK
REALLY ESSENTIAL TO THIS BILL WE
CUT OUT A LOT. OF A LOT MORE AND
A LOT OF DETAIL SO FOR THAT AND-
I'M GRATEFUL TO YOUR ENGAGEMENT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THE KALRA. ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR DORADO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN. ALLEN AYE BATES. BATES
KNOW DOLLY. SALLY NOW GONZALEZ.
INNER STERN RIGHT STERN HI WHITE
HOUSE KEEP UP VOTING. CASKEY NOT
VOTE. OKAY WILL HOLD THE ROAD
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU SIR
OKAY I SEE CENTER ADMIN HERE-
SHE'S READY TO PRESENT NEITHER
NUMBER SIX IN YOUR IN YOUR
POCKETS MEMBERS IS SB TEN FORTY
SIX OH NEWMAN- I'M SO SORRY. I'M
SO SORRY. HE'S A PHONE SHE HOW
DOES KICKBACKS- YOU. ARE THIS IS
A REAL STAND- YEAH- CHRIS ROCK
AND HIS WELL. TO SEE OKAY RIGHT
I CENTER AYE APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR INTO CENTER ADMIN IN IS
SENTIMENTS HERE TO PRESENT SB
NINE FORTY TWO YOU MAY PROCEED
AND MY APOLOGIES TO MY COLLEAGUE
WHOSE BODY LANGUAGE MAKES IT
CLEAR HOW SHE FEELS. GET MORE MR
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB NINE FORTY TWO WHICH WILL
PROVIDE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES THE
AUTHORIZATION AND FLEXIBILITY TO
UTILIZE FUNDS ARE TO
CALIFORNIA'S LOW CARBON TRANSIT
OPERATIONS PROGRAM. OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS L. C. TOP TO
SUPPORT FREE OR REDUCED FARE
TRANSIT PROGRAMS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. THE APPLICATION L. C. TOP
FUNDS IN THIS MANNER WILL
PROVIDE FOR THE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY AND BENEFITS OF
FORWARD THINKING TRANSIT
PROGRAMS SUCH AS FREE AND
REDUCED FARE YOUTH RIDERSHIP
BROKE. THAT EXPAND ACCESS TO
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND CREATE
LIFELONG TRANSIT RIDERS WHILE
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS L. C. TOP WAS REGION
CREATED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN BY S.
B. EIGHT SIXTY TWO IS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF
PROGRAMS TARGETING GHG EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS IN CALIFORNIA. USING
FUNDS GENERATED BY THE STATE'S
GROUND BREAKING CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDE A
FULL INCLUDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
TRANSIT AND INTERCITY RAIL
CAPITAL AND OPERATING PROJECTS.
IN HIGH SPEED RAIL LC TOP IS TO
MINISTER BY CALTRANS AND IS
FUNDED THREE CONTINUES TO
APPROPRIATION 5% GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS GENERATED BY CAP
AND TRADE FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FISCAL YEAR. APPROXIMATELY
ONE HUNDRED AND.SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION- OVER OVER ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY MADE WAS LAID. FOR
ALLOCATION TO OUT TO- TO LC TOP.
AS NOTED ONE OF THE FOUNDATION
GOALS WILL SEE TOP IS THE
PROVISION OF OPERATING AND
CAPITAL SYSTEMS TO TRANSIT
AGENCIES. TO IMPROVE MOBILITY
WHILE REDUCING GHGS WITH A
PRIORITY ON SERVING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
TODAY'S BILL BUILT ON S. B.
ELEVEN NINETEEN PASSED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHICH CONTAIN
PROVISIONS FOR TRANSIT AGENCIES.
TO INVEST LC TOP FUNDS IN THREE
AREAS PURSUANT TO MEETING THE
OVERALL STATUTORY REQUIREMENT.
OF PROVIDING A BENEFIT TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THOSE
THREE AREAS WERE FIRST FUNDING
TRANSIT FARE SUBSIDIES INCLUDING
STUDENT TRANSIT PASSES. SECOND
FUNDING TRANSIT CONNECTIONS TO
MAJOR EMPLOYMENT AREAS EDUCATION
CENTERS OR MEDICAL FACILITIES
FOR RESIDENTS OF. OR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. FOUR FUNDING
TECHNOLOGY IMPROVEMENTS THAT
REDUCE EMISSIONS OF GREENHOUSE
GASES INCLUDING THE APPLICATION
OF LC TOUGH FUNDS FOR THE
PURCHASE OF ZERO EMISSION BUSES
IN FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE. UNDER
PROVISIONS OF SB ELEVEN NINETEEN
A TRANSIT AGENCY CAN ONLY USE LC
TOUGH FUNDS ONCE PER SIX MONTH
PROGRAM INTERVAL MEETING THAT
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO REAPPLY IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE TO ADMINISTER.
AN APPROVED PROGRAM EVEN IF THE
POPULATION SERVE HAS NOT CHANGED
BECAUSE THE PROGRAM REQUIRES
REGULAR RATE RIGOROUS EMISSION
REDUCTION ANALYSIS AND OTHER
REPORTING. THIS BILL WILL REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS WHILE
ALLOWING FOR LONGER PERIODS OF
APPROVAL THEREBY EXPANDING THE
BENEFITS OF THE- OVER THE PAST
DECADE ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC TRANSIT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. HAS TRIED
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT FREE
AND REDUCED TRANSIT FOR YOUR
PROGRAMS. UNFORTUNATELY A LACK
OF AVAILABLE FUNDING FOR
MAINTAINING PROGRAMS ON A LONG
TERM BASIS HAS STYMIED THOSE
EFFORTS IN ORANGE COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE. THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY HAS
SUCCESSFULLY OPERATED AN LC TOP
FUNDED YOU THROW YOU THROUGH
FREE PROGRAM. ALLOWING YOUNG
WRITERS AGES EIGHTEEN UNDER TO
ACCESS ALL ORANGE COUNTY FIXED
ROUTE BUSES AT NO COST THIS
MONTH THIS SIX MONTH DEL SITO
PILOT PROGRAM. BEGAN IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE WITH
PASSES THAT WERE VALID THROUGH
FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH OF THIS
YEAR. SINCE THE PROGRAM'S
INCEPTION THE NUMBER OF YOUTH
WRITERS HAS INCREASED STEADILY
FROM SEVENTH OUR FIVE EIGHTY.
INSERT TWENTY ONE TO OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND RIGHT IN THIS. OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE COMPELLING
EVIDENCE THAT THE PROGRAM IS
SUCCEEDING IN ITS AIM OF
CULTIVATING GENERATION OF NEW
AND HOPEFULLY LIFELONG RIDERS.
THIS PROMISING YOUTH RIDERSHIP
PROGRAM IS ALSO PROVIDED A
SECONDARY BENEFIT OF SUPPORTING
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN ORANGE
COUNTY IN THE WAKE OF THE
PANDEMIC. PARTICULAR MULLIN-
SEES LOW INCOME AND DIVERSE
POPULATIONS UNFORTUNATELY
HOWEVER WHILE THE INITIAL PIRATE
PRO PILOT PROGRAM QUALIFY TO
UTILIZE LC TOP FUNDING THE
EXISTING STATUTORY RESTRICTIONS.
NOTED EARLIER RENDER LC TOP AN
UNSUSTAINABLE SOURCE OF ON GOING
FUNDING YOU. OF THE INITIAL
SUCCESS A LONG TERM PROSPECTS OF
THE PROGRAM. AND PASSAGE OF S.
NO FORTY TWO. CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES WILL BE AUTHORIZED TO
USE LC TOP MONIES FOR THE
FUNDING OF FREE OR REDUCED
RETURN PROGRAMS AND TO CONTINUE
TO USE THOSE FUNDS TO MAINTAIN
THOSE PROGRAMS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. PROVIDED THAT THE
POPULATION OR OTHER ELEMENTS OF
THIS PROGRAM HAVE NOT CHANGED IN
SO DOING SB NINE FORTY TWO WILL
PROVIDE MULTIPLE SIMULTANEOUS
BENEFITS. REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GASES EXPAND MASS TRANSIT
UTILIZATION BY LIFE LONG RUN.
WITH CONGESTION OUR STREETS YEAH
OFFERING AN AVENUE U.
IMPROVEMENT OF FAMILIES THAT
HAVE BEEN NEGATIVELY AND- BY THE
- OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS HERE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY THIS MORNING.
ARE MOIRA TOP. MY LIKE TO REFER
TO IS MORE L. TOP REPRISING MY
JOKE EVERY FOUR YEARS. AND MR
MICHAEL PIMENTEL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSITION TO TRANSITION WILL
TESTIFY BY TELECONFERENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. HI ASIDE WELCOME IS
TOP. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN A
MEMBER SO I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE
AS A SPONSOR OF SB NINE FORTY
TWO. AS MENTIONED THE OFF THE
TOP PROGRAM A STATEWIDE FORMULA
BASED PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
FUNDING TO ALL TRANSIT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FOR A CTA
WE HAVE USED THESE FUNDS TO
AMONG OTHER THINGS FUND FREE AND
REDUCED TRANSIT FARE PROGRAMS
WITHIN THE COUNTY. FOR EXAMPLE-
SEE TOP- CTA HAS. USED THE TOP
FUNDS FOR ITS COLLEGE PASS.
PROGRAM WHERE A CTA PARTNER WITH
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
PROVIDE HEAVILY DISICK
DISCOUNTED FARE PASSES TO
STUDENTS. AND MOST RECENTLY WE
HAVE USED L. C. TOP FUNDS TO
FUND OUR YOUTH RIGHT FREE%
PROGRAM ALLOWING THOSE EIGHTEEN
IN A AND UNDER TO RIDE AFFECTS
FIXED ROUTE BUSES FOR FREE. THE
YOUTH RIDE FREE PRO IS A KEY
PART OF OUR STRATEGY TO IMPROVE
MOBILITY OPTIONS. REDUCE
CONGESTION AND CUT GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. IN ADDITION
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THESE WILL HELP
BRING RIDERSHIP LEVELS BACK TO
THOSE PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC. IN
VOTING TO CONTINUE THIS THE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM THE- CTA
BOARD OF DIRECTORS NOTED THE L.
C. T. L. C. L. C. TOP FUNDS ARE
VITAL TO ITS CONTINUATION.
UNFORTUNATELY CURRENT LAW DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR THE USE OF L. C.
TOP FUNDS LONG TERM REGARDLESS
OF THE SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM.
SB NINE FORTY TWO WILL CLARIFY
THAT ONGOING USE OF L. C. TOP
FUNDS FOR FREE AND REDUCED FARE
PROGRAMS IS AUTHORIZED. AGENCIES
WILL STILL BE REQUIRED TO REPORT
METRICS ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR
PAST PROGRAMS AND DEMONSTRATE
CONSISTENCY WITH L. C. TOP
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS IN THE
INITIAL ALLOCATION ACROSS. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT MR
PIMENTEL ON THE LINE. SURE
MEMBERS MULTI CASH RECORD
CALIFORNIA TRACTORS. PRODUCT
SPONSORS S. B. I WILL CHOOSE
HEAR YOU ON BEHALF OF MY THAN
EIGHTY FIVE PRINTS WELL EACH
TEAM MEMBERS WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS FILM ACTUALLY
URGE YOUR OF I KNOW YOU HEARD
QUITE A BIT ABOUT THE BACKGROUND
OF THIS PROGRAM I KNEW EXACTLY
WHAT HE CAN CAN YOU YOU TO STEP
ASIDE THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE
. CALIFORNIA TRANSIT AGENCY KEEP
CONTAINERS CONTINUOUSLY DIRECTOR
ALCOPOP ON THE FAIR FREE OR
REDUCED HEALTH PROGRAM THESE
PROGRAMS QUITE FRANKLY COULD BE
AN EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR BUILDING
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP YOU CAN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
INCREASING ACCESS TO TRANSIT
SERVICES I WOULD ARGUE THAT IT
ALL THESE ARE MODEL OUTCOMES
COMPANIES CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE
WITH OUR GAS PRICES. IN TRAINING
AGENCY STATE IS STILL DEPLETED
RIDERSHIP BASED RESULTING FROM
YEAH. THE HAPPINESS OF THESE
PROGRAMS I WOULD HIGHLIGHT THE
TRANSIT AGENCIES HAVE OFTEN.
DIFFICULTY SUSTAINING USE THEIR
FREE WILL YOU STEP PROGRAM
BECAUSE THESE PROGRAMS FRANKLY
USED REVENUES COLLECTED OUR
OFFICE. BEAT NINE FOUR TO CREATE
CLEAR PATHWAYS TO LONG TERM
SUPPORT FOR THESE PROGRAMS BY
MODIFYING THE TALK AND WOULD
JUST CLOSE IN SAYING I DO
BELIEVE THAT IF THIS BILL PASS
IT WOULD HELP OUR INDUSTRY IN
OUR EFFORTS TO EXPAND TO OUR
SERVICES WHILE ALSO PROTECTING
THE FINANCIAL HEALTH SOLVENCY OF
OUR TRANSIT AGENCIES. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
ONES. OF THE ANSWERED QUESTIONS.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
NAY FRUSTRATION CHARACTERS
SUPPORT GREAT THANK YOU. MOTOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE TO ONE OF
VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL AT
NINE FORTY TWO. I LOSE A LITTLE
PUBLIC FIGURE THIS YEAR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AND THE OPERATOR
WILL BE RIGHT WITH YOU MY NUMBER
THE SECURE LINE OVER THE FALLS.
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION THE
LEGISLATIVE RECORD ONE ZERO.
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
NINE FORTY TWO. WE HAVE ONE ZERO
ONE NUMBER FORTY. US. THANK YOU
MISTER SEPTEMBER SOURCES ROUGH
BUT WE ON BEHALF OF BY TRASH
AUTHORITY AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
. OKAY JUST ONE PERSON AND
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO. VOICE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL I DON'T
SEE ONE HERE IN PERSON AND ON
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR.
THERE'S NO RESTAURANT BUSINESS
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO PROPER.
JOURNALIST OKAY LET'S GO TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
ABOUT THE BILL CENTER BATES. ARE
I SUPPORTED THE AD IN. I THINK-
I INTEND TO DO THAT TODAY BUT I
WAS CURIOUS ABOUT THE FARE BOX
RETURN RATIO IN IS THE ARE THE
FUNDS THAT COME THROUGH THIS ON
TO THE SUPPLEMENT THAT. WILL
THAT WERE NOT AFFECTED ON THAT
FROM ALL THE OTHER FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT COME TO OUR TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AGENCIES I DON'T KNOW
IF I'M ON THE RIGHT PAGE WITHOUT
BUT I JUST WAS THINKING. THAT
WHEN THESE PEOPLE ARE WRITING
FREE BUT THEIR THEIR FARES ARE
BEING SUPPLEMENTED WITH THIS.
ITEM I BELIEVE SO THAT'S CORRECT
A LET MR HIM UNTIL SHE COULD
SPEAK TO. IS ON THE LINE. THIS
QUESTION YEAH WHICH IS DID NOT
YOU. SENATOR BATES THAT YES THE
MY PROVIDE BY THE C. POSSIBLE
OFFSET- RIGHT LAW- BOX BELOW
AGENCIES COMPUTED- BOXER
REQUIREMENT THAT SPECIFY IN
STATE THANK. OKAY BUZZARD. SO I
OFF THIS INTERNET AND THEN I'M
I'M A FOR. YOU'RE GIVEN SOME A
FAIR PASS BUT IN THE BILL IF YOU
GO TO- ACTUAL PAY A LINE SEVEN.
THE MONEY'S OF FOR THIS PROGRAM
SHOULD BE EXPANDED TO PROVIDE
TRANSIT OPERATION CAPITAL
ASSISTANCE THAT MEET ANY OF THE
FOLLOWING. EXPENDITURES THAT
DIRECTLY ENHANCE OR EXPAND
TRANSIT SERVICES BY SUPPORTING
NEW AND EXPANDED BUS OR RAIL
SERVICES. NEW EXPANDED WATER
BORNE TRANSIT OR EXPANDING
INTERMODAL TRANSIT. TRANSIT
FACILITIES AND MAKING INCLUDING
EQUIPMENT ACQUISITION FUELING
AND MAINTENANCE AND OTHER COSTS
OPERATING THE SERVICES
FACILITIES AND IT GOES ON THE
LIST. A WHOLE LOT MORE THAN JUST
OFFSETTING THE FARES FOR. FOLKS
TO RIDE THE SO THIS IS A VERY
EXPENSIVE. AND WE'RE GONNA SO I
JUST KINDA WANT TO GET YOUR IDEA
OF. OF THIS IS MORE THAN JUST A
FAREBOX. SUPPLEMENT RESTAURANT
ALLOWED MR OF SPEAK OF THIS
PROJECT I DON'T KNOW THAT THIS
TRULY CHANGES THE EXISTING
PROVISIONS. GO AHEAD MR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. MISTER DOLLY-
SO THAT'S CURRENT LAW SO THE
BILL DOES PROVIDE FOR ALL OF
THOSE ALTERNATIVES- FOR
EXPENDITURE WHAT WE'RE SAYING IN
THIS BILL IS- SIMPLY FOR THE FOR
A FAIR REDUCE THEIR PROGRAM. YOU
CAN HAVE A LONGER TERM OR A
LONGER TIME FRAME TO- TO EXPAND
THE MONEY IN THE PROGRAM YOU CAN
THAT LET HAVE A PROGRAM LAST
LONGER SO FOR CAPITAL
EXPENDITURE IT MAKES SENSE TO
HAVE A TIME LIMITED-
REQUIREMENTS. BUT FOR A
OPERATIONAL PROGRAM BECAUSE THE
STOCK THIS OP PROGRAM ALLOWS FOR
BOTH CAPITAL AND OPERATIONS
EXPENDITURES IT MAKES SENSE TO
CONTINUE A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S SIMPLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. SO THIS IS
A TWO THIRDS HE IS A TWO THIRDS
VOTE SO THIS IS OBVIOUSLY AN
INCREASE. IN A NEED TO TWO
THIRDS VOTE TO GET AT THE PAST
AND SO WHAT HOW HOW LONG WILL
THIS GO WELL THERE IS THERE
SUNSET ON THIS BILL. AND SHOW.
MISTRUST MY UNDERSTANDING YOU
CAN. WAIT UNTIL THE CENSOR THE
BILL IS THE SUNSET FOR CAP AND
TRADE- THERE'S NO EXPLICIT
SUNSET FOR THIS. PARTICULAR
PROVISION THE CORRECT CORRECT.
OKAY I WOULD MOVE THE BILL
THUNDERSTORMS MOVE THE BILL
SENYUMANNYA MAKE CLOTHES YEAH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I WILL
THANK YOU THIRTY OF HIS CAR. I
AM NUMBER FIVE SB NINE FORTY TWO
BY SENATOR NEWMAN. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALAN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES. AYE
BATES FIVE DALLY. L. A. NOT
VOTING ENDS ON. SKINNER STERN
ALL RIGHT STERN I WHITE HOUSE BY
CAST I. THAT'S FOR VOTERS AS AN
EFFORT TO GET A BELIEVER ROLLED
IN FROM THE NUMBERS AND ON THE
CENTER ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE CENTER EGGMAN. AYE
YOU MAY PROCEED. WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION OF SB TEN FORTY SIX
WHEN READY MEMBERS IS ITEM SIX
IN YOUR PACKETS. CAN MEET MYSELF
. WELL TO BE HERE WITH YOU TODAY
ABOUT LIKE SOME OF YOU I SERVED
IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT BEFORE I
CAME TO THE CAPITAL AND- DURING
MY TIME IN THE CITY COUNCIL I
REALLY. BECAME VERY INTERESTED
AND PASSIONATE ABOUT THE IDEA OF
WASTE AND WASTE REDUCTION. I
REALLY THINK IT'S THE UNDERBELLY
OF OUR OF OUR WORLD ECONOMY AND
IF WE DON'T REALLY ADDRESS IT.
THAT WE ALL HAVE ISSUES SO- IT
IS NOT AS GLAMOROUS AS SOME OF
THE OTHER THINGS BUT- A WASTE
AND WHAT WE DO WITH THAT I
THINK. WILL HAVE LONG LASTING
IMPLICATIONS FOR OUR HEALTH. SB
TEN FORTY SIX IS A BAG. THAT
WOULD PROHIBIT OF FROM
DISTRIBUTING PRE CHECK OUT PRUDE
PRODUCE BAGS THAT ARE NOT
REUSABLE RECYCLABLE OR
COMPOSTABLE. YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN FOLKS THOSE BAGS THAT YOU
TAKE THAT YOU TRIED TO GET OPEN
TO PUT YOUR VEGETABLES IN- NOW.
WHERE BHASKER DON'T BUT THEY
WERE VERY DIFFICULT. TO MAKE
DOES COMPOSTABLE BUT WE KNOW NOW
FROM. OUR PREVIOUS BILLS IN
TRENTON IMPLEMENT- THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE ARE DIVERGING GOALS
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO REALLY- CUT
DOWN. ON WHAT WE PUT INTO THE
TRASH AND PUT MORE INTO THE
COMPOSTABLE GREEN WASTE. AT SO
IF YOU'RE LIKE ME AND YOU GET
SOME GROCERIES AND IF YOU PUT
HIM IN THE GREEN WASTE. IN YOUR
LITTLE BAG. IF THAT STARTS TO GO
TOO SOON AND YOU TO THROW THAT
IN THE TRASH NOW GONNA HAVE TO
YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT OUT OF
THERE. TRY TO GET ALL THE GREEN
OUT OF THERE. THEN PUT THAT IN
THE GREEN WASTE AND PUT THAT
BAG. IN THE TRASH. AT THAT COST
MORE FOR THE HOLDERS TO TRY TO.
GET THOSE TWO APART- SO THIS IS
VERY SIMPLE I THINK THAT WE NOW.
AND IS YOUR- THERE IS NO DATE
FOR IMPLEMENTATION WERE WORKING
WITH THE GROCER. WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL FOR THEM TO BE ABLE SEE
WHAT IS REASONABLE- TO BE ABLE
TO EFFORT TO THIS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. SO THAT WOULD BE
YOUR MEAT BAGS PRODUCE BAGS
THOSE BY THAT YOU GET WE'VE
ALREADY. THAT WE CAN PLASTIC BY
AT THE CHECKOUT MISTER PAY MORE
FOR IT THE SAME KIND OF LIKE
THINKING. BUT THIS WOULD BE FOR
THOSE BAGS THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
COMPOSED BILL. ALSO I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT YOU BUT I ALSO HAVE DOGS
AND USE THOSE BAGS LATER. FOR
SAID DOG WALKING- WE WANT THAT
THING TO BE COMPOSTABLE WE DON'T
WANT TO PUT IT IN A BAG AND- IT
FOR. OUR GRAND TO FIND LATER ON-
SO WITH ME TODAY I HAVE NICKEL
CREAM FROM THE CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE WHO ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND I
WOULD INVITE HER FORWARD WENT.
THE COMMITTEE DEEMS IT. HER
TIME. NO COMEDIANS A TIME. THANK
YOU AND PERCY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU KAREN MEMBERS- AS YOU'RE
WELL AWARE CALIFORNIA HAS A
MAJOR PLASTICS PROBLEM. WHILE
PLASTICS ARE MULTI FACETED ISSUE
THAT WILL REQUIRE COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS. PLASTIC PRODUCE BAGS
POSE A UNIQUE CHALLENGE THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED. AS MORE
RESIDENTS GET COMPOSTING SERVICE
MORE AND MORE OF THE PLASTIC
PRODUCE BAGS WE USE FOR FRESH
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES. AND OF
THE COMPOST WASTE STREAMS
CONTAINING MUNICIPAL COFFERS.
BILLS FACILITIES. OBLONG NOT
ONLY INCREASE MICHAEL. IN COMPO
. BUT ALL BE TO INCREASE
HANDLING. AND HIGHER RATES
WORKING- AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BEGIN IMPLEMENTING THE
COMPOSTING REQUIREMENTS SET
FORTH IN SB THIRTY THREE IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE WORK TO ENSURE
OUR WAY STREAMS ARE AS CLEAN AND
UNCONTAMINATED AS POSSIBLE. THE
AVERAGE WORKING LIVE A PLASTIC
BAG IS FIFTEEN MINUTES AND OVER
A HUNDRED TRILLION PLASTIC BAGS
ARE USED WORLDWIDE EACH YEAR. AS
COMMITTEE IS WELL AWARE
CLASSICALLY ARE JOKES BIRDS
TURTLES AND OTHER SENSITIVE
MARINE SPECIES AND PERSIST IN
THE ENVIRONMENT AND DEFINITELY.
SEVERAL STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
CONTAMINATION AND COMPOST WASTE
STREAMS DECREASES WHEN CONSUMERS
HAVE CONVENIENT ACCESS TO
COMPOSTABLE BAGS. IN A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FOOD WASTE COLLECTION
TRIAL IN NEW YORK CITY
COMPOSTABLE BAGS WERE FOUND TO
BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR
REDUCING COMPOSTING
CONTAMINATION. AND THE TRIAL
ALSO FOUND THAT CONSUMERS WERE
ABLE TO MORE SUCCESSFULLY
COLLECT AND IMPLEMENT ORGANIC
WASTE BECAUSE OF THE CONVENIENCE
OF ALREADY HAVING ACCOMPLISHED
BACK ON HAND. SO CALIFORNIA'S
PLASTIC BAG BAN PROVIDED A
CRITICAL STEP FORWARD IN
REMOVING SINGLE USE PLASTIC BAGS
WERE AWAY STREAMS. REPLACING
SOURCES OF FILM PLASTIC
POLLUTION CAN BE DONE COST
EFFECTIVELY WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
SUPPORTING THE STATE'S ORGANIC
WASTE RECYCLING GOALS. WE CAN DO
THIS BY TRANSITIONING TO
ALTERNATIVE. M. S. B. TEN FORTY
SIX WHAT PER PROHIBIT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF PLASTIC PRE
CHECK OUT PRODUCE BAGS UNLESS
THEY'RE REUSABLE RECYCLABLE OR
COMPOSTABLE. AND THIS BILL
PROVIDES CALIFORNIA WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THE NEXT
LOGICAL STEP WHICH WILL BE TO
REMOVE SINGLE USE PLASTIC
PRODUCE BAGS FROM OUR WASTE
STREAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH LET'S NOW GO TO THE PHONE%
LINES ANYONE WITH A VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. SB TEN
FORTY SIX. OR ANYONE IN PERSON.
YOU HEARD A VOICE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SUPPORT OKAY COME ON
UP. GOOD MORNING GERMAN AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M DE COUPLED
WITH CALIFORNIA PRODUCT OF
COUNCIL US VOICE SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU TO. RESET
GOOD MORNING PERSONAL COULD ALSO
BE HAVE A STOP WASTING SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OKAY I SEE NO OTHERS
IN PERSON I WAS GONNA PHONE
LINES MODERATOR FOLKS ONE VOICE
OF TEN SB. TEN FORTY SIX. THANK
YOU MR HERE TO SUPPORT S. B. M.
FORTY SIX PRESSED ZERO UPPER
RIVER LINE NUMBER YOU WAS CALLED
STATE YOUR NAME THE POLLUTION
LEGISLATIVE RECORD WE GOT A LINE
NUMBER SIXTY NINE FIRST ONE
SIXTY GOING PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
MYERS AND OF REACH WASTE IN
SUPPORT. THANKS FOR A LINE
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT WELL. GOOD
MORNING DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF
OF YOUR QUOTE CALIFORNIA AND
SPORT. I ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINES OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS
IS VICTORIA ROME WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT PRISCILLA. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEDGES OF CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
ONE FORTY SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE
. HI MY NAME IS REBECCA AND I AM
CALLING O BEHALF OF MYSELF- AND
I URGE STRONG SUPPORT. MR WITH
ONE MORE KEEPING UP WITH ME JUST
ONE MOMENT. ONE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINES OPEN ONE OF THE THINGS.
THE MORNING CATHY SAFER FOR THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY- CLIMBED
REALITY PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND WITH THAT MISTER
CHEROKEE WAS CLEAR THANK YOU SO
MUCH OKAY- ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
VOICE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL I DON'T
SEE HIM HERE IN PERSON MODERATE
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES.
PROPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO
PLEASE. MR WE HAVE NO PUBLIC
FUELING UP OKAY SORRY THANK YOU
LET'S COME BRING TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS NOW. WE WILL HAVE YES
ALI IT'S IN THE BOOK BILLS A
MOVE BY CENTER WOOD COUNTY. SO-
IS THAT THE COMPOSTABLE BAGS- SO
I KNOW I GET PAPER BAGS
COMPOSTABLE BUT A PLOT OF SOME
THIRTEEN IS NOT PAPER- AND YOU
WANTED TO BE COMPOSED DOUBLE
THAT DOES IT ALLOW FOR THE
TRANSFER OF SO SAY I HAD- MEAT
PRODUCT AND I HAD A LEAFY
LETTUCE PRODUCT AND THEY WORK IN
MY BACK TOGETHER AND I DON'T
WANT TO GET THE- I DON'T CROSS
CONTAMINATION WHAT IS THE
PRODUCT IS AVAILABLE WHAT KIND
OF A PRODUCT WOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO KEEP THAT FROM HAPPENING. DID
YOU MEET DOESN'T TOUCH YOUR YES
LET US SEE SO YES OF THE STORE
I'M TRYING TO I KNOW THAT YOU
CAN USE PAPER AS COMBUST AS A
RIGHT. THERE IN THE SAME BAGHEL
TOUCH NO NO I'M SAYING IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU WANT TO KEEP IT
SEPARATE SO RIGHT NOW IT'S
PACKAGED IN PLASTIC. AND BOTH OF
PLASTIC SO WHAT WHAT THAT LOOK
LIKE- I WILL ASK MY EXPERT
WITNESS MY UNDERSTANDING IS I
MEAN WE ALREADY USE THOSE BAGS
SO IT WOULD KEEP THOSE THINGS
APART BECAUSE LIKE TRADER JOE'S
THERE ARE YOU'RE ALREADY
COMPANIES TO MAKE THESE BAGS
YOU'LL SEE IN THERE KIND OF A
GREENISH COLOR. AND WASHINGTON
HAS PASSED A LAW THAT SAYS THEY
HAVE TO BE GREEN SO PEOPLE WILL
KNOW WHICH ARE WHICH ABOUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IT IS IT WILL KEEP
IT APART MAYBE NOT FOR LONG
TERM- BUT AS LONG AS THE BAG
WOULD ASK I WOULD ASK ME
WITNESSES SHE HAS ANYTHING
FURTHER TO ADD. BUT THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE OF THE
TYPE OF BAGS AND THERE ARE TWO.
COMPANIES TO MAKE THEM THEIR
RESIDENT FOR THESE TYPE OF BAGS
THAT THAT IS ALREADY DEVELOPED
AND ESTABLISHED AND THAT COMPANY
HAS SAID THEY'RE READY TO GIVE
UP MORE BUT YOU GOT MORE
DEFINITIVE OF MISTER KELLY'S
MEETING HER ACT YEAH- SO THERE
ARE COMPOSTABLE. PRODUCE BAGS
THAT RESEMBLE THE CURRENT
PLASTIC PRODUCE BAGS THAT ARE
WIDELY AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW- BUT
THAT YEAH THERE'S TWO COMPANIES
THAT MAKE THE RESIN NOBLE MIND
B. A. S. F. AND THE OTHER
COMPANIES USE THAT RISING TO
MAKE THOSE BAGS- AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE AVAILABLE IN LIKE TRADER
JOE'S- AND SO THOSE THOSE BAGS
HAVE TO MEET COMPOSED ABILITY
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE BILL- AND
THOSE COMPOSED ABILITY
REQUIREMENTS WERE PASSED ON LAST
YEAR AND AB TWELVE ALL ONE- BY
SOME MEMBERS HANG. AND THOSE
COMPOSED ABILITY ARE
REQUIREMENTS JUST TO MAYBE
ELABORATE A BIT. OUR MEETING THE
A. S. C. OF KERR. ABILITY THIRD
PARTY SERVICE. NOT CONTAINING P.
FOSTER AND THEY HAVE TO BE
DISTINGUISHABLE AS A COMPOSTABLE
PRODUCT WHICH INCLUDES LIKE
GREEN LABELING AND SUCH. K. MY
LAST I KNOW THIS IS NOT THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BUT DO
YOU. THERE IN ALICE'S ON WHAT
THE COST TO CONSUMER WOULD BE-
IN THE FUTURE. THE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS BECAUSE THIS IS
ALREADY ESTABLISHED AND-
COMPANIES ARE USING IT- THERE
SHOULDN'T BE A HUGE THE COST
BECAUSE IT'S NOT MESSED UP NOT
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO DEVELOP TO
USE IT SORRY SOMETHING IN USED
IN PRODUCTION. OF COURSE THE
MORE PEOPLE USE OF IT THE- LESS
EXPENSIVE IT IS TO MAKE. OKAY HI
. OF COURSE YOU KNOW. THAT THE
MEAT AND THE VEGETABLES ARE
GONNA DECOMPOSE WAY FASTER THAN
THE- AG- RIGHT YEAH OKAY- THE
ITEM HAS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
CASKEY SOME OF YOU MAY CLOSE I
WOULD JUST ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I THINK IN THIS COMMONSENSE
BILL TO TAKE US A STEP FURTHER
REDUCING THE PLASTIC IN OUR
WASTE STREAM AND REDUCING THE
COSTS FOR FOLKS SO WE DON'T HAVE
TO PAY AS MUCH TO GET IT ALL THE
WAY BECAUSE THE STREAM WILL BE
CLEAN. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT AS A
GROUP ROLE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
TEN FORTY SIX BY SENATOR EGGMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS ALAN I.
ALLEN HI BATES. IT'S NOT VOTING
DALLY. DALLY NOT VOTING GONZALEZ
SKINNER STERN AYE CASKEY HI HI.
OKAY WILL EITHER OPEN FROM
THIRTY ARTS AND ARCHULETA AS
HERE AS AN ARCHER ACTUALLY HAS
TWO BILLS TO PRESENT HIS WITH SB
TWO SEVENTY SIX. I AM SO YOU'RE
A PACKETS MEMBERS. AND WILL
BEGIN WITH TENTS SIX THIS. THAT
THAT'S GREAT IF OKAY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE TIME
TODAY. I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY SIX
WHICH WILL HARMONIZE STATE AND
FEDERAL TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS AND
REGARD SHOULD LEAD BASED LOOK AT
LEAD PAINT- AND RELATED WORK.
TOTAL BRINGING IT TO THE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TOGETHER-
AND WHICH IS IT DESPERATELY
NEEDED CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
CONTRACTORS AND INDIVIDUALS WHO
DO WORK THAT MIGHT DISRUPT LEAD
PAINT. TO BE TRAINED AND
CERTIFIED AT BOTH THE FEDERAL
AND THE STATE LEVELS. THIS HAS
LED TO LOTS OF CONFUSION IN THE
INDUSTRY. TO ADDRESS THIS
CONFUSION SENATE BILL TEN
SEVENTY SIX WOULD REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO ADOPT AND UPDATE THEIR
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS TO REFLECT THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. IN
PRACTICE THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
CONTRACTORS AND INDIVIDUALS TO
BE TRAINED AND CERTIFIED ONCE.
INSTEAD OF CURRENT PRACTICE
WHICH REQUIRES A SEPARATE
TRAINING FOR BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL. ALTHOUGH LEAD PAINT AS
BEEN BANNED IN CALIFORNIA FOR
DECADES LEAD POISONING FROM
EXPOSURE TO LEAD PAINT CONTINUES
TO PLAGUE THE STATE. IN FACT AS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS OFFICE
ESTIMATES THAT ABOUT 60% OF
HOUSES IN CALIFORNIA WERE BUILT
BEFORE NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
AND ARE PRESUMED TO HAVE LEAD
BASED PAINT. THE EXPOSURE TO
LEAD AT ANY LEVEL CAN HAVE
SERIOUS NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF FOR
BOTH CHILDREN AND ADULTS ALIKE.
HOWEVER LEAD EXPOSURE IN
CHILDREN IS A PARTICULAR AREA OF
CONCERN EVEN A SLIGHT ELEVATION
OF IN BLOOD LEVELED- IN A CHILD
CAN REDUCE IQ CAUSE BRAIN OR
NERVE DAMAGE AND EVEN STUNT IN
CHILD GROWTH. EXPOSURE TO LEAD
IS COMMON AMONG AND DURING
RENOVATION AND RECONSTRUCTION.
UNTRAINED INDIVIDUAL WHO DOES
NOT FOLLOW PROPER PROTOCOLS CAN
UNKNOWINGLY CHIPPED PAINT LEAD
BASED PAINT IT TWO YARDS OR SEND
UP CLOUDS OF LEAD PAINT DUST ARE
CAUSING THE PROBLEMS TO THE
NEIGHBORS AND SURROUNDING AREAS
. UNTRAINED UNCERTIFIED
INDIVIDUALS WORKING WITH LEAD
PAINT POSE A HAZARD NOT JUST TO
THEMSELVES BUT TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY
SIX ADDRESSES THIS LEAD ISSUE BY
STREAMLINING AND HARMONIZING OUR
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION
PROCESS AND AT THE SAME TIME
STRAIGHT IN OUR OVERSIGHT BY
EMPOWERING LOCAL TO HANDLE THIS
ISSUE. IN ADDITION THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD. TO COLLABORATE AND
IMPLEMENT AN EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH PROGRAMS TO INFORM
INDIVIDUALS OF THE HARMS OF LEAD
AND THE REQUIREMENTS TO BE
TRAINED AND CERTIFIED. THE
OUTREACH PROGRAM WILL RUN FOR
ONE YEAR BEFORE CRTIFICATION
AND TRAINED A REQUIREMENTS WILL
BE FORCED AND ENFORCE. GIVE
EXAMPLE GIVING EVERYONE AMPLE
TIME RATHER TO COMPLY FOURTEEN
OTHER STATES HAVE ALREADY
STREAMLINED THEIR REGULATIONS TO
HARMONIZE BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS THIS BILL I
RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION AND IS
SUPPORTED BY A NUMBER OF HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
AFTER I VOTE. AND WITH ME TODAY
I HAVE SUSAN LITTLE OF
REPRESENTING THE BUYER METAL
WORKING GROUP. ON THE PHONE IS-
LARRY BROOKS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. THANK YOU
MAY PROCEEDMAY THANK. BYE AND
BYE THE WAY PLAY- I- WRIST ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE YES I WOULD. HAVE
EXPECTED OKAY SO LET'S GO WITH
THIS WITH YOU MISLED. IT'S A
LITTLE I'M WHAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF SB TEN
SEVENTY SIX. AND AS THE SENATOR
HAD EXPLAINED HAS EXPLAINED- AND
AS YOU ALL KNOW LEAD IS HARMFUL
TO CHILDREN AND ADULTS. BUT
YOUNG CHILDREN ARE THE MOST
SENSITIVE TO THE EFFECTS OF LEAD
AND IN FACT. A CHILD'S EXPOSURE
TO EVEN MINUTE AMOUNTS OF LEAD
CAN HARM THEIR BRAIN. AND THEIR
NERVOUS SYSTEM AS IT DEVELOPS.
LOW LEVELS OF LEAD EXPOSURE CAN
CAUSE CHILDHOOD BEHAVIORAL AND
LEARNING PROBLEMS THAT LAST WELL
INTO ADULTHOOD. AND WE KNOW NOW
THAT UNFORTUNATELY THIS DAMAGE
THAT LED DOES IS A REVERSIBLE IT
IS A LOT IT IS A LIFE LONG.
CHALLENGE THAT THEY WILL HAVE.
BECAUSE OF THIS THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL HAD DETERMINED
THERE'S NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD.
AND HEARING CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY THIS TO STATISTICS
INDICATE. THAT LOW INCOME
CHILDREN OUR LEAD POISONED MORE
OFTEN THAN CHILDREN FROM HIGHER
INCOME FAMILIES. 88% THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
INDICATE SAYS THAT EIGHTY EIGHT
PERCENT. OF CALIFORNIA'S LEAD
POISONED CHILDREN ARE ON
MEDICAID. ON AN THIS IN ANY
DISTRIBUTION ISN'T. BECAUSE LOW
INCOME CHILDREN OF COURSE ARE.
LIVE ARE MORE LIKELY TO LIVE AN
OLDER HOUSING. THAT HAS CHIPPED-
AND PEELING LEAD BASED PAINT.
AND OF COURSE WHEN THIS PAINT IS
DISTURBED OR MOBILE IT IT
MOBILIZES INTO DUST AND OTHER
PAINT CHIPS. AND IT CAN BE
INHALED INGESTED TRACKED AND
OTHER LOCATIONS OTHER FOLKS
HOMES- LET PAID SAY PAINT A
RENOVATION TO THE LEAD SAFE
PAINT READ IT. LET SAFE PAINT
RENOVATION PRACTICES ARE NOT
BEING CONSISTENTLY PRACTICING
CALIFORNIA IN LARGE PART DUE TO
THIS THE DIS LOT OF
DISCREPANCIES BETWEEN AND
CONFUSION BETWEEN STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS. AND MANY OTHER
STATES FOURTEEN OTHER STATES
HAVE ALREADY DONE WHAT THIS BILL
PROPOSES TO DO WHICH WOULD BE TO
HARMONIZE THOSE TWO SETS OF LAWS
AND ENSURE THAT THEY ARE-
TOGETHER AND- IMPLEMENTED
ENFORCED HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
WE'D APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT SO LET'S NOT
HEAR FROM YOU LARRY BROOKS.
THANK YOU BUT TO THE HONORABLE.
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE LARRY BROOKS ALAMEDA
COUNTY HEALTHY HOMES AND ALSO AS
THE MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR CASEY- I GREET YOU
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA. OF
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO
ARE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
HISTORICALLY IMPORTANT BILL THAT
WE SO APPRECIATE SENATOR ARE TO
LET. OF THE COLDER FOR SPIN
OFFICER IN A HEALTHY HOUSING. I
AND OTHERS LIKE ME THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ROUTINELY RECEIVED
COMPLAINTS FROM RESIDENTS
REGARDING UNLICENSED. PERFORMING
RENOVATION AND OR REPAIR WORK ON
HOMES IN WHICH THEY CREATE LEAD
PAINT CHIPS AND DUST DEBRIS THAT
CAN BE INHALED BY ADULTS IN
DIRECTLY AND JUSTIFIES CHILDREN
CRAWLING ON FLOORS ARE PLANING
CONTAMINATED SOIL. THUS THE
INDIVIDUALS. THESE UNSAFE
RENOVATION AND PAINTING JOBS
HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO NOT ONLY
POISON THEIR CUSTOMERS AND
NEIGHBORS OF THEIR CUSTOMERS BUT
EVEN THEMSELVES IN THEIR OWN.
CHILDREN AND SUCH TRY. COULD
HAVE BEEN OF IF THESE WORKERS
USE LET'S SAY WORK FOR. TAUGHT
IN THE DAY ONLY. EPA RENOVATION
AND PAINTING RULE COURSE ALSO
KNOWN AS R. P. WHICH IS OFFERED
BY STATE CERTIFIED INSTRUCTORS
SO SORRY MISTER BROOKS WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE- IF I DO SAYS HE
WRAP UP YOUR- WE'RE JUST KEEPING
THE KEEPING OUR- OUR TIMELINES.
OKAY ALL TOLD THERE IS
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
COLIN FORSMAN OFFICERS ARE IN
THE INTERSECTION OF HOUSING
PRESERVATION AND HELP. HIM WITH
THAT RECOGNITION COMES THE
EXPECTATION THAT WE WILL PREVENT
LEAD POISONING HAZARDS FROM
BEING CREATED BY UNSAFE
PRACTICES AND THIS BILL WILL DO
THAT HELP US. PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY
I DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE OF
YOU'RE HERE TO TEST FINDS.
OPPOSITION CONCERNS. DID YOU
EVER HAVE GREAT YES SORRY YOU'RE
JUST THERE WAITING TO HAVE
QUESTIONS OKAY GOTCHA. I MY
ANYWAY HAS- AND ANYWAY WANT TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL ON ON
THE PHONE LINES. AND I TO
CONTAMINATE HE WISHED TO BE IN
SUPPORT OF. AS YOU CAN SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS. ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. AND FIRST WE HAVE THE LINE
OF SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HIS BIGGEST BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE
HAVE LINE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JIM WOOD
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION-
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT. AT
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE MARKED
HEALING UP.
THAT MOTOR. I'M ARE JUST LAST
ONE ARE IN HERE NOW IS BLIND TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ANDREA. WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH HI ANYONE WANT
TO VOICE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
VILLA POSITION HERE IN PERSON
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
ANY REGISTER OF PETITIONS BUT-
MAYBE. THANK YOU WANT AGAIN
LADIES AND IF YOU WISH IF OFF
THE- SP AND SEVEN THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NOBODY WANTED AND WENT AGAIN.
NOW I HAVE NO ONE HEARING OTHER
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIS IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE SERTOLI. THANKS
FOR BEING THIS BILL FOR WE DON'T
ALLOW OF IN THE SERVICE AFTER
THE XII THE- PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAD. IT WHAT ARE YOUR WHAT.
SPOKE YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT ARE.
THIS AND THEY'RE NOT. TO BE ABLE
DO. SO THESE LICENSE CONTRACTORS
OR THESE. UNLICENSED CONTRACT
THAT'S WHO I. WAS THERE ANY DATA
ON WHO'S DOING THE WHO BECAUSE
OF THEIR UNLICENSED. OR IT'S A
HOMEOWNER THIS ACTUALLY JUST
REPAINTING THEIR HOUSE AND DON'T
KNOW- THAT DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS A RISK. SO IS THERE
ANY DATA THAT'S BEEN GATHERED
ON. ON WHO'S ACTUALLY DOING
THESE THE WORK. THAT WE TURN
THAT OVER TO THE EXPERT. FOR
WHAT WE KNOW IS ACTUALLY THIS
BILL DOES NOT APPLY TO THE
INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNER. WOULD
APPLY TO SOMEONE WHO IS HIRED TO
DO THE WORK. SO WE KNOW THAT-
I'M ACTUALLY REFER TO DEFER TO
LARRY BROOKS WAS ON THE CALL
BECAUSE HE IS. WITH THE CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER SOMEONE KNOW
THE STATISTICS ON THIS BUT- IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT A LARGE
PART OF THE PROBLEM COMES FROM
UNLICENSED CONTRACTORS. AND
OFTEN TIMES THESE ARE FOLKS WERE
OUT WE'RE GETTING THE LICENSE
CONTRACTORS BECAUSE THEY ARE-
NOT. PERFORMING THE LEAD SAFE
WORK AND ARE ABLE TO CUT
UNDERCUT UNDERCUT THE- BETTER
ACTORS IN THE INDUSTRY AND SO.
WE DO HAVE A IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SUPPORT OFFICE THE SUPPORT LIST.
WE DO HAVE THEM INFORM
CONTRACTOR SINCE. ALL RIGHT WHY
I KNOW THAT SO THIS IS THAT. THE
A CLASSIC CASE OF. THE PERSON
THAT'S DOING IT RIGHT IS GETTING
PENALIZED AGAIN TO GO TO CLASS
AGAIN AND THE PERSON IS NOT
DOING IT RIGHT. WHO IS IT
PUTTING. THEIR FAMILY AND OTHER
PEOPLE AT RISK IS THERE'S AND
THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME WAY TO GO
OUT TO THE UNLICENSED PERSON WHO
IS. THAT WHAT WE'RE REGULATING
THE LOOK THE LICENSE PERSONS
AGAIN. AND THAT'S THAT'S BEEN
MY- YOU KNOW FRUSTRATION AS
ALLEGED. WHERE WE GO AFTER WE
CAN TO ADD MORE- TO THE PERSON
ALREADY. THAT IT'S THIS A THAT
WE WERE DO IT AND A ON SAFE. SO
SOME AND IF THE LAW LEVEL RIGHT
I SERVED FOR SIX YEARS- THOSE
ARE THE THOSE ARE THE PLAYS WE
NEED TO GIVE THEM THAT RE. TO BE
TO GO OUT. AND THAT GO OUT THE
BAD. WHO ARE UNDERCUTTING THE
LEGITIMATE CONT WHOSE. THE LAW
INSTEAD OF MAKING MORE LAWS TO
MAKE IT HARDER FOR THE LICENSE
CONTRACTOR EVEN BID AGAIN SO
THAT'S WHY I SWITCH FROM TRENT
REYES. WHO ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ACTUALLY BREAKING THE LAW
ALREADY RIGHT NOW YOU NEED TO
HAVE YOU NEED TO TAKE CARE OF WE
HAVE PLENTY LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
TO FOUR REGULATED OF LEAD
DISPOSAL PAINT. BEEN AROUND FOR
A SOME TIME AND WE'VE DISCUSSED
THESE THINGS IN THIS COMMITTEE
OVER THE LAST. YOU KNOW FIVE OR
SIX YEARS AND WHEN I WAS IN THE
SAME WAY WE DID A LOT OF WORK ON
LAND. IN THE END OF. CAME OUT OF
THE ACTS SIX. THAT WE SAW IN
THE- THAT DIRECTLY IN. BY LEAD
BASED NOT ONLY GOOD TEN. FROM
SMELTING ALSO LEAD BASED PAINT
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES SO I'M- A
SOMEWHAT- HESITANT TO. REGULATE
SOMEBODY WHO'S ALREADY REGULATE
I WANT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GO
AFTER THAT UNREGULATED PEOPLE
WHO REALLY THE PROBLEM THEY'RE
THEY'RE UNDER VETTING THESE
LICENSE CONTRACTORS. AND THE
HOMEOWNER DOESN'T KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE. AT THE END OF THE
DAY THERE JUST WANTED TO GET
THEIR HOME. REPAINTED OR OR THE
PAINT REMOVED AND SO THERE HAS
TO BE SOME ABILITY TO. GO AFTER
THE BAD ACTORS AND QUIT- MAKING
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN LICENSE ALREADY- TO
MEET THE LAW YEAH IT'S SENATOR
IF I MAY. REMEMBER I HAD JUST
MENTIONED WE HAVE THE FEDERAL
LAW THAT'S ALREADY ESTABLISHED
AND WE HAVE THE STATE LAW ALL
THE GOING TO DO JUST JOIN
TOGETHER SO ALL THESE-
INSPECTORS CAN GO OUT AND GET
ONE CERTIFICATION WHICH JOINS US
TOGETHER FEDERAL AND STATE. AND
THESE ARE THE ISSUES YOU TALKED
ABOUT GRANTED ARE OUT THERE THE
CALIFORNIA SO REAL. AT FORM THAT
YOU TO EACH SELLER OF A PIECE OF
PROPERTY OF COURSE WE'RE ALL
LOOKING AT IT THIS BILL PERTAINS
TO JOINING TOGETHER HAVE ONE
INSPECTION- IN ONE REQUIREMENT
ONE CERTIFICATION. BETWEEN THE
STATE AND FEDERAL ELIMINATE-
WOULD YOU TALKING TO BUT YOU TO
MAKE IT. IN THE WHY WE'RE GONNA
DO THEN ON LOCAL. BECAUSE THERE
IS MY FROM THE- WHERE THE COW
SINCE. WERE A TO PAY FOR AND HOW
. ADDITION FOR SEARCH- THE END
TO GO OUT AND THE HOUSE AND ON
SO THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT. OKAY
BECAUSE THE SEVEN THOUSAND
PENALTY IF YOU HAVE A BY RIGHT
YES SIR. OKAY TO HEAR A MOTION
SIR WESLEY YEAH YEAH OKAY GREAT
THE YOU I. THREE RECKLESS- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK I BOUGHT
TRANSACTION PLEASE CALL. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY OUR I ALAN I BATES.
VALLEY ASSEMBLY NOT VOTING. AND. FROM THE START- THE INSIDE
GONZALEZ I SEE. SKINNER I STERN
I CAN LIFELIKE I'D- OKAY WE HAVE
FIVE VOTES WILL THE ROLE OPEN
FOR YOU I THINK TO GET MY VOTES
IS OTHER MEMBERS BACK- BUT YOU
GO AHEAD AND- AND ALSO PRESENT
YOUR NEXT BILL TO THE SENATE
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU THE CHAIRMAN OF TODAY
AND PRESENTING SENATE BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR I WOULD LIKE
TO FIRST THANK. YOUS AND- TO
BEGIN TO LET YOU KNOW THAT WE
HAVE WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH YOU
AND YOUR COMMITTEE AND ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS. OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND WE THINK THE CHAIR-
AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ADD TO MAKE THIS BILL WHERE
IT IS TODAY AND I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- AS AMENDED SENATE BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR WILL ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM OF MANGANESE IN
CALIFORNIA'S WATER SYSTEMS THE
CENTRAL BASIN REGION. IS IN MY
OWN DISTRICT AND HAS HAD CHRONIC
ISSUES WITH OUR WATER AND
PACIFIC LEAD MAGNETS WHICH IS
WHY I FELT THE NEED. TO AUTHORED
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. MATT
MATERIAL. FOUND NATURALLY IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND IT'S ONE OF THE
MOST ABUNDANT METALS AND THE
EARTH'S SURFACE THAT IS FOUND IN
THE AIR. WATER AND SOIL AND
COULD BE FOUND IN BOTH
GROUNDWATER AND SURFACE WATER
FROM NATURAL SOURCES OR BECAUSE
OF HUMAN ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
MINING OR INDUSTRIAL
DISCHARGERS. BALCONIES IS IN
WATER CAN CAUSE. AS THE STATIC
ISSUES SUCH AS- METALLIC TASTING
OF THE WATER. METALLIC TASTING
OF WATER. AND BLACK STAINS ON
TUBS SHOWERS TOILETS PLUMBING
FIXTURES AND LAUNDRY. THAT IS
HAVE ALSO. IN THE SOCHI ATION
BETWEEN EXPOSURE TO MANGANESE IN
DRINKING WATER AND NEUROLOGICAL
ISSUES IT INFANTS AND CHILDREN
THIS INCLUDES CHANGING OF
BEHAVIOR LOWERED OUR Q. S.
SPEECH IMPEDIMENTS OF MEMORY
LEFT DIFFICULTIES AND LACK OF
COORDINATION. AND MOVEMENT
CONTROL. AND IT'S THOUGHT THAT
BAG IN THESE AS A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
CHILDREN AND ELDERLY AND PEOPLE
SUFFERING FROM LEVEL- LIVER
DISEASE. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT IN TWENTY TWELVE
CALIFORNIA BECAME THE FIRST
STATE IN THE NATION TO
LEGISLATIVELY RECOGNIZE THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER. IN THE
WATER CODE THE STATE'S
STATUTORILY RECOGNIZES THAT
EVERY HUMAN. EVERY HUMAN BEING
HAS THE RIGHT TO SAFE CLEAN
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE WATER
ADEQUATE FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION.
COOKING AND SANITARY PURPOSES WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES TODAY AND SENATE
BILL ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. WITH
THAT BEING SAID SENATE ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR AS AMENDED AND AS
AMENDED REPRESENTS A RESPONSIBLE
AND THOUGHTFUL SOLUTION TO HELP
BOTH THE CENTRAL BASIN REGION
AND CALIFORNIA AT LARGE TO
ACHIEVE OUR WATER GOALS. SENATE
BILL ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR FIRST
REQUIRES THE OFFICE TO PROVIDE.
HEALTH HAZARD ASSESSMENT TO
PREPARE A PUBLIC HEALTH GOAL FOR
MAGGIE'S BY JULY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. WHAT'S THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH GOAL HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
REQUIRES THE STATE WATER BOARD
TO ADAPT A PRIMARY DRINKING
WATER STANDARD FOR MANGANESE AND
ESTABLISH APPROPRIATE MONITORING
REQUIREMENTS IN BOTH SOURCE
WATER AND THE DISTRIBUTE
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO ESTABLISH A PRIMARY
DRINKING STANDARD FOR MACINNES
BECAUSE MAGGIE NEEDS ITS SOUL
SOUL- COCCYX CONCEPTUALIZES
BECAUSE A PRIMARY DRINKING
STANDARDS OR ENFORCEABLE-
HEALTH- ISSUES. HOWEVER
SECONDARY STANDARDS ARE NOT
ENFORCEABLE GUIDELINES.
REGULATING COSMETIC OR AESTHETIC
EFFECTS MACINNES IS CURRENTLY
CLASSIFIED AS A SECONDARY
STANDARD MAKING. THIS BILL
NECESSARY. DURING THIS PERIOD
ADD THE OF PRIOR TO ADOPTION THE
PRIMARY DRINKING WATER STANDARD
FOR BAGGIES SENATE BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR WE'RE DIRECT THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO CONSIDER
ESTABLISHING NOTIFICATION AND
RESPONSE LEVEL FOR MAGNITUDE
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
ALSO AUTHORIZES THE WATER BOARD
TO REQUIRED COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEMS. TO MONITOR FOR BAG
INDIES IN THEIR SOURCE WATER
WITHIN THEIR DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM
AS WELL AS AUTHORIZED THEM TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
TREATMENT AND SOURCE PROTECTION.
FINALLY SENATE BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR ALLOWS FOR THE USE
OF EXCEEDING THE SECONDARY
STANDARD FOR MAGNETS IN THE
SOURCE WATER OR WITHIN THE
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM OF A
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEM AS A
BASIS FOR FUNDING PRIORITIZE
ATION. AS OF. SENATE BILL TWENTY
FOUR WOULD DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE
THE WATER AND THE CENTRAL BASIN
REGION AS WELL AS HELPING BRING
THE FUNDING FOR THE REGION WHERE
70% OF CUSTOMERS COME FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
STARTED AS A THIRD DISTRICT BILL
BUT NOW IS INVOLVED IN TO BECOME
A GREAT STEP FORWARD TO ENSURING
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE ABLE
TO TRUST THAT WATER. DOES NOT
CONTAIN DANGEROUS LEVELS OF
MANGANESE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE THIS
IMPORTANT BILL DARROW LUCIENNE.
ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRAL BASIN
WATER DISTRICT WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER TWO MILLION PEOPLE I
RESPECT GAS ROUTE RESPECT AFTER
AYE VOTE. WE'LL GO TO DINNER I
ALSO HAVE THAT DANIEL BLESSED
HANDS HERE IS. YES OKAY- YOU ARE
THEIR FIRST AT THE PLAN LET'S GO
TO EUROPE I WANT TESTIFY AND
THEN. THE DAY YOU KNOW YOU CAN
PRESS THE- DICE. ZERO THANK YOU
THANK YOU OF THE CHAIRMAN-
APPEARED DILUTION HERE TO
FINALLY. OF THE CENTRAL BASED
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT.
PLEASED TO WORK WITH THE CHAIR
TO COME UP WITH- WHAT IS A
MAKEABLE SOLUTION TO RESPOND TO.
A NUMBER OF REPORTS THAT HAVE
COME OUT CONCERNING THE-
CONCENTRATE. OF MANGANESE.
ARAMBULA INTO THE- SCIENCE HERE
TO ESTABLISH. IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH GOAL AND THEN THAT MAXIM
GROUP. LEVEL THAT WILL HELP I
GUIDE THE REGION ALL WHAT THE
BEST PRACTICES SHOULD BE NOTED
TO SAFELY. DELIVER WATER TO- ALL
THE HOUSEHOLDS IN OUR REGION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH TARA. OKAY I. UNDERSTAND
THAT THE DETAILS CAN BE RAISING
SOME. ABOUT THE BILL SO LET'S GO
TO THE PHONE LINES SEE IF
ANYONE'S GOT ANY. ANY ANY- FOLKS
WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT. FOR SB.
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. ON THE PHONE
LINES AND I DID. BELIEVE THEM
YOU WISH HE CAN OF STEEL TO FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF.
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. OKAY LET'S
GO LET'S HEAR FROM THEM I HAVE
NO AND YET OKAY THANK YOU. FIVE
TO SAY IT IS SO GOOD TO BE BACK
IN PERSON NICE TO SEE ONCE ACES-
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE DANIEL BLESSED HAD
WITH CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION. ARE FIFTY
FIVE PUBLIC WATERAGENCY MEMBERS
SERVE RETAIL OR WHOLESALE WATER
275% OF CALIFORNIANS- WE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED TO THE
CURRENT VERSION A HAVE SB ELEVEN
NINE OR ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. BUT
I REALIZE THE AUTHOR HAS
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. I WON'T GO THROUGH
WHAT OUR CONCERNS ARE WITH THE
VERSION AND FRANK AS I KNOW IT'S
GOING TO CHANGE. BUT I DID WANT
TO FOCUS ON THE FACT THAT OUR
MEMBERS ARE COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING THEIR CUSTOMERS WITH A
SAFE AND RELIABLE WATER SUPPLY
AND THEY ALSO CONSISTENTLY LOOK
FOR WAYS TO ADVANCE ACCESS TO
SAFE AND RELIABLE SUPPLY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. INCLUDING THOSE IN
THE CENTRAL BASIN REGION AHEAD
IN FACT I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT ANOTHER BILL THE MOVES
THE NEEDLE FORWARD ON THAT
ISSUE- WE HAVE NOT TAKEN. THE
NEW LANGUAGE TO OUR COMMITTEE
FOR CONSIDERATION YET SO SENIOR
IT IS NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION WE APPRECIATE THE
SIGNIFICANT WORK AT THAT I KNOW
HAS GONE INTO- READING THE-
AMENDMENTS BY. COMMITTEE ALSO
THE AUTHOR CYPRUS THAT WE DO
EXPECT TO HAVE CONCERNS ON THE
NEW LANGUAGE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE. AND
ALSO THE AUTHOR TO TRY AND
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AND I'M-
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT MANGANESE. LEAVE A LEAVE
THAT- TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
VIRGINIA AND I MEAN OBVIOUSLY I
KNOW YOU'RE- FEELING MUCH BETTER
ABOUT IT THAN YOU WERE BEFORE
MAY I KNOW YOU THERE'S ALSO SOME
CONCERNS- I WOULDN'T SAY THAT
WE'RE FEELING BETTER ABOUT.
FEWER BEFORE IT'S JUST THAT IT'S
A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
OUTSIDE OF ISSUE IT'S A
DIFFERENT ISSUE AND FOR THE
RECORD SECONDARY AND SEALS. ARE
IN FACT ENFORCEABLE IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S JUST THAT
THEY'RE BASED ON AESTHETICS AND
NOT ON PUBLIC HEALTH REFER YOU
ARE VERY OPPOSED TO THE
PRODUCERS. I WOULD VERY FOCUSED
REVIEWS. OKAY ALL RIGHT HOW. WE
GO TO THE PHONE LINES IF ANYONE
WANTS TO AND- ADD. VOICE
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL. INTERMIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR. ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND FIRST WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS ADAM
KING HONEST I'L BE HAPPY SAYS
STATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES- SO LIKE IN YELLOW- WE
TALK WE DID NOT HAVE A POSITION
ON THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS BUT I DID WANT
EXPRESS- TRONG CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS- FIRST
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AT THE
ANNUAL MENTIONED THERE IS
ALREADY A SECONDARY DRINKING
WATER STANDARDS FOR MANGANESE-
SO WATER SYSTEMS ALREADY MONITOR
REPORT ON MANGANESE BECAUSE THE
DISCOLORATION- THE STATE WATER
BOARD IS. AS DANIEL STATE HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO ISSUE PENALTIES
FOR- VIOLATION OF THE MANGANESE
MCL UP TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
DAY- AND SO IF THERE IS THE
DESIRE TO HAVE THE OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT TAKE ADDITIONAL
ACTION ON THE NEWS YOU COULD
ENCOURAGE THEM TO REVIEW THE
CURRENT SCIENCE- AND DETERMINE
IF A PUBLIC HEALTH GOAL IS
NEEDED I THINK. YOU KNOW THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE ASSUMES THAT
WE HOW CAN DEVELOP A PUBLIC
HEALTH WILL BY NEXT YEAR WHICH
IS A TIGHT TIMELINE BUT IT
PRESUPPOSES THAT A PUBLIC HEALTH
BOTHUSE IF NEEDED AND
CIRCUMVENTS YOU KNOW A REALLY
IMPORTANT SCIENTIFIC REGULATORY
PROCESS THAT IS. THOROUGHLY DONE
BY WE HAVE- IN THE STATE WATER
BOARD SO I'M I WOULD ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE ARE
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS MANGANESE
CONTAMINATION- THE CALIFORNIA
DRINK WATER REVOLVING. COULD BE
YOU ON TO ADDRESS MANY ISSUES-
AS WELL AS I DID GROUND YOU KNOW
FUNDING THAT STATE WATER BOARD
IS IT. YOU KNOW YEAR THE
GOVERNOR. UP AND LEGISLATURE
APPROVED SIX HUNDRED FIFTEEN
DOLLARS. IN DEBT WATER SRF FOR
PROJECTS LIKE THIS- SO WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THAT THAT THAT YOU
KNOW FUNDING FOR MAINLY FOR
MEDIATION. BE INCENTIVIZED- AND
LET THE CURRENT REGULATORY
PROCESS YOU KNOW KIND OF WORK
THE WAY IT HAS- FOR SO LONG SO-
THANK YOU WERE THAT HAPPY TO.
WORK WITH. YOU GOING FORWARD.
THE TERM. OKAY I'M OKAY SO. LET
ME JUST START BY- PHARMACY
THINKING THAT THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US AND CRAFTING AN
ALTERNATIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING SOME OF THESE UNIQUE
DRINKING WATER ISSUES AND IN
SOUTHERN LOS ANGELES COUNTY- WE
GOT DEEP INTO THE REPORT TO YOU
THAT I THINK ORIGINALLY INSPIRED
THE ORIGINAL BILL AND- AND ONE
THING BECAME LOUD AND CLEAR
THROUGH THE REPORT WAS THE ISSUE
OF MANGANESE POLLUTION- OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN-
GRAB SAMPLES TAKEN FROM THE
WATER IN SOUTHERN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY- MY CA WHERE YOUR PRESENT
AND WE SHOWED. THEY SHOWED
EXIGENCES OF MANGANESE IN
DRINKING WATER MULTIPLE TIMES
ABOVE THE EPA ADVISORY LEVEL
WHICH YOU KNOW RAISED A WHOLE
SLEW OF HEALTH OF HEALTH
CONCERNS AFTER YOUR LOGICAL
IMPACTS- BUT YOU HAVE. THE WATER
QUALITY SAN IS ONLY. THERE'S NO
REQUIRE FOR TREATMENT SO. WE SO
OUR GOAL THROUGH THE BILL AT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
IS TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY
REQUIRING A WE HAVE. TO PREPARE
A PUBLIC HEALTH GOAL FOR
MANGANESE. ONCE THE GOALS
ESTABLISHED IN REQUIRING THAT.
THE WATER BOARD TO ADOPT THE
PRIMARY DRINKING WATER CENTER
FOR MANGANESE IN THE INTERIM
AUTHORIZING THAT. THE WATER
BOARD TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR TREATMENT SOURCE
PROTECTION. AND ALTERNATIVE
SUPPLIES- AND THEN ALSO THE
WATER BOARD TO USE EXCEEDED SAYS
OF THE SECONDARY STANDARD. FOR
MANGANESE IN THE SOURCE WATER OR
WITHIN THE DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM
OF A COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEM AS A
BASIS FOR FUNDING.
PRIORITIZATION I HEARD THE
ARGUMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY SOME
FOLKS WANTED TO RAISE. CONCERNS
ADAM AND DANIELLE. I'M CERTAINLY
ONE IT WILL WILL. DO YOU CAN
WORKING WITH YOU HI- ONE OF THE
OBJECTS WAS THAT WATER. AT TO
THE WHEN THE OBJECTION AS IDEA
OF THE WATER BOARD- ESTABLISHING
A PRIMARY DRINKING WATER CENTER
FOR MANGANESE BEFORE WE HAVE TO.
HAS CONDUCTED THE SCIENCE I
GUESS WE JUST POINT OUT THAT THE
LANGUAGE DIRECTS WE HAD TO SET A
PUBLIC HEALTH GOAL. THAT'S THE
SCIENCE RIGHT. I'M BEFORE THE
BOARD ESTABLISH ITS DRINKING
WATER STANDARD. I AM SO I THINK
THAT THAT ISSUE IS HIS ADDRESS
IN OUR MEN'S AND- YEAH THE OTHER
THING IS THAT- HI. I'VE EITHER
THE QUESTION BY THE END WHETHER
IT'S UNNECESSARY. YOU KNOW THE
OF COURSE I SITES MY- BELIEF
THAT THE BILL WILL GIVE THE
FOLKS IT AT WE HAD THE BOARD. A
PUSH IN THE BUDGETARY AUTHORITY
DOWN THE ROAD AND TO DO THIS. TO
DO THIS WORK TO STUDY AND
DEVELOP THE DRINKING WATER
STANDARD AND FOCUS ON THIS
ISSUE. AND SO. YOU KNOW I THINK
THE END OF THE DAY WE GOT TO A
GOOD PLACE- BUT- BUT BUT I'M
CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN WORKING
WITH OUR OUR FRIENDS FROM THE
AGENCIES TO AN- TO. TO GET
SCATTERED THEIR ISSUES ADDRESSED
BUT I WILL SAY. THIS REPORT WAS
PRETTY SHOCKING ABOUT THE
MANGANESE LEVELS AND WHATEVER
WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE WORKING- AND SO I I'M
SEEING THIS BILL. AS A WAY FOR
US TO PUSH ON THIS ISSUE. AND I
THINK YOU MISTER FOR REC. THAT
IN ALL COMMITTEE. I THINK ALL OF
US. IN OUR- RESPECTIVE THIS.
WERE OUT. ALWAYS ABOUT. CLEAN
WATER AND- EVERYTHING PERTAINING
TO THE HEALTH. OF OUR- AND
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT I BEEN
ABLE TO WORK WITH YOU. MISTER J.
AND WE WALK. TO DO THAT. IN
FINALLY PUT THIS THING. TOGETHER
WHERE EVERYONE WILL AGREE THAT
WE'VE GOT TO TAKE CARE OF THE
CONSTITUENTS. AND IS A NO STEP
FORWARD. AND I THINK WITH THE
WORK THAT AHEAD. WILL BE. TO
THAT WORK. WITH YOUR OFFICE AND
EVERYONE THAT IS GOOD. CHOI
LOOKING FOR. TO CAN. THAT RELATE
. AND TO ME. THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THAT'S THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- YOU SENATOR UP
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD SINCE
THIS ISN'T A DIFFERENT VERSION.
TOO WOULD LIKE TO JUST CONTINUE
TO. BE ENGAGED WITH YOU- I'M AS
YOU KNOW THIS- THAT TOUCHES BOTH
OF OUR DISTRICTS AND I WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE TALKING TO.
EACH OF THE- STAKEHOLDERS
WHETHER THEY OPPOSE OR THEY
SUPPORT TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING THE FULL CONTEXT OF
WHAT. YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS THAT
WE NEED TO. CONTINUE TO WORK ON
BUT I ALSO THINK THE COMMITTEE.
FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE FORWARD
AND ALTHOUGH THERE ARE OTHER-
PROCESSES IN PLACE FOR AT
TACKLING MANGANESE I THINK THAT.
FOCUSING SPECIFICALLY AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES I
THINK IS A GREAT APPROACH- AND
SAID LOVE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT I WILL. SUPPORT
THIS. BILL TODAY BUT I LOOK FOR
TO ONGOING DISCUSSIONS WITH AND
I THANK YOU FOR THAT. AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEE WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS WOULD LOOK LIKE AT
THE END. SO WE CAN TAKE OF ALL
TAKE CARE OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
OKAY ARE I WILL TAKE THAT AS A
MOTION- AND- WITH THAT WILL ASK
YOU TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY YEAR
I WROTE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER OKAY- SIGNIFICADO.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
THE MOTION AS HE PASSES AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER ALLEN AYE
ALLEN AYE BATES. IT'S NOT VOTING
TALLY VOTING TALLYING VOTING
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I SKINNER.
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN. AYE
CASKEY AYE AYE CASKEY AYE.
THAT'S NOT. WELL BELIEVE THE
ROLE OF FURTHER- GET OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON HERE I WILL
GRAB GO TO- CENTER HERTZBERG
WHO'S YOUR PRESENT SB. TWELVE
FIFTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. THIS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
. IN THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THERE WILL. ASSESSOR TO SENATOR
DODD- INTRODUCED A BILL THAT WE
VOTE MOST OF US VOTED ON AND-
WAS SUCCESSFUL. THAT DEALT WITH-
APPOINTING ADMINISTRATORS TO- DO
YOU WITH SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD ADULT WITH THIS
MEASURE YOU HAVE YOUR FOR TODAY
IS WHAT OFTEN HAPPENS IN
GOVERNMENT WHEN WE HAVE A GOOD
IDEA AND WE LOOK AT THE
PRACTICAL IMPLICATIONS AND HOW
DOES IT ACTUALLY WORKING IT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE COURSE
CORRECTED DOESN'T TO BE FURTHER
DEALT WITH AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE TODAY STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD I THINK
MOST OF THE MEMBERS KNOW.
REGULAR EXPRESSIONS SEVEN
HUNDRED- WATER SYSTEMS ONE THIRD
OF THOSE WATER SYSTEMS ARE
FAIRLY SMALL RANGING FROM
FIFTEEN TO TWO HUNDRED. SERVICE
CONNECTIONS AND A NUMBER OF
BILLS WITH REGARD TO THOSE OVER
THE YEARS. AND OFTEN THOSE ARE
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
OF THOSE WATER SYSTEMS OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOSE SYSTEMS.
MEMBERS CONSISTENTLY FAIL TO
PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING WATER TO
THEIR CONTINUED USE. AND THESE
WATER SYSTEMS SERVE AN ESTIMATED
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA'S SHOULD HAVE A
MILLION PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT ARE NOT BEING TAKEN CARE OF
AT ANY GIVEN TIME. RECOGNIZING
THE EXTENT OF THIS ISSUE. AND
THE SMALL SYSTEMS LACK OF THE
TECHNICAL MANAGERIAL AND
FINANCIAL CAPACITY TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE. OPERATIONS
AT THE AS I SUGGESTED WHAT WE
DID IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IS
WE GRANTED TOGETHER WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE THE STATE
WATER CONTROL BOARD THE BILL TO
APPOINT. THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATORS TO ASSIST. IN
THOSE FAILING SYSTEMS. BUT THE
REALITY IS I SUGGESTED IS THE
TOOL HAS NOT BEEN WORKING AS
WELL AS IT SHOULD HAVE OF THE
THIRTEEN WATER SYSTEMS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE.
ADMINISTRATORS ONLY ONE. ONE HAS
APPOINTED. A ONE TO DATE. S.
ARE. SO BASED WHAT'S HAPPENING
IS THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE SEEING
WILLING AND PROMISING CANDIDATES
CITE A LACK OF CLARITY AROUND
THE STATUTORY LIABILITY. AS A
KEY REASON FOR THEIR RELUCTANCE
TO ACCEPT. ADMINISTRATORS
RESPONSES MINISTRY
RESPONSIBILITY. THIS IS HAD AS I
SAID A CHILLING EFFECT ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE WATER BOARD
ADMINISTRATOR PROGRAM. SO WHAT
WE'VE DONE TODAY IS TO SET UP A
FRAMEWORK TO PROVIDE A BY BILL
PROTECTION TO ADMINISTRATORS
WERE WORKING GOOD FAITH WITH
WITH REASONABLE EFFORTS. SO WE
CAN START REFORMING OUR FIELD
WHAT SYSTEMS. IN ADDITION THIS
MEASURE ALSO EXPANDS THE
APPOINTMENT AUTHORITY OF
ADMINISTRATORS TO DEAL WITH AT
RISK SYSTEMS WE DON'T WANT JUST
SYSTEMS FAILED. IF SOMETHING'S
AT RISK WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO BE
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT IT AND GET
AHEAD OF THE PROBLEM. SO YOU
KNOW IS A SUGGESTED ADDITIONAL
SIX HUNDRED WATER SYSTEMS ARE
CURRENTLY AT RISK FOR FAILING
SIX HUNDRED AND APPROX ME FORTY
SEVEN NEW WATER SYSTEMS ADDED TO
THE FAILING WATER SYSTEMS.
ANNUALLY SO WE KNOW THESE WATER
SYSTEMS OF OUR PROBLEM ONCE AND
THIS EXPANSION OF THE STORY
TOGETHER WITH PROTECTION ONE
SURE THAT WE CAN PROACTIVELY GET
AHEAD OF THE PROBLEM. WHICH IN
MY JUDGMENT IS GOVERNMENT AT ITS
BEST. LEARN LISTEN GROW IMPROVE
AND GET AHEAD OF THE PROBLEM. IN
SHOW OF MY OFFICE AND THE
SPONSORS ARE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A
POSITION LETTER FROM. THE LAWYER
TRIAL OR IS DEALING WITH THIS
LIMITED LIABILITY BUT I WHEN I
READ IT IS I'VE- VOTED MANY OF
THESE OVER THE YEARS. IT DIDN'T
SEEM LIKE IT WAS A SIGNIFICANT
OPPOSITION. SOME WE CAN WORK OUT
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM TO
RESPOND TO THEIR TO THEIR- AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT-
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO. DO
BETTER THE PUSH OF OUR OUR JOBS
LEGISLATORS YEAH- DERREN PULL
MISTER WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD THIS YEAR'S A WITNESS IF
ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS. THAT. COURSE RESPECTFULLY. GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH HER LOOKS WAS
GOING TO ON THE- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE HERTZBERG
OF FINAL STOP FEATHER RISING THE
- APPROACH WE WANT TO TAKE A
THIS WAS MY- BORN SOME AGO TO.
BELIEVE THIRD PARTIES CAN.
REALLY SMALL STRUCK WATERS. THAT
ARE UNABLE TO CHIU THEIR WATER.
BECAUSE OF THE AND LEAST HELP
YOU GET THE- A WEEK HAVE THE
FOR. THROUGH THE BUT- OF THE S.
TWO HUNDRED SUPPORT WATER ACT UP
ON THE- AND- SERVICES. THAT WE
JUST HAD- INTO TO PAY FOR. THE
NEEDS PRESENT- CLAY. ASTOR WELL
THE IS. DIRECTLY THOSE THAT WANT
TO TAKE ON THIS GREAT CHALLENGE
AND WORK WITH THESE COMMUNITIES
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN GET
SIX CULTURE WATER. DISTRICT TO
PROVIDE CAREER THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL. BRING IN THEIR CAR WHICH
INCLUDE COUNTY. CITIES NOT.
OTHERS THAT WILL US TO US- ONE
SYSTEMS BACK ON FEET AND- BACK
THE COMMUNITY. ARE DIRECTLY SO.
THE BALLOT AT THE TECHNICAL AND
THINK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AND I SEE DANIEL HERE. JEFF COOK
THE VOICE SUPPORT THIS YEAR WHAT
IF I JUST AS VENTURE BECAUSE
YEAH YOU KNOW OFTEN P. SERVE AND
WE- FORGET THEIR THAT THEY
HELPED IMPORTANCE THEY HAD WITH
SB TWO ON. WAS MAKING. EFFORT BY
MY YEAH JORDAN. THAT'S RIGHT
WHAT'S THE DEATH AND HERE HAS
THE MY OF IT TO BE ABLE TO HELP
PH<c.cyan>ND- I NEVER WANT TO. CENTER</c>
MUNNINGS UP TO HE WERE SO HARD
AND- THING IN THE WRONG. OKAY
YESTERDAY ALSO WAS THE DANIELS
HERE WITH THE- THE MINNESOTA
UTILITY SUFFICIENT WITH A WAY OF
LIFE THE TITLE IS SENIOR AGAIN
AND JUST I WANT TO SAY ONE QUICK
THING WEALSO TRIED TO GET THIS
ACCOMPLISHED- CENTER TO COVER
YOUR OWN OUR CONSOLIDATION BILL.
HUGE ISSUE WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE
AND SO WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU THANKS ANYA. OKAY ARE YOU ON
THE PHONE LINES ONE OF OUR
SUPPORT FOR S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. I'M SORRY TWELVE FIFTY.
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR I'M SO SORRY.
TWELVE FIFTY TWELVE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONE MOMENT HER
FIRST LINE. AND WE HAVE LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SURE NUMBERS THERE
TURNER WORKING ON TOP OF THIS IS
ON BEHALF OF EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND THAT. WE HAVE LINE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MANY STUDENTS BELIEVE THAT WITH
ME WATER CENTER CALLING- INTO
PORT OF SB TWELVE FIFTY FOUR
BISON HERDS FOR GOING TO PUT A
CONCEPT AND- REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT CENTRES EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER MODERN. WE HAVE
ONE MORE ONE MOMENT I'LL GET
THEIR LINE NUMBER. LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. KEVIN
MEMBERS DR MILAN HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU JASON OKAY. ARE IS
ANYONE HERE WANT TO VOICE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OR RAISE
CONCERNS HERE IN THE BUILDING
OKAY HOW ABOUT ON THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR ANYONE WITH A
VOICE OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS.
AND ANYONE WITH OPPOSITION ARE
CONCERNED ON. A. B. CROFTY FOR.
ACCIDENTAL ROSA SB I'M SORRY SB
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. AND I HAVE KNOWN QUEUING
UP THIS TIME THANK YOU AND YOU
MENTIONED IN YOUR IN YOUR
PRESENTATION SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS- I KNOW YOU.
MENTIONED YOU CAN BE WORKING
WITH THEM SO I'M CERTAINLY. AND
IF THIS IS A THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND I
WANNA ALSO ECHOED SECOND YEAR.
PRAISE FOR- FOR OUR OUR GREAT
COLLEAGUE BILL MINING IN. SENECA
WE ARE TO USE WORK ON THIS AND I
CERTAINLY MISS FOR THE BILL. OUR
THOUGHTS COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS. YEAH MOVE THE BILL
MOTION FROM CINEMA CASKEY- YOU
MAY CLOSE CENTER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COMMITTEE APPRECIATED
THAT'S RIGHT. THIRTY OF HIS
COLOR. I ITEM NUMBER TEN SB
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG MOTION IS DUE FACT DO
PASSPORT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY ALAN
HI ALAN I BATES. BATES AYE DALY
GONZALEZ HI AND SALAS I SKINNER
. SKINNER AYE STERN AYE CASKEY
AYE AYE CASSIE AYE OKAY BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR FOLKS TO ADD
ON THAT WAS FIVE VOTES THANK YOU
CENTER THEY DON'T AND I SEE
SENATE PORTANTINO'S HERE HE'S
HERE TO PRESENT. SB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE. THE DISHWASHER BILL. YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
CENTER PORTANTINO ITEM ELEVEN
YOUR PACKETS MEMBERS IS SB
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS EXCITING FOR ME
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WE ALL COME UP
HERE WITH GREAT AGENDAS AND
IDEAS BUT WE CAN'T HAVE EVERY
GOOD IDEA AND THIS WAS BROUGHT
TO ME BY. FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT
ON A PHONE CALL TALKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN BE A GREENER
CALIFORNIA SO I'M VERY EXCITED
THAT THE GLENDALE ENVIRONMENTAL
COALITION SUGGESTED THIS. THE
IDEA BEHIND THIS BILL AND HAPPY
TO BE PRESENTING IT TODAY- THIS
WOULD ESTABLISH A DISH WASHER
GRANT PROGRAMS FOR WASTE
REDUCTION IN K. TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CURRENTLY
THERE IS NO PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA DEDICATED TO TACKLING
THE SINGLE USE. WASTE STREAM
COMING FROM K. TWELVE SCHOOL
CAFETERIAS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CENTER HERTZBERG LEFT
BUT HE AND I ARE OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER WHEN WE ACTUALLY HAD
PLATES KNIVES AND FORKS IN OUR
CAMPUSES AND- ACTUALLY EIGHTY
ONE ON FLATWARE AND DIDN'T THROW
IT AWAY- INDUSTRIAL DISHWASHING
MACHINES PRESENTED UPSTREAM
WASTE PREVENTION MEASURE BY
AVOIDING SINGLE USE ITEMS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. THEY RESULT IN LESS
WASTE AND ALLEVIATE THE COST OF
HAULING IN LITTER CLEANUP FOR
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES THEY ALSO
NORMALIZE THE RE USE OF DAILY
ITEMS TEACHING STUDENTS THE
VALUE OF IBM ARE VERY
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP IS
VERY IMPORTANT SO COVER CURRENT
COMMERCIAL DISHWASHING MACHINES
USE VERY LITTLE WATER. DRY
QUICKLY ARE FAST AND ENERGY
EFFICIENT THEY CAN COMPLETE A
CYCLE AND ONLY A FEW MINUTES
LOWERING THE AMOUNT OF DISHES
THAT ARE NEEDED A WELL CARED FOR
MACHINE CAN LAST FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS OVER TIME AND OFFSETTING
WASTE MANAGEMENT COSTS THAT ARE
EXPECTED TO RISE IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. HOWEVER MOST DISHWASHERS
BELIEVE OR NOT REMOVED FROM
SCHOOLS IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. RECENT STUDIES
ESTIMATE THAT ONLY ABOUT 7% OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL CAFETERIAS USE
DISHWASHERS. COMPARED 27290% IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
AGAIN CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
LEADING AND HERE WERE NOT. SB
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE WOULD PROVIDE
GRANTS UP TO FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER SCHOOL DISTRICT
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WINSTAR COMMERCIAL
DISHWASHER. THIS WILL ALLOW THE
TRANSITION TO SAFER USABLE FOOD
WHERE DESIGNED FOR REPEATED USE
AND SANITIZING INSTEAD OF
CONTRIBUTING TO THE WASTE
CRISIS. CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN ELIMINATE
THE USE OF SINGLE USE FOOD WHERE
AND HELP REDUCE WASTE WHILE
INSTILLING THESE VALUES. IN
STUDENTS- WHICH IS ALSO EXCITING
IS THAT IN THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
BY THE FROM THE GOVERNOR. IS
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO
RETROFITTING- OUR SCHOOL.
CAFETERIAS ALREADY IN SO THERE'S
MONEY IN THE BUDGET WE BELIEVE
TO COVER THIS. AND OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING TO THE
BUDGET FOLKS ABOUT THAT. AND
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE MONICA
COMPAGNIA FROM THE GLENDALE
ENVIRONMENTAL COALITION AND
ALLEYS. ALEXANDRINA CHAVEZ A
POLICY ASSOCIATED CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH SOONER ALL RIGHT LET'S
START WITH MONICA ON THE PHONE
LINE. THANK YOU CHAIR ALLEN AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE MY NAME IS
MONICA COMPANION AND MIND YOUR
NUMBER WITH RANDOM RANDOM NEW
COALITION. AND I CAN CAMPUS AT
FRANKLIN ELEMENTARY IN THE
GLENDALE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHERE I WAS PREVIOUSLY A PARENT
VOLUNTEER WITH THE PTA GREEN
LUNCHROOM COMMITTEE. WITH THE
DONATION OF THE DISH MACHINE
THREE YEARS AGO BY THE
MANUFACTURER. OUR SCHOOL WAS
ABLE TO MOVE FROM DISPOSABLES TO
USABLE FOR THE CAFETERIA. THE
DONATION REMOVED THE HIGH UP
FRONT COSTS FOR THE DISTRICT
WHICH WHAT'S THE MAIN BARRIER TO
ENTRY AND THE PROBLEM. SB TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE WILL FALL. UST
STARTED BY FINDING THE SPOT WITH
THE OLD DISHWASHER USED TO LIVE.
AT OUR DISTRICTS LIKE MOST IN
CALIFORNIA REMOVED THE MALL IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES. THEY
DON'T MAKE THE INVESTMENTS
NEEDED FOR UPGRADES KITCHEN
RECONFIGURATION SURPRISED HE
LASTED A FULL YEAR COST ANALYSIS
WITH THIS PILOT PROGRAM AND
SHOWED A FOUR YEAR PAY BACK.
AFTER WHICH THEY SAVE ABOUT
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
MOSTLY FROM NOT HAVING TO
PURCHASE THE DISPOSABLES WITH
FUNDING FROM SB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE THAT'S EVEN. COM
IMMEDIATELY AND SCHOOLS WON'T
NEED TO DECIDE BETWEEN REPLACING
A FAILING REFRIGERATOR. TACKLING
SINGLE USE WASTE. YOUR
THANKSGIVING DISHWASHER SALT OR
AVOID IT FOR US IN ADDITION TO
THE HUGE VOLUME OF WASTE WHEN NO
LONGER GENERATING FOR THIS
CAFETERIA THE DISTRICT DOESN'T
HAVE TO DEAL WITH STOCK
SHORTAGES AND RISING COSTS OF
SINGLE USE ITEMS. WHICH THEY ARE
DEALING WITH AND OTHER
LOCATIONS. INSTEAD OF CHECKING
OUT EIGHT TRASH CANS MULTIPLE
TIMES A DAY IN OUR LUNCH ROOM
ARTISTS AUDIENCE PEOPLE TO FOCUS
ON A NEW ORGANIC FORTY AREA WITH
ONE LANDFILL TRASH BINS ONLY. WE
NO LONGER THROW AWAY A THOUSAND
COMPOSTABLE TRAYS PER WEEK WHICH
REQUIRED MANY BAG CHANGES AND
QUICKLY FILLED OUR GREEN
DUMPSTER. DISTRICTS MONEY WITH
ONLY A SINGLE WEEKLY ORGANICALLY
KICK UP THAT SERVICE IS REQUIRED
NOT ALL SCHOOLS WITH THE PASSAGE
OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE AND
IT'S EXPENSIVE. SELECTICA. NEED
MORE SAVINGS WHEN NO LONGER
SENDING HIGH AND TEN THOUSAND
SPARKED THE LAND IN. I KNOW HOW
TO NO LONGER HAVE TO PICK UP
ANALYST AMOUNTS OF CELLOPHANE
SPORT THAT RAP THAT OFF THE
CABLE FOR. THE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY ALONG TEACHING THE
KIDS FROM TO SEE GRADE. PLAY IN
THE NOW. OKAY NORMAL TO USE FOR.
MINUTES AND THEN TALK TO THE
NEXT. TO BE TAKEN AWAY INTO THE
NOTHER WORLD. THAT THE KIDS WITH
REAL SILVERWARE CARPARK
COMPARTMENTALIZED VISIBLE TRADE.
AND WE DO THINK THAT OUR PARENTS
DID WE WASH THE DISHES. BEGAN
OUR DISHWASHER IS STATE OF THE
ART IF HE'S TO VERY HIGH
TEMPERATURES IS SPENT LESS AND
IT RUNS CYCLE IN MINUTES. A LACK
OF DISHWASHING EQUIPMENT IS THE
SINGLE BIGGEST BARRIER TO MAKING
THE SWITCH TO REUSABLE. AND MOST
SCHOOLS SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE
BUDGET TO MAKE THE HIGH UPFRONT
INVESTMENT. SB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
WITH OPENER FASTLY FOR SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES ACROSS
OUR STATE. CAPITOL WASTE
REDUCTION IN A MEANINGFUL WAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION IT'S IMPORTANT
BILL THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH HI MISS COMPANY
LISTED ALEXANDRIA CHÁVEZ FROM-
CALIFORNIANS WASTE. JEREMY OF
MANY ALEX AND TOM BECAUSE- FACE
. ARE HAS A SINGLE. USE ISSUE
AND- SCHOOLS ARE ASPECT OF THAT
NEED THAT NEED TO BE A- CAL
RECYCLE REPORTS THAT SCHOOLS AND
UNIVERSITIES GENERATE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO THOUSAND TONS
OF WASTE ANNUALLY- AND MEANWHILE
THE STATE'S RECYCLING AND WASTE
DIVERSION RATES ARE FEELING IN
PART DUE TO THE INCREASED USE OF
SINGLE USE PRODUCTS. A SINGLE
USE PLASTIC FOOD WHERE- IS MADE
OF LOW QUALITY PLASTIC OR
POLYSTYRENE THAT CANNOT BE
RECYCLED AND HAS TO BE DISPOSED
OF AS WASTE AND TO REFERENCE
HELD SCHOOLS CONTRIBUTE TO THIS
THE GLENDALE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT REPORTED THAT THEY USE.
AROUND. SIX THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED PLASTIC- UTENSIL PACKETS
DALY SAYS I'M ASK YOU WRAP IT UP
BECAUSE MISS COMPANION USE UP SO
MUCH TIME SO BUT WE HAVE HERE IS
A WIN IS FOR TESTIMONY BUT BUT
YOU LIKE TO. SORRY WE'RE WE'RE
JUST VERY CURRENT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU- OKAY
LET'S AND THAT'S GONNA GO TO
FUNDING WAS OF US VOICE SUPPORT
FOR SB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE- BUT
GIVEN THE PUBLIC. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. TWO I'M AT THE SPORT.
YOU MUST PRESS ONE ZERO SIX WILL
GO FIRST TO LINE NUMBER. NINETY
THREE IS GOING TO. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS- GENEVIEVE AVEDON
ON BEHALF OF THE CLEAN THESE
LOBBYING COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SELF. NEXT THE
LINE NUMBER OF NINETY GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MORNING THE CENTER OF
THIS IS JOCELYN ON BEHALF OF
HEAL THE BAY THE ENVIRONMENTAL-
OCEAN ADVOCACY GROUP DOWN IN
SANTA MONICA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANKS LINE
THIRTEENTH IS GOING. ONE THIRTY
ONE OKAY GO AHEAD PLEASE. THE
ONLINE NUMBER FORTY SEVEN FORTY
SEVEN ALONG A LITTLE. HI THERE
MY NAME IS REBECCA AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SELF THANK
YOU. LITERATURE WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC INPUT IN
COUPON THANK YOU SO MUCH ON PAGE
NINE AS AN EXTENSIVE LIST OF
SUPPORTERS- IF YOU'RE NOW SAYS
BUT I'VE HE DUG SAYS YES OF
OTHER FOLKS HERE IN PERSON TO
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- TO COLD CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS WERE SHIPPED COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. PERSECUTORS
ON BEHALF OF STOP WASTING
SUPPORT THANK YOU PERCENT THANK
YOU OKAY- I DO I KNOW THAT
THERE'S NO RETROCESSION I DON'T
SEE ANYONE HERE WANTS TO VOICE
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS ANYONE
THE PHONE LINES MODERATE WHO
WANTS TO VOICE CONCERNS
OPPOSITION. SB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
PROPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO WE DO
HAVE ONE CUED UP ALREADY. THIS
IS ONE OF THE LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY
SIX WITH THEMSELVES YOU THE
MASSIVE BOX WITH A PLATE FOR
SUPPORT. NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT
EDUCATION. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU.
WITH RESPECT TO THE
COMMUNICATIONS COMMENTS-
SENATORS OFFICE. JUST WHEN I SAY
THIS IS A GREAT BILL SENATOR I
WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR I THINK THE ONLY- JUST
AS- I GUESS SUGGESTION FROM THE
COMMITTEE WAS WHETHER TO
ADMINISTER THIS THROUGH THE CDC
VERSUS POWER CYCLE WHICH I'M
SURE YOU'LL- YOU'LL WORK OUT
BUT- THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD INTO YOUR SUPPORTERS AS
WELL. AND WE PLAN ON ALIGNING IT
WITH THE BUDGET LANGUAGE SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE MAKING THAT
CHANGE. OKAY I TEND TO MOVE US.
ALL THIRTY MICHAELIS SO I SAY
THANK YOU TO THE G. C. FOR BRING
THIS TO MY ATTENTION AND EFFORTS
BERKELEY S. RIVAL. THANK YOU
SECRETARY ME PLEASE HELLO. I AM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE BY SENATOR PORTANTINO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION. ALAN HI ALAN I'D
BATES. EIGHT FIVE DALLY. AND
SALAS GONZALEZ I SKINNER. STERN
BURKE OWSKI HI MY COUNTY I'D-
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER WILL
EITHER OPEN FOR FOLKS TO ADD ON
THAT THE BILL DOES A FOUR OF US
THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT ALL
RIGHT LET'S INVITE- ARE. HIS
FRIENDS AND ATTENTIVE TO THE- TO
THE DÍAS ITEM NUMBER TWELVE S.
B. TWELVE NINETY SEVEN THAT'S
ITEM TWELVE YOUR PACKETS MEMBERS
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY. THE
JUDGE ENTERED A- FAVOR CAN YOU
OFFER DISCO KEEP ROLLIN. THAT
WAS A GOOD BILL OKAY GREAT LET'S
GO TO. THE NECROTIZING. I THINK
YOU A MISTER TERRENCE SANDERS
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT SB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA TAKES A LEADERSHIP
ROLE. IN ADVANCING CLIMB
RESTORATION. TAKEN STEPS TO
MINIMIZE EMBODIED CARBON AND-
MAXIMIZE CARBON SEQUESTRATION IN
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT. THE CO
TWO CAN BE STORED OUR BUILT
ENVIRONMENTS INCLUDING ROADS AND
BUILDINGS THESE STRATEGIES
PROVIDE VALUABLE OPPORTUNITIES
TO STORE CARBON AND ENORMOUS
POTENTIAL SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
AMBITIOUS. CLIMATE PRIORITIES SB
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN WILL REQUIRE
THE STATE TO DEVELOP A PLAN AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO MINIMIZE
EMBODIED CARBON IN MAXIMIZE
CARBON SEQUESTRATION. IN
BUILDING MATERIALS NOTABLY THIS
WOULD GREATLY EXPAND THE REACH
FOR STATES CURRENT EMBODIED
CARBON REDUCTION GOALS. INCLUDE
MATERIALS SUCH AS CEMENT
CONCRETE AGGREGATES. LUMBER
CROSS LAMINATED TIMBER STEEL AND
MORE. OUR BUILT ENVIRONMENT. OF
COURSE IS A LARGE GHG EMITTER.
IN BODY CARBON OR GHG EMISSIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH PRODUCING USING
BUILDING MATERIALS ACCOUNTS FOR
AT LEAST ELEVEN PERCENT. OF
GLOBAL CARBON EMISSIONS. DESPITE
HIGH GHG IMPACTS FROM BUILDING
MATERIALS IN THE SIGNIFICANT
POTENTIAL THE OPPORTUNITY AS
CALIFORNIA'S GHG GOALS AND
CLIMATE RESTORATION. LITTLE HAS
BEEN DONE TO ADDRESS THESE TALKS
IN CALIFORNIA. SB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE STAKEHOLDER
INPUT IN FOR STATE AGENCIES TO
DEVELOP PLANS COUNTY FRAMEWORKS
AND OTHERWISE ENCOURAGE USE OF
BUILDING MATERIALS WERE FEASIBLE
WITH LOWER NEGATIVE EMPLOYEE
CARBON EMISSIONS TO HELP. BEGIN
MAXIMIZE LEVEL OF CARBON
SEQUENCE SEQUESTRATION IN THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT. SB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN FALLS IN
ANNOUNCEMENTS AT THE RECENT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE UNITED NATIONS
CLIMATE CHANGE CONFERENCE IN
GLASGOW SCOTLAND FROM THE
PACIFIC COAST COLLABORATIVE THAT
PARTNERING JURISDICTIONS
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA WILL WILL
WORK TO ACCELERATE INNOVATION
INVESTMENT AND MARKET
DEVELOPMENT FOR LOW CARBON
MATERIALS. IT ALSO COMES ON THE
HEELS OF THE RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT
BY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
REGARDING NEW ACTIONS TO ADVANCE
A PRODUCTION AND USE OF LOW
CARBON BUILDING MATERIALS MADE
IN AMERICA. AND GUIDANCE ON
RESPONSIBLE DEPLOYMENT OF CARBON
CAPTURE UTILIZATION AND
SEQUESTRATION TO HELP ACHIEVE A
CARBON NEUTRAL CON. I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT SB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN. A VITAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHARTER GLOBAL PATH
FORWARD IN CLIMB RESTORATION.
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT FOR THIS
COMMITTEE THAT WE HAVE ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENT. BUT NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS TO CLARIFY.
THAT THIS BILL S. O. PR TO
EVALUATE THE CIRCUMSTANCES. IN
WHICH USE OF LOW EMBODIED CARBON
BUILDING MATERIALS OR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION BUILDING MATERIALS
QUALIFIES. AS AN ACCEPTABLE GHG
MITIGATION MEASURE PURSUANT TO
SEE WHAT. THE CURRENT BILL
LANGUAGE INCLUDE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT FROM LABOR. INSURERS
THROUGH THIS BILL WE ARE
ADVANCING METHODS IN BUILDINGS
AND CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS THAT
CAN. AND WILL CREATE AND
MAINTAIN JOBS FOR CALIFORNIA
WORKERS THAT WILL PROVIDE MIDDLE
CLASS WAGES AND BENEFITS IN
UNION REPRESENTATION ULTIMATELY
. REGARDING REQUESTED AMENDMENTS
FROM INDUSTRY I WANT TO JUST
TOUCH UPON THOSE REAL QUICK- IT
CBI IN SOME OTHER INDUSTRY
GROUPS WERE CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM. WORKING
ON AMENDMENTS TO HOPEFULLY FULLY
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AND TO FIND
FEASIBLE WHICH I THINK IS REALLY
OF THE CONCERN THERE THE WORD
FEASIBLE- IS IN THE BILL- BUT
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN AND I THINK
IT'S- IT'S PROBABLY ACCURATE TO
SAY WHAT WE WANT TO DO IN TERMS
OF REMEMBRANCES. A TO DEFINE
FEASIBLE AS MATERIAL- CAPABLE
BEING INSTALLED A SUCCESSFUL
MANNER WITHIN A REASONABLE
PERIOD OF TIME TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENTAL
LEGAL SOCIAL AND TECHNOLOGICAL
FACTORS ALSO MATERIAL THAT DOES
NOT HARM THE HEALTH OR SAFETY OF
THOSE WHO INSTALL MATERIALS WERE
OCCUPIED THE BUILDING THAT
SEEMS. TO BE GOOD COMMONSENSE
THE MATERIAL THAT PROVIDES THE
SAME FUNCTION AT LEAST SAME
DURABILITY USEFUL LIFE AND
PERFORMANCE AS BASELINE
MATERIALS- THAT'S UNDER
CONSIDERATION THE MATERIAL THAT
DOES NOT POSE. AN INCREASED RISK
OF A CONSTRUCTION OR DESIGN
DEFECT OR CONSPIRE CONSTITUTE A
THREAT TO THE INTEGRITY OF THE
BUILDING MATERIAL THAT IS
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE IN THE
REGION OF THE PROJECT WHICH OF
COURSE WOULD BE CALIFORNIA AND
THE SUBREGIONS. OF THOSE ARE
ALL- OF THE ITEMS THAT I THINK
JUST HAVE TO BE LOOKED AT IN
TERMS OF THE DEFINITION IN THE
BILL OF THE WORD FEASIBILITY PUT
THIS FEASIBILITY ME- THOSE ARE
NOT ON THE TABLE TODAY BECAUSE
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH. OF LANGUAGE- WITH
INDUSTRY. ASSOCIATION THAT HAVE
THAT BROUGHT THAT UP- WITH ME
TODAY IS- TERRY YOU REPRESENTING
THE FOUNDATION FOR CLIMATE
RESTORATION TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AS WELL AS LAURA BERLIN SHEEN
REPRESENTING BLUE PLANET. THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TO THAT I KNOW
LONG PRESENTATION- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU SIR LET'S START WITH
TERRY. HELLO I APPRECIATE BEING
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TO THE CHAIR AND THE HONORABLE
SENATORS REGARDING THE BILL.
OKAY THE INTRODUCED LAST MONTH
SB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN. MY NAME
IS TERRY AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT FOR THE
FOUNDATION FOR TO RESTORATION.
OUR ORGANIZATION IS FOCUSED ON
REACHING THREE HUNDRED PARTS PER
MILLION OF CO TWO BY TWENTY
FIFTY WHICH IS MUCH LOWER THAN
THE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE OUR
FIRST YEAR HOPPERS THAT DAY.
WHICH OF COURSE IS STILL BECAUSE
WE SEE THIS AS A SOLUTION THAT
CAN HELP RESTORE THE ATMOSPHERE
AND REACH OUR GOAL FOR MOVING
THAT LEGACY CARBON BUT IT'S
SIMPLE TO GET EACH INDUSTRIAL
REVOLUTION BEGAN OVER TWO
HUNDRED YEARS AGO. CALIFORNIA SB
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN HAS A FOCUS
ON MINIMIZING EMBODIED CARBON
AND MAXIMIZING REQUESTED CARBON
IN THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT AND
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA ONCE
AGAIN TAKES A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
ADVANCING CLIMATE RESTORATION.
EMBODIED CARBON FROM THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT ACCOUNT FOR AT LEAST
11% GLOBAL CARBON EMISSIONS. WE
AT THE FOUNDATION FOR QUITE
RESTORATION SB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN CORPORATE CLIMATE
RESTORATION SOLUTION. BECAUSE IT
STARTS CARBON IN THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT AND WILL ENABLE NET
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS HEALTH
BROUGHT DOWN WITH A CARBON
DIOXIDE LEVELS. WHICH CAN BE
DONE SAFELY FOR THE ARMENIAN
ECONOMICALLY WE SEE THIS IS A
CRITICAL FIRST STEP IN GETTING
CLOSER TOWARD RESTORING THE
CLIMATE AND BEAUTY STANDARDS FOR
THE INDUSTRY. THIRTY TO SUPPORT
PASSAGE OF SB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK. YOU THE
SIX GOING TO MISTER BRUNCHING.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN. MEETING ON
THE- LAURA. WITH THE PLANET THAT
. AN INCREASE TO VOICE MY STRONG
SUPPORT AS TEN. MCKENZIE S. B.
NINE SEVEN. THE PLANET THE LOS
GATOS. BASED ON. DEVELOPING
TECHNOLOGY AND PRODUCT RELATED
TO CARBON CAPTURE UTILIZATION.
OUR PILOT PLANT IS CURRENTLY
UNDER CONSTRUCTION IN THE BAY
AREA. SPECIFICALLY PITTSBURG
CALIFORNIA. OUR GOAL IS TO HELP
MITIGATE CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ADVANCE CLIMATE RESTORATION. BY
CONVERTING CAPTURED CO TWO INTO
HIGH VALUE BUILDING MATERIALS.
AT LEAST FINANCED WE CAPTURE IN
MINERALIZED. TWO TO SAFELY AND
PERMANENTLY SEQUESTER IT INTO
ROCK. THE ROCK WE PRODUCE. IS
THEN USED AS A RAW MATERIAL
INPUT. IN THE CONCRETE
PRODUCTION PROCESS. THROUGH THIS
PROCESS. WE CAN START BASS
QUANTITIES OF CO TWO IN THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT. PARTICULARLY
WITH CONCRETE. IS THE MOST
WIDELY. USED BUILDING MATERIALS
HONOR. MARTIN ST UNDER YOU
STRATEGY FOR THE CARBON. IS TO
REDUCE BY. WITHIN BILL MATERIAL
AT THE FRONT SEVEN PROVIDE
VALUABLE STRATEGY IN A SEPARATE
. IT IS TREMENDOUSLY PROMISING
CLIMATE SOLUTION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THE MEASURE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES I DON'T SEE ONE LINE
OF HIS VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL ON THE FRONT LINES ANYONE
ONCE VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
ON THE FRONT LINES MODERATOR. TO
VOICE SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE ARE GOING
TO LINE NUMBER ONE OLD. ONE NEW
ONES OKAY GO AHEAD. THIS IS JOHN
HANCOCK OKAY COULD BE SO
COMPELLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
KATIE. THANKS WE'VE LINE TWENTY
TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI THIS IS
A WILL BRING HER FROM THREE
FIFTY SACRAMENTO ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT ONE OF LINE
NUMBER NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IT WAS JUST SOMEONE HERE GAINED
ON BEHALF OF THE U. S. GREEN
BUILDING COUNCIL IN LOS ANGELES
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF MUCH NEEDED
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANKS TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED GO AHEAD PLEASE. FIND ONE UNDER YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M ONE OF YOU MIGHT BE
NEEDED ON YOUR AND CHECKING
REPUBLICANS. HELLO WE CAN GO
AHEAD. WELCOME SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT
IN COURT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE NEXUS LINE NUMBER NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINES OF. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE OKAY WHO IS
REPRESENTING THE CALPINE
CORPORATION BUT THE OWNERS AND
OPERATORS OF THE EIGHTH FOR
MENTION POWER PLANT. IN THE BAY
AREA SPECIFICALLY PITTSBURG
WE'RE VERY BULLISH ON THIS
TECHNOLOGY WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS AN APPROPRIATE USE OF-
CAPTURED CARBONIA ELEVEN MEMBER
YOU KNOW THIS IS A ME TOO TIME.
WE'RE JUST WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
JUST WE'RE TRY WE HAVEN'T WE
REALLY DO GIVEN THE CLOCK
MEASURE NOW SO IF THIS MATTER
PLEASE SAID. AND ARE WE AT WE
NEED MORE FOLKS ONE OF OUR
SUPPORT. Q. SQUARE MR OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH LET'S GO TO- FOLKS
WANT TO VOICE OPPOSITION OR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL- ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR.
ROB SOLUTION BUT ONE ZERO THIS.
MISTER CALDERON COUPLE FUELING
UP WITH ME ONE MOMENT.
GOING ON THE LINE FOR ONE OH
THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO
JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE CONCERNS-
REGARDING OUR OUR POTENTIAL
LIABILITY FOR PEOPLE WHO MAY
DISAGREE WITH OUR
DETERMINATIONS. WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HOPE THAT WE
CAN RESOLVE THOSE CONCERNS AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION TO
THAT. THANK YOU THAT'S TRUE A
LOT NUMBER FOURTEEN GOING TO
STOP WORKING. HELLO THIS IS
CRYSTAL SHOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION-
WE ARE CURRENTLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED- CENTER CORTESE
HIGHLIGHTED SOME OF THOSE-
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
WORKING ON SO WE APPRECIATE. THE
SENATOR AND HIS STAFF WORKING
WITH US AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH HIM ON SB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU. MISTER
CHEROKEE WAS QUICK GREAT THANK
YOU OKAY LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS THOUGHTS
COMMENTS AND- CASKEY- SINCE THIS
BILL DOESN'T GO THE JUDICIARY
GOES TO NATURAL RESOURCES. THE
STAFF REPORT RAISES THE- DORMANT
COMMERCE CLAUSE ISSUE AS BY
ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA MADE.
PRODUCTS GET A PREFERENCE VERSES
WE JUST BUY THEM AND THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY THAT. YEAH I
THINK I THINK THAT WILL PROBABLY
HAVE TO BE ADMITTED TO- BY
AMERICAN AS OPPOSED TO BY
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW GIVEN THE-
IMPLICATIONS THE DORMANT
COMMERCE CLAUSE. REGARDING THAT
UP CENTER. OKAY THE QUESTION
SPOTS BUT HERE MOTIONS. THE BILL
MOVED BY CENTER STERN ASSEMBLY
WE CLOSE- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IDOL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU- SURGEONFISH KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN BY SENATOR CORTESE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER ALLEN AYE.
ALLEN AYE DATE. BATES NOTE
DALLY. GONZALEZ AND SALAS I
SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI AYE CASKEY
AYE. GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHER FOLKS THAT ON- THREE
SENATORS NOW HERE SO SHE'S GONNA
PRESENT ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AND
YOUR AGENDAS MEMBERS THAT'S SB
TWELVE. OH SIX. YOU'RE RIGHT IS
THE THING- SB NINE FIVE FIRST.
THE CCS OKAY SO START WITH SB
NINE OH FIVE THAT'S ITEM
FOURTEEN YOUR PACKETS. YOU MAY
PROCEED. RIGHT THAT HERE MEMBERS
- LARGEST CEMENT PRODUCING STATE
IN THE US AND I THINK ALL OF US
REALIZE THAT WE- THE MAN IS
ESSENTIAL TO. WE LOOK AT THE NEW
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING.
MUCH OF THAT INFRASTRUCTURE WORK
IS GONNA NEED CEMENT WE KNOW
THAT OUR HOUSING COMMITMENTS ARE
GOING TO NEED CEMENT AND WE FROM
MY POINT OF VIEW WE WANT TO KEEP
THE CEMENT INDUSTRY HERE AND THE
REASON WE WANT TO KEEP IT HERE
THE CEMENT PRODUCED ELSEWHERE.
IS SO MUCH HIGHER CARBON AND SO
MUCH MORE POLLUTING IN THOSE IN
THE LOCAL AREA FOR WHERE IT'S-
FIVE- PRODUCED THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PRODUCE THE
MATERIALS THAT WE NEED. A HAND
TO DO THOSE IN AS
ENVIRONMENTALLY SMART WAYS
POSSIBLE THE LAST YEAR SENATOR
BECKER CARRIED A BILL THAT WAS
SUCCESSFUL THAT WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW THE PUT NEW REQUIREMENTS ON
THE DECARBONISATION OF THIS
MINISTRY. AND CEMENT IS UNIQUE
PRODUCT BECAUSE NOT ONLY IS
THERE A LOT OF CARBON INVOLVED
IN THE HIGH IT'S A VERY ENERGY
INTENSIVE BUT THERE'S ALSO
CARBON IS A BY PRODUCT AS PART
OF ITS PROCESSING IT'S JUST THE
NATURE OF IT. AND SO IT'S
DIFFICULT TO DECARBONISE CEMENT
BUT IT'S ESSENTIAL. SO WHAT MY
BILL DOES IS IGNORE ALLEGE THAT
. IN A TERMS OF A WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND YET
WE'RE STILL NEED MATERIALS THAT
HAVE CARBON ASSOCIATED HOW DO WE
DO THAT AS SMART AS POSSIBLE
WELL IN THIS IN THIS CASE
CAPTURING THE CARBON. AND THEN
ALLOWING US TO STORAGE. IS ONE
WAY TO DECARBONISE CEMENT SO
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS CREATE A
PILOT PROJECT FOR. THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO TEST THE VIABILITY
OF UNDERGROUND STORAGE OF
CARPETING CARBON. AND BY
ALLOWING US TO CAPTURE CARBON
FROM INDUSTRIAL PROCESS. FIVE
THE I'VE BUT THE BILL WAS BUILT
IN VARIOUS PROTECTIONS TO HELP
ANY COMMUNITIES THAT MAY BE
DOWNWIND OF- THE CEMENT
PRODUCTION IT ALSO LIMITS THE
CARBON FROM FOSSIL FUEL
PRODUCTION. FIVE RELATED TO IT
AND VARIOUS OTHER THINGS BUT LET
ME TURN MY WITNESSES NOW I'VE
GOT DOCTOR REBEKAH DEL FROM
CLIMATE WORKS AND ELLIE CONE
FROM THE CLIMATE CENTER. GREAT
LET'S START WITH AMERICA. HELLO
UP I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE THEIR WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU TODAY TO TALK ABOUT SB NINE
ZERO FIVE- I LEAVE THE LARGEST
NONPROFIT PROGRAM TO ELIMINATE
GREENHOUSE GASES FROM THE
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR. IN THE WORLD
. AND I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA PASSED SB
FIVE NINETY SIX COMMITTING THE
STATE TO ZERO OUT ITS CEMENT
EMISSIONS BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
MINUTES THE LARGEST SOURCE OF
MANUFACTURING EMISSIONS IN THE
STATE WITH BETWEEN TWO AND 3% OF
TOTAL STATE EMISSIONS IT'S ALSO
7% OF GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. OF CALIFORNIA CAN
DEMONSTRATE THE TECHNICAL POLICY
AND BUSINESS FEASIBILITY OF GHG
FREE CEMENT THAT CAN HAVE A MUCH
GREATER IMPACT AROUND THE WORLD.
AND NO ONE HAS FIGURED THIS OUT
YET SO CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP
IS BADLY NEEDED. US CEMENT IS
THE SECTOR WITH THE CLEAREST
CASE FOR RELYING ON CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS SO IF WE WANT TO START
TO EXPLORE CCS AS A PATHWAY TO
CLIMATE ACTION. CEMENT IS THE
CORRECT NO REGRETS PLACE TO
START. THE MAN IS ALSO CRITICAL
BECAUSE AS SENATOR SKINNER SAID
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE CRISIS
ACROSS OUR ECONOMY WILL REQUIRE
THAT WE BUILD AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT. OF NEW TRANSPORTATION
AND ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE AND IF
WE CONTINUE TO USE CONVENTIONAL
CEMENT OUR EFFORTS TO REDUCE
CLIMATE DAMAGE COULD THEMSELVES
BECOME DRIVERS OF CLIMATE DAMAGE
. AND FINALLY ADDRESSING US
CLIMATE DAMAGE FROM CEMENT WILL
ALSO HELP US TO ADDRESS ITS
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS
CALIFORNIA'S CEMENT KILNS ARE
THE ONLY FACILITIES REMAINING IN
THE STATE THAT STILL RELY ON
DIRECT COAL BURNING. FOR THEIR
ENERGY. THEY HAVE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF SOX EMISSIONS A
CRITICAL LOCAL AIR POLLUTANT AND
THAT THE IMPACT OF THIS
POLLUTION FALLS
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. CAPTURING THE CARBON WILL
ALSO REQUIRE US TO ELIMINATE
THESE LOCAL AIR POLLUTANTS AND
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH. FOR ALL
OF THESE REASONS SB NINE OH FIVE
IS A TIMELY AND IMPORTANT BILL.
N. IN CONJUNCTION WITH OTHER
POLICIES IT WILL HELP TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUED CLIMATE
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS VENTURA MANCHA
ON THE HALF THE CLIMATE CENTER-
STANDING UP AT THE CLOSE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS MANAGER. AT THE
CLINTON CENTER IS A POLICY
NONPROFIT WORKING TO RAPIDLY
REDUCE CLIMATE POLLUTION AT
SCALE STARTING CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB NINE FIVE.
AS MILLS RECENTLY OUTLINED IN
THE I. P. C. SIX THE SEVEN
REPORT MEET ACTIONS MUST BE
TAKEN TO HEAD OFF THE WORST
OUTCOMES OF CLIMATE CRISIS.
INCLUDING CAREFUL CONSIDERATION
ALL TECHNOLOGIES. WITH CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE IN PROMISING
CLIMATE DISCUSSION WE'RE AT AN
INFLECTION POINT AS TO WHAT TO
DO WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY. FOR THE
CLIMATE CENTER THIS DISCUSSION
BEGINS WITH A VERY CLEAR
BOUNDARY CCS SHOULD NOT BE USED
FOR CARBON CAPTURE OF FOSSIL
FUEL EXTRACTION EMISSIONS OR FOR
ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES. THESE AND USES A
CCS LEVEL CONTINUED FOSSIL FUEL
EXTRACTION POLLUTION WHILE
CONTINUING TO UNJUSTLY VERDANT
THAT'S LIKE COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONALLY CCS DOES HAVE A
STRIKING TRACK RECORD WITH
RESPECT WITH ACCENT PORTABILITY
IN EXISTING POSSIBLE PROJECTS.
THAT SAID CCS MAY HAVE A
CRITICAL I'M SO SORRY MISTER
REMAIN WITH YOUR PREVIOUS
WINNERS TOOK UP MOST THE TIME TO
UNDERSTAND IF YOU COULD IF YOU
COULD GO. VISIT WITH US
ABSOLUTELY SO WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE ARE SAFEGUARDS.
INCLUDING CONTINUING TO KEEP THE. STORAGE AND TRANSPORTATION IS
HERE TO SAVE. THE BILL IS NEEDED
OUR PROCESSING. STILL IT IS TO
ALSO. CONTAINED THERE ARE NONE
CO TWO. AND MEANINGFUL. WITH THE
CAN. THAT IN THESE. PLANS BUT SB
NINE FIVE INCLUDES THE
SAFEGUARDS AND FOR THESE REASONS
WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OKAY I ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
HERE IN PERSON YOU HAVE TO COME
UP AND- STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. I'M RIGHT BOB STAY
WITH PROJECT TWENTY THIRTY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE MONICA
ON THE BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. OKAY
SERVE FOR FOLKS TO KNOW THAT
SOME. OKAY BUT THE PERPETRATORS
AND OPPOSITIONISTS THOUGH IS
THAT RIGHT. OKAY YES. AFTER GOOD
MORNING I'M TOM TEETH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CEMENT
ASSOCIATION AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE EMPHASIZE TO THIS
GROUP THAT THE CALIFORNIA CEMENT
PRODUCERS ARE COMMITTED TO
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE WE HAVE THAT GOAL IN
PLACE WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
ARE YOU RAISING CONCERNS WITH A
BILL YOUR YOUR ON A KNOCKED OUT
OF A POSITION YET BUT- FOLLOWING
SUPPORT OKAY WHY TO AT LEAST
MENTION WHERE WE STAND SIR IT
WILL ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY ARE NOT
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY SIX LAST
YEAR. WE FEEL AS A
GROUNDBREAKING A BILL TO HELP US
GET TO WHERE WE NEED TO BE
CARBON CAPTURE UTILIZATION OF
STORAGE ARE HE COMPORTED OF US
GETTING THAT WE CAN'T DO IT
WITHOUT IT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON SOME
OF THE DETAILS OF THIS BILL WE
STILL HAVE SOME QUESTIONS BUT- I
THINK THIS COULD BE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US THANK YOU
THAT INVOKES THE FIGHTING SIX
ONE SENATE BACKERS BONE CEMENT.
THE RIVER OKAY THANK YOU. I OKAY
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OPPOSITION OKAY SEE. VIRGIL HERE
COME ON UP AND DOWN. FIRE AWAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- I'LL CUT TO THE
CHASE AND- WE'VE GOT SOME CLOCK
MANAGEMENT ISSUES- AS WELL LET
ME BE CLEAR- THIS BILL IS TOO
CONSTRAINING- WE FULLY AGREE
WITH- CENTER SKINNER THAT CCS IS
A CRITICAL PART OF A
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS- THE
REALITY IS THAT WE WILL NOT
ACHIEVE OUR TARGETS IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT DEPLOYMENT OF
CCS TECHNOLOGIES ACROSS MULTIPLE
SECTORS AND SO CEMENT IS
CERTAINLY ONE OF THOSE SECTORS-
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT SECTOR.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT THERE IS
APPLICATIONS IN MULTIPLE SECTORS
AND AT MULTIPLE- FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW- THAT WILL
BENEFIT FROM CCS TECHNOLOGIES-
AT LEAST SEVENTY FIVE FACILITIES
IN CALIFORNIA- COULD BENEFIT
FROM THE DEPLOYMENT OF A WHOLE
RANGE OF C. C. U. S.
TECHNOLOGIES- THE CEMENT SECTOR-
COMPRISES EIGHT FACILITIES VERY
IMPORTANT SECTOR- BUT OUR
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL IS THAT
THE FOCUS ON CEMENT- COULD VERY
WELL HAVE THE IMPACT- IMPEDING-
OTHER CRITICAL- CCS DEPLOYMENT
IN AND OTHER SECTORS THE POWER
SECTOR THE OIL AND GAS SECTOR-
THE MATHIS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR IN
TERMS OF- WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO. IF WE'RE GOING TO
MEET OUR SCIENTIFICALLY DRIVEN
CLINICALS- SO FOR THAT REASON-
WE WOULD LIKE TO ACTUALLY SEE
THIS BILL- NOT NECESSARILY BE
PREFERENTIAL TO A CERTAIN SECTOR
BUT ACTUALLY WHAT WE NEED IN THE
STATE IS REALLY A COMPREHENSIVE
POLICY FRAMEWORK THAT LEVELS THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR ANY INDUSTRY
THAT WANTS TO INVEST IN CCS
TECHNOLOGY- SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO- SPEAK WITH YOU AND I WOULD
HOPE. TO WORK WITH YOU TOWARD
THAT IN GOING FORWARD. THE YOU
MISTER WELCH OKAY ARE ELSE WANTS
TO RAISE CONCERNS THE BILL.
SACKLER WITH THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AS PRODUCES US
THEY'VE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES YOU
WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS OR
OPPOSITION BILL. ONCE YOUR
PHONES PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE
SEND YOUR FIRST LINE OF A ONE
GOAL ONE ONE HALF. GALAKHOV FOR
THREE FIFTY DOLLARS VALLEY-
HAVE- SUPPORT IMPLEMENTED
POSITION WE WISH TO ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS-
THREE FIFTY HUMBOLDT. AND THANKS
VERY MUCH WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE OFFER ON THE
BILL. NEXT TO ONE NUMBER SEVENTY
NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AT SENATORS AND LOOK
AT FOR EXAMPLE AFTER NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATOR SKINNER'S ACTING ON A
FIVE. THANKS WILL ONE ONE OH
FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS ROB SPIEGEL
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION- ALSO
OPPOSE THANK YOU. I GREITENS ONE
TWENTY SEVEN UNITS ONE OF.
TWENTY SEVEN ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE. HELLO THIS IS ME YES
THIS YEAR I THINK FIVE DID NOT
KNOW MY NUMBER. THE FOUNDATION
FOR CLINICAL THRACIAN WE WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR SB
NINE OH FIVE. THE STATICALLY
THANK YOU. MOST OF MY NUMBER
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD OF. YOU
ALSO ALONG HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
YEAR IT'S GREEN BUILDING COUNCIL
IN LOS ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT
ESPECIALLY WITH THOSE SAYS
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL THAT
WOULD BE THAT IT YEAH I WAS ONE
OF MY FOLKS WERE NOW IN
OPPOSITION. NEVER CALLED THE
PHONE FOR IS THERE FOR SUPPORT.
WELL YEAH IS THAT RIGHT. SO I'M
- SORRY ABOUT THAT JUSTIN OKAY
WE'RE HERE FOR EVERYONE THEN.
IT'S A FREE FOR ALL ON THE
PHONES. EXCITEMENT OKAY LET'S
HEAR THE NEXT CALLER. THANKS A
LOT NUMBER ONE HUNDRED GO HEAD
SIX SHE'LL. YOUR FULL. ONE ONE
HUNDRED IS YOUR TURN LEAD. THIS
IS CHERYL KUNIO FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. THE PROJECT IN
SUPPORT. LEXELL ONE ONE OH FOR
GOD'S PLEASE. ONE ONE FOUR ONE
ZERO FROM. I'M ALL FOR FIFTEEN
HUNDRED ON YOUR SIDE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN AND YOU'RE AVAILABLE NOT
ADDRESS MANY. LET'S MOVE ON
MATTER. ONE OF THIS IS YOUR THE
QUEUE IS CLEAR WITHOUT THERE ARE
NO OTHER RESPONDENTS OKAY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MY APOLOGIES
THAT I THINK IS WHEN THE- TO
MAKE I GOT UP AND RAISE
CONCERNS. DURING THE SUPPORT I
STARTED MOVING OVER TO
OPPOSITION MODE IN MY MIND SO.
THERE WE ARE- GREAT WELL THIS IS
A GOOD GOOD ROBUST DISCUSSION
SOME GOOD IMPACT- INPUT FROM
BOTH SIDES HI WHAT ONE WE- ARE
NOW OPEN FOR DISCUSSION FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THOUGHTS WESTON'S
THUNDERSTORMS. YOU EARN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FOR BUT ALSO YOUR
LEADERSHIP- LAST YEAR IN LOOKING
AT A BROADER NATIONAL WORKING
LANDS AND TRYING TO BUILD SOME
SOME PARAMETERS IN THE SPACE
THAT WE CAN REALLY NOT
HYPOTHESIZE ABOUT THE C. C. U.
S. CONVERSATION BUT ACTUALLY-
DIG INTO WHAT THE PRACTICALITIES
PROJECT OR AND STARTING WITH
WITH WITH THE KINDS OF PROJECTS
THAT I THINK PEOPLE ON THE
WHOLE- SHOULD AGREE ON- I THINK
YOU. THINK THE CONSTRAINTS IN
THE BILL OUR OUR PRUDENT AT THIS
POINT- BEN WALLER ARE COMMITTEE
WOULD NORMALLY HAVE
JURISDICTION. OVER THESE KINDS
OF ISSUES I KNOW WERE YOU BE
OTHERWISE TRIPLE REFERRED TO I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SENATE
EDUCATION NEXT. BECAUSE YOU'VE
CREATED A UC PROGRAMMER YOU SEE
INSTITUTE OF SOME SORT- TO BE
THE HUB IS A COULD BE ALSO IT
CSU OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS
WELL BUT- I WOULD JUST. COMMIT
THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCE IN
WATER COMMITTEES- ASSISTANCE TO
YOU GOING FORWARD ON THIS
MEASURE- ESPECIALLY AS YOU WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THE MORE COMPLEX
ISSUES. THAT ARE EMBEDDED IN%
SOME SOME REALLY TIGHTLY
WRITTEN- PROVISIONS IN THIS
MEASURE BUT THAT. THAT MAY I'M
NOT I'M I'M NOT CONVINCED YET
WHETHER THEY'LL NEED. SORT OF
MORE STATUTORY FRAMEWORK WHETHER
WE CAN GET SOME OF THIS WORK
DONE AT THE REGULATORY LEVEL SO
FOR INSTANCE THE- SEVENTY ONE
TWO NINE FIVE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT- ENSURING THAT- ALL THE
RIGHTS AND INTERESTS- AND-
RESPONSIBILITIES SO SEE WITH.
FEW TO STORM THE GEOLOGIC
STORAGE RESERVOIR- OUR OUR SORT
OF WRAPPED UP IN THE ITLE- I
LIKE THE FINAL COROLLARY THAT
INCLUDES THE LIABILITY FOR AND
ANY AND ALL DAMAGES CAUSED BY.
ANOTHER WORDS IF YOU HAVE A
RELEASE FROM A PROJECT OF THAT
CEILING FORMATION DOESN'T WORK
FOR WHATEVER REASON WHAT
RECOURSE DO WE HAVE UNDER OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS PROGRAM- AND IN
THE PAST SOME OF THE PRINCIPLES
THAT HAVE BEEN OUTLINED AND
PERHAPS EVEN YOUR SPONSOR THE
CLIMATE WORKS FOLKS MAY KNOW BUT
THERE'S BEEN THAT THE IDEA OF A
OF A TRUST OR SOME KIND OF
INSURANCE MECHANISM. THAT
THERE'S A BUFFER ACCOUNT IF YOU
WILL IN CASE OF ANY RELEASE
YOU'RE NOT SORT OF FORCED INTO A
LITIGATION STANCE IF THINGS GO
WITH OF WRONG WITH THE PROJECT
BUT THAT THERE'S SORT OF A BUILT
IN UP FRONT. EITHER BOND OR SOME
KIND OF REQUIREMENT I THINK A
LOT OF YOU'VE LEFT SPACE FOR A
LOT OF THAT IN THE BILL TO BE
WORKED THROUGH I THINK THIS THE
UNIT IS ASIAN ISSUE AND SORT OF
POROSITY RIGHTS IS ANOTHER BIG
ONE WE KNOW THERE'S A SPLIT
STATE BETWEEN- THE MINERAL
STATE- AS WELL AS THE SERVICES
STATE AND- WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THE PROJECTS THAT WE DO
ONE OF THIS BILL- THEY WORK AND
THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE VIABLE AND
THEY REALLY DO PROVIDE NOT JUST-
ENVIRONMENTALLY DURABLE PATH TO
GO FORWARD BUT BUT ONE OF THE
MARKETS ONE THE WORK FORCE WHEN
THAT INVESTORS ARE GOING TO BE.
SEIZE FEASIBLE SO I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'VE DONE- TAKING A FIRST
SMALL STEP I THINK IS THE
SMARTER APPROACH HERE- AND- YEAH
I JUST WANT TO PLEDGE OUR OUR
WORK I KNOW THERE WERE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT- BY THE COMMITTEE FROM
FROM OUR COMMITTEE HERE BUT- BUT
I THINK. I WOULD BE CURIOUS AND
YOU CAN DO. IT IN YOUR CLOSER
OTHERS CAN MAKE REMARKS BUT- HOW
TO DEAL. THAT SORT OF THE
UNDERLYING A STATE AND MAKING
SURE THERE'S ENOUGH CERTAINTY
ABOUT- THE RIGHTS TO THAT VALUE
THAT ASSET. AND THEN SORT OF
RECOURSE THAT WE HAVE NGUYEN.
SEISMICITY FOR INSTANCE RIGHT
LIKE WE KNOW THAT THERE'S NOT A-
THERE'S NOT REALLY MUCH OF A
REGIME ON HOW UNDER THE CLASSICS
WILL CITY PA THEY DON'T REALLY
HAVE SEISMICITY BUILT INTO THAT
FRAMEWORK. HOW CAN WE DO THAT IS
A STATE IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY SO
JUST SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THINK
ABOUT GOING FORWARD BUT- HAVING
MOVED THE- BILL IT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND PROCEED TO
WORK. YEAH AND I WILL I WILL SAY
I MEAN I. WITH WITH WITH SO MUCH
RESPECT OUR FRIENDS THE RULES
COMMITTEE I WAS A LITTLE
MYSTIFIED BY THE WAY THAT THIS
BILL WAS- WAS AND REFERRED I DO
THINK THAT NATURAL SERVICES AND
WATER WOULD HAVE BEEN. THE
OBVIOUS PLACE FOR THIS TO GO-
BUT THAT BEING SAID- WE DID
INCLUDE AN EXTENSIVE NOTE FROM
THE COMMITTEE ON THE ANALYSIS
TWELVE ON PAGES TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN I JUST I WOULD ASK YOU
SENATOR. TO TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH- WITH NOT ONLY OUR
COMMITTEE BUT BUT ALSO- GOOD
ACTORS WATER COMMITTEE I TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE TECHNICAL
DETAILS THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED IN THE IN THE COMIC GIVEN
THEIR- PARTICULAR EXPERTISE IN
IN THE AREA OF. OIL EXTRACTION
CARBON CAPTURE ITS ADDRESS SO-
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING I WOULD- I
TO MOVE BY CENTER STERN AND WE
ASK YOU TO CLOSE. THANK YOU THE
BENEFIT OF WHAT THE BILLS WITH.
CONSTRUCTED AS PILOT PROJECT.
AND THE BENEFIT OF THAT IS THAT
AS PILOT PROJECTS. WE HOPE TO.
LEARN YOU CAN ALWAYS KNOW WHAT.
WHAT AND- DIFFICULTY IN MY FACE
OR WHAT COMPLICATIONS YOU COULD
FACE UNTIL YOU PILOTED IF WE
JUST OPENED UP CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE TO OSMAN INDUSTRY OR
TO EVEN MORE INDUSTRIES BEFORE
WE'VEREALLY HAD THE ABILITY TO
TRY IT OUT THE MEASURE IT THE
WAY IT IS TWO RESEARCH WHICH IS
PART OF THE REASON THE WE HAVE
THE EDUCATION COMPONENT TO HAVE
A CARD ESTABLISH EITHER AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CSU OR UC AN
INNOVATION HUB IN ORDER TO LOOK
AT THIS BECAUSE WE WANT TO GAIN
KNOWLEDGE I MEAN I PERSONALLY
BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
DO CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE.
IN A LOT MORE THAN JUST CEMENT
BUT THIS IS A GOOD FIRST START
AND LIKE SO MANY THINGS I MEAN
YES THERE THERE COULD BE AN
EARTHQUAKE AND THAT WOULD
RELEASE THE CARBON THAT WAS
GEOLOGICALLY STORED MOST LIKELY
BUT LOOK AT OUR WILDFIRES LOOK
AT THE AMOUNT OF TIME LOOKING AT
MY FRIEND OVER HERE LOOK AT THE
AMOUNT OF CARBON THAT'S GOTTEN
RELEASED AS A RESULT OF THOSE SO
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT ARE
UNDER OUR CONTROL BUT THOSE THAT
WHICH ARE. NOW WE NEED TO DO OUR
BEST TO DO IT WITHOUT A
ESCRIBIR. I'M I'M SO BUT SANTA
CLAUS HAS A VERY BRIEF COMMA TO
ME BECAUSE COULD LET ME. OF THE
KNOW THAT HI TO HAVE A- OF
CARBON CAPTURE PROGRAM THIS
DEMONSTRATION WILL- BASE WILL
INCLUDE NATURAL GAS AND- THE
METHANE ALSO TOOK. OUT A SISTER
A BILL TO THIS THEY'RE WORKING A
COOPERATIVELY SO SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS ON UNIONIZATION AND-
IT WILL GO TO ENERGY FOR THAT.
ROBUST DISCUSSION JUST SO
EVERYBODY KNOWS MORSE COMING.
GREAT OKAY CERTAINLY KALRA. THE
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB NINE OH
FIVE BY SENATOR SKINNER THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION ALAN HI ALAN I BATES
BATES NOTE DALLY DALLY NO
GONZALEZ AND SALAS I SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE STERN RIGHT STERN
AYE BY CASKEY BY CASKEY I'D-
OKAY. LET'S NOW GO TO YOUR NEXT
BILL THAT SELLS SB TWELVE A SIX
WILL BE THE ROLE OF ANY OTHER
ONE FOR OTHER PEOPLE THAT ON.
THIS ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN YOUR
PACKETS MEMBER AT EVERYBODY I
THINK. YEAH THAT'S RIGHT. RIGHT
OKAY. THANKS SO MUCH SIR MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SO THIS BILL IS
THE ANOTHER ONE OF THESE-
TECHNICAL BILLS AROUND OUR
CLIMATE CRISIS THERE ARE SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS THAT
ONLY LASTS THE ATMOSPHERE TWENTY
ODD YEARS BUT DURING THE TIME
THEY ARE IN THE ATMOSPHERE THERE
ARE THOUSANDS OF TIMES MORE
DAMAGING TO THE CLIMATE. THAN
CARBON DIOXIDE SO GIVEN THAT
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A CRISIS
RIGHT NOW AND FOR SOME OF YOU
MAY HAVE- WATCH THE- REPORTS
AROUND THE LATEST ANTARCTIC ICE
SHELF THE JUST- COLLAPSED- WE
NEED TO ACT AGGRESSIVELY BUT
ACTING AGGRESSIVELY AROUND THE
FULL TRANSITION OFF FOSSIL FUELS
IS A LITTLE HARDER IT'S NOT
IMPOSSIBLE BUT IT'S HARDER AND
SO IF WE CAN AS MUCH AS WE CAN
GET. THE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS OUT OF THE ATMOSPHERE
RIGHT NOW THE BETTER OFF WE'RE
GOING TO BE IN A PRICES TIME THE
PARTICULAR SHORTLIVED POLLUTANT
THAT 'M FOCUSED ON HERE IS HSCS
USED IN REFRIGERATION AND AIR
CONDITIONING NOW WE'VE ALREADY
DONE LEGISLATION WE'VE GONE A
LONG WAY TO- TO REDUCING THE-
THE- G. EIGHT THE GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL OF THOSE AGENCIES BUT-
THERE ARE. AVAILABLE ALL. NOW
AND THERE ARE LOWER GWP OR
GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL
AGENCIES AVAILABLE ON THE
MARKET. AND SO WE JUST NEED TO
MORE AGGRESSIVELY MOVED TO DOES
ADDITIONALLY. AT AIR
CONDITIONERS REFRIGERANTS THEY
LEAK AND IF THEY HAVE THE HIGHER
GLOBAL WARMING HFC IN THEM AND
IT LEAKS THEN THAT GOES INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE SO THE MORE OF THAT
WE CAN RECLAIM AND RECAPTURE
THOSE AND WHILE MY BILL DOESN'T
HAVE A SPECIFIC PROVISION. THAT
REQUIRES THAT IT DOES LET CARD
DEVELOP SOME PATHWAYS IN IF THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO INCENTIVIZE
THE CAPTURE OF THOSE
REFRIGERANTS BEFORE THEY ESCAPE-
AND I HOPE THAT THEY WILL
DEVELOP A PROGRAM TO DO SO. ON
THAT MY BILL AT LEAST CREATES
THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
LOOK AT THAT- SO I'M GONNA LET
MY- EXPERTS SPEAK FROM THE MAIN
PART OF THE YEAR ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS YES AN ACCEPTABLE
MOMENTS THE MAIN PART OF BILL
HOWEVER THERE IS THE- IS.
BRINGING FORWARD THE TIMELINE
FOR WHEN THE HIGHEST GLOBAL
WARMING HSCS ARE ALLOWED TO BE
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA- AND ALSO TO
UPDATE OR APPLIANCE STANDARDS
THOSE ARE THE MAIN THINGS BUT IT
DOES ALLOW CARP ALL STEWART TO
EXPLORE OTHERS SO ALLOW ME TO
HAVE CRISTINA STORE. FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL INVESTIGATION
AGENCY. AND ALEX- BRAND FROM IN
OUR DC. AS MY WITNESS THREE ALL
RIGHT LET'S START WITH THEM
MISTER. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
CRISTINA START BUYING ON BEHALF
OF ENVIRONMENTAL INVESTIGATION
AGENCY AND SUPPORTED AT THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. YEAH A HAS
PARTICIPATED IN INTERNATIONAL
CLIMATE NEGOTIATIONS LIKE THIS
USED FOR MORE THAN TWO DECADES.
WE MUST ACCELERATE HE'S A BAKER
EMISSION REDUCTION BEYOND OUR
CURRENT SCHEDULE IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE ARE GLOBAL FINANCIALS
UNDER THE PARIS AGREEMENT. THE
BILL PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK FOR
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD THE WAY AND
DOING JUST THAT. FIRST BY
RESTRICTING SALES OF NEWLY
PRODUCED AGENCIES IT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY ENCOURAGE
INCREASED RECOVERY RECLAMATION.
ANDRECYCLING OF AGENCIES AND
REDUCE WEEKS WHICH WILL HAVE AN
IMMEDIATE EFFECT ON REDUCING
EMISSIONS IT'S RELATIVELY EASY
TO CAPTURE USER FOR DRINKS OR
OLD EQUIPMENT AND RECLAIM NUMBER
USE. THE PROBLEMS ARE ALREADY
RECLAIMED EACH YEAR AND THIS
LEGISLATION WILL HELP MAKE THIS
MORE COST EFFECTIVE BY
INCREASING DEMAND AND GIVING HER
HER. DRAG OUT YOU IF AND THE
FLIGHT. THANK THIS BUDGET
MANDATE THE CAR AND THE BEAUTY
DEVELOP. TO INCREASE ADOPTION OF
NO OR VERY LOW GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL ALTERNATIVES AGENCIES
IN EUROPE BUT THAT. INCLUDING
THROUGH FOR THE REGULATORY
MEASURES AND INCENTIVES. VERY
LOW GWP ALTERNATIVES ARE
INCREASINGLY COMMERCIALLY
AVAILABLE IN THE U. S. GLOBALLY
FOR A RANGE OF USERS. AND THE
INDUSTRY CAN AND SHOULD
TRANSITION AWAY FROM THE MOST
HARMFUL REFRIGERANT ULTIMATELY
MOVING TOWARDS REFRIGERANTS WITH
LOW OR NO CLIMATE IMPACT. WE
NEED STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA TO
LEADING GROWING THE MARKET FOR
THESE NEW CLIMATE ALTERNATE THAT
. THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY AND I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO BACK SUPPORT DRAFT
LEGISLATION FORWARD A POSITIVE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT NEXT ONE IS
PLEASE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS ALEX PHIL GRAMM ALEX A
BRAND OF AN ADVOCATE WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. AN RTC SUPPORTS MOVING
SB TWELVE ZERO SIX FORD WELL.
WE'VE ALSO WORKED FOR SEVERAL
DECADES PROTECT THE OZONE LAYER
AND CLIMATE SYSTEM REMAINS
HARMFUL REFRIGERANT TYPES OF
GASES INCLUDING HYDROCHLORIC
CARBONS MOST RECENTLY. THAT SOME
OF YOU KNOW HERE IN THE U. S. AS
SOME OF THE LOOTED IF YOU WERE
STARTING ON AN EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENT. OVER. FIFTEEN EARLY AND
AMBITIOUS ACTION ON AGENCIES WAS
AN INDISPENSABLE PART OF THIS
EFFORT TO PASS NATIONAL EACH OF
C. LEGISLATION AND HAS ALSO
HELPED THE CLIMATE. OF DIRECTLY
TO BOOT TWELVE ZERO SIX CARRIES
THAT LEADERSHIP FORWARD
PROPOSING MEASURES THAT HAVE
JUST BEEN DESCRIBED AND
ESSENTIALLY CALL ON THE INDUSTRY
NOT TO GIVE UP HERE BUT RATHER
TO KEEP INNOVATING CLIMATE
FRIENDLIER HFC ALTERNATIVES. AND
THAT'S CRISTINA JUST MENTIONED
THE BILL ALSO INDIRECTLY
ENCOURAGES A VAST EXPANSION IN
THE INDUSTRY THAT RECLAIMS
RECOVERS REUSES RECYCLES OLD
HSCS FROM THE EXISTING STOCK
WILL CLIENTS IS OUT THERE USING
THEM. THIS IS A KEY STEP IN
TODAY WERE MISSING THIS
OPPORTUNITY BUT WITH THIS BILL
WE TAKE A STEP TOWARDS MAKING
THAT MORE PREDOMINANT OF A
PRACTICE MORE COST EFFECTIVE.
SEVERAL OTHER GOOD THINGS. THIS
WILL ALSO HELP CUT EMISSIONS
DIRECTLY THEY CAN'T SEE A
MISSION BY THE WAY TWENTY
NINETEEN RESTORED RIGHT
CALIFORNIA I'M SO SORRY. AND
VERY MUCH WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
GOOD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE OFFICE
OFFICE THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING. FANTASTIC THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY LET'S SEE
IF IS. ANYONE HERE IN PERSON
ONCE THE VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. PERSONAL COULD ALSO ON
BEHALF OF NATIONAL ATTACKS
COUNCIL INTO. THANK YOU- EXIT
CHAU OF CAL AGAINST WASTE SINCE.
THANK YOU. OKAY ANYONE THE PHONE
LINES ONE OF OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL SB TWELVE OH SIX. THE VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL PRESS ONE
ZERO PLEASE WHAT A LINE ONE GOAL
ONE IS CUTER. IS GOING TO ONCE
LOCAL. THIS IS JOHN HANCOCK
THREE THIRTY TWO ABOUT WITH THE-
MUCH OF OUR WORK. ON FINE. WE.
WELL SIX. HUNDRED PART THANK YOU
. THANK YOU THANKS FOR THE
ALLOWED NUMBER TWENTY TWO ONE
TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD WHAT. HELLO
THIS IS WILL BRING HER THREE
FIFTY AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE NEXT IN
LINE ONE- LET THEM GO AHEAD. IS
DAN CHANDLER WITH THREE FIFTY
HUMBOLDT AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MISTER CHEROKEE WAS
CLEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL
RIGHT- I KNOW WE HAVE DONNED
KHAKI HERE TO- THE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. MAY PURSUE
AN ARMY GREAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURR SAID DON KHAKI
MCCUE CAP CAN ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF AIR CONDITIONING
HEATING AND REFRIGERATION
INSTITUTE. I RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED BUT CERTAINLY
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
SENATOR AND HER TEAM ON THE BILL
I NOTABLY H. ARAI IS BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PHASE DOWN HFC
USE. ARE NOT ONLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA A BIT NATIONALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY HAVING WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH CAR THE LAST
FW YEARS ON THEIR RULEMAKING
PACKAGE FOR MOVING TO LOW GWP
REFRIGERANTS. AS WELL AS WORKING
VERY PROGRESSIVELY PROACTIVELY
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO PASS THE
IMAC TO CERTAINLY WE SUPPORT THE
GOALS IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE
TURN CONCERNS OF WORKABILITY
ISSUES WITH THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED. A WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH OF THE PROPOSAL AS
CURRENTLY UNDER THE CAR
REGULATION WE ARE WORKING AND
REALLY READY AS AN INDUSTRY TO
MOVE TOWARDS THOSE LOWER GWP
REFRIGERANTS. AND YET WE CANNOT
DO SO DUE TO THE FACT THAT THE
STTE HASN'T UPDATED STATES-
BUILDING CODES TO INCORPORATE
THE SAFETY STANDARDS FOR THOSE
NEW LOW GWP REFRIGERANTS SO WE
KNOW THE SENATORS CERTAINLY
AWARE OF THIS ARE CERTAINLY
DISCUSSING THAT WITH HER. AND SO
THAT CAUSES A CONCERN WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ALREADY MOVING THE
BALL TOWARDS THESE A NEW ULTRA
LOW VERY LOW GWP REFRIGERANT
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE NATURAL
THOSE NATURAL OPTIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE ARE HIGHLY
FLAMMABLE. AND REPRESENTS A
REALLY SIGNIFICANT SAFETY
CONCERN NOT TO MENTION THERE ARE
NO SAFETY STANDARDS THAT HAVE
BEEN DEVELOPED FOR THOSE
ALTERNATIVE AND NATURAL ULTRA
LOW GWP REFRIGERANTS. AND IN
CONTEXT OF THE ONES THAT ARE IN
PROCESS AND WAITING TO BE ABLE
TO USE NOW THOSE ARE ONLY MILDLY
FLAMMABLE AND WERE UNABLE TO
MOVE THOSE BUILDING STANDARDS
FORWARD. ON THE ISSUE OF RE
CLEAN H. REYES ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF RECLAIM I WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
CARVE ON OF THE RECLAIM ASPECT
OF. OUR THEIR GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES UNFORTUNATELY THERE
ARE SOME CHALLENGES TO THAT AND
WE'RE STILL EXPLORING. AND
TRYING TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT
THOSE CHALLENGES- ALL. AS A
RELATES TO THE- ACTION UNDER AIM
AT IT'S PUTTING HIM. A PHASE
DOWN THAT'S- IN SOME MARKETS
CONDITIONS THAT ARE CERTAINLY
ARE DRIVING THE DEMAND FOR
RECLAIM A BUT WE'RE NOWHERE IS A
STATE CLOSE ENOUGH TO RE CLAIM
TO BE ABLE TO. OUR SERVICE THE
EQUIPMENT IT'S IN USE TODAY AND
NOT JUST PRESENTS SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT WORK ABILITY
CHALLENGES IF WE WERE TO PUT A
DATE CERTAIN BAN ON KIND OF FULL
SALES OF HSCS. FOR THOSE TYPES
OF EQUIPMENT TODAY THE CERTAINLY
AGAIN H. RIGHT SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOALS AND DIRECTION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR AND HER TEAM AS WELL AS
THE COMMITTEE- IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME A LEAVE IT THERE BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO VOICE.
OPPOSITION ABOUT THE BILL.
JENNIFER WROTE ON BEHALF OF
JOHNSON CONTROLS OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED MEMBER OF H. R. I. AN
ECHO ARE CONCERNED THANK YOU
JOHNSON CONTROL THAT'S IT OKAY
SEE COMPANY. OKAY OKAY OUR PHONE
LINES ANYONE WANT TO VOICE
CONCERN OPPOSITION THE BILL ON
THE PHONE LINES. THE PROPOSAL
THE PHONE TO OPEN IT IN. PRESS
ONE ZERO PLEASE. SURE WE DO HAVE
ONE COMING UP IT'LL BE ONE
MOMENT.
ONE MOMENT SIR. AND TAKEN THE
COMMITTEE IMMENSE. THE ONE
NUMBER ONE FOUR EIGHT POINT ONE
LITER OPEN. HI THIS IS ALLOCATED
THE HEAT AND RECORD STREAMERS
INTERNATIONAL OR THE WHOLESALERS
OF A REFRIGERATOR AIR
CONDITIONER PRODUCTION
EQUIPMENT- WITH NUMBERS IN THE
STATE. PHONE MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE IT
SIGNIFICANTLY HARDER TO REPAIR
EXISTING EQUIPMENT BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF SERVICE GASES IF
THERE IS NO SERVICE YES MAIL
BECAUSE THE LIMIT AMOUNT OF
REQUIREMENTS INTRODUCED
MENTIONED IT WILL MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO SERVICE THE PIECE
OF EQUIPMENT I'M HAPPY REPLACED
WHERE A COST THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS HIGHER IN REPAIRABILITY.
I THINK IN A- A VERY BAD IDEA.
FOR US CALIFORNIA. OKAY ONE ARE
MY FOLKS SAID- THIS IS
OPPORTUNITY JUST TO VOICE
SERVICE YOUR YOUR IN A PLACE TO
ME TO- ANYONE LSE MATTER.
MISTER CHEROKEE WAS CLEAR GREAT
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- LET'S
GO TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTION
SENATOR. WELL I THINK THE
SENATOR FOR WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE BUT- HAS SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT. ACTUALLY BEING ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT AND WE'RE SETTING A
GOAL- AND WE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT. AVAILABILITY
OF GASES IN THE GASES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THERE ARE MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SAFE FAR MORE
FAMILIES ARE BUILDING CODES-
THIS EMINDS ME OF THE MTV EVEN
WE PUT MTV AND GASOLINE TO HELP
THEIR QUALITY ACTUALLY DAMAGED
OUR GROUND WATER AND SO- THIS
WAS A LONG TIME AGO NOT HAPPEN
SO I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS
ON LIKE. HOW THIS IS ACTUALLY AN
IMPLEMENT AND WHAT THE FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE I THINK THAT WE NEED
I'M- THINKING WE NEED MORE
INFORMATION ON WHAT. TECHNOLOGY
AVAILABLE TO ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT.
THE GOAL. CERTAINLY- PERMISSION
ANSWER. I'M LIKE SO MANY THINGS
WE CAN'T ALWAYS WE NEED TO SET
GOALS WHICH CAN THEN HELP DRIVE
MARKETS BUT IN THIS CASE THERE
ARE ALREADY ON MANY OF THE
COUNTRIES IN THE E. YOU HAVE SET
THEIR STANDARDS FOR THESE LOWER
GWP REFRIGERANTS AND THEY ARE
USING THEM THEY'RE USING THE
LEAST FLAMMABLE OF THEM NOT THE
MOST BUT THEY ARE IN ALREADY IN
APPLICATION IN VARIOUS EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES NOW. ON CLEARLY THERE
WHILE I'M MOVING UP THE DATE IT
IS STILL GIVING SOME TIME FOR
NOT ONLY CAR BUT THE INDUSTRY TO
FOR THE IF IT'S PARTLY IT SENDS
THAT MESSAGE TO THE PRODUCERS
AND THE RESEARCHERS AND
DEVELOPERS. IN ORDER TO GET US
THE OPTIMAL IN MOST SAFE
ALTERNATIVES WHEN I THINK ABOUT
YEARS AGO WHEN I CARRIED THE
BILL FOR- UTILITY GRADE ENERGY
STORAGE THERE WERE THERE WERE NO
UTILITY GRADE BATTERIES. AND-
IT'S CONNECTED TO OUR GRID
STORING STORING OUR ELECTRICITY
AND NOW WE DIDN'T HAVE OUR THE
LEAD OF THE MARKET ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND WE HAVE BUT YOU KNOW
I CAN'T GIVE YOU THE EXACT
NUMBERS BUT ANYWAY SO. THE SO AT
LEAST WE KNOW RIGHT NOW THAT
SOME OF THESE LOW GWP
ALTERNATIVE REFRIGERANTS ARE IN
USE IN EUROPE- BUT WE DO HAVE TO
GET CC TO FIX THEIR BUILDING
CODES AND THEY OBVIOUSLY WILL BE
LOOKING VERY CAREFULLY AT
FLAMMABILITY STANDARDS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT SAFETY- AND-
MY STAFF WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY TO YOU KNOW TO LOOK AT
WHAT ELSE WE NEED TO TWEAK TO
MAKE IT. TO MAKE IT IS TO OPPOSE
POSSIBLE AND IS SAFE AS POSSIBLE
BUT THESE. ON NINETY TWO MAY
HAVE THE COMMITTEE GO LONGER
BUT- I STARTED WORKING I GOT
INVOLVED IN THE ISSUE OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS THROUGH THE OZONE
DEPLETION ISSUE. AND WHEN THE
MONTREAL PROTOCOL IS REGAINING
NEGOTIATED BACK IN THE LATE
EIGHTIES EIGHTY EIGHT AND EIGHTY
NINE. AND AT THAT TIME WE WERE
USING CFCS WHICH WERE FAR MORE
DAMAGING AND WE WERE USING THEM
IN ALL KINDS OF THINGS BESIDES
YOUR CONDITIONING AND
REFRIGERANTS AND A STAR FROM
PRODUCTION IT'S WHAT LED ME TO
BAN STYROFOAM. BECAUSE
BASICALLY- BUT ANYWAY. WHAT WHAT
HAPPENED IS. IN THE MONTROSE PRO
WE PROMOTE HSCS BECAUSE THEY
WERE LESS. DEPLETING THE OZONE
LATER WITHOUT FULLY
UNDERSTANDING HOW SERIOUS THEY
WERE IN TERMS OF THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. BUT YOU KNOW WE'VE KNOWN
THAT NOW FOR HOW MANY YEARS AGO
WAS THAT THAT WAS SOME THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AGO WE'VE KNOWN THAT.
FOR AT LEAST THIRTY YEARS SO
WE'RE KIND OF BEHIND GIVEN HOW
LONG WE'VE KNOWN THAT THEE H.
FC'S HALF THIS DAMAGE SO WE NEED
TO ACCELERATE OUR- OUR ABILITY
TO GET THE ALTERNATIVES. INTO
THE MARKETPLACE AND BEING
UTILIZED SO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME TO ON MY
OWN TIME SO LOOK I WANT TO SEE
IS. DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE
THE ENVIRONMENT WELL BUT AT THE
SAME TIME- WE NOTICED IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE THE
LEGISLATURE'S. APPROACH IS BEEN
. MORE OF A MORE OF A STICK THEN
THE CARROT AND WHEN I SAY THAT I
MEAN IT. ON THIS GIVEN EXAMPLE
WE WANT TO GO TO ELECTRIFICATION
OF CARS. TO HELP THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND WE WANT TO GO
WE WANT TO ALLOW THEIR THIRTY
MILLION CARS IN CALIFORNIA. IN A
MILLION NUMBER ELECTRIC. BUT OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR OUR GRID IS
NOT THERE YET SO STRIVING THE
COST OF FUEL UP. IN CALIFORNIA'S
A LOT OF THESE THINGS DRIVE THE
COST OF LIVING UP IN RIGHT NOW-
IF YOU'VE NOT NOTICED THAT
CALIFORNIA'S VERY EXPENSIVE
PLACE TO LIVE IN IS BECAUSE WE
ARE LEADING. ARE SUPPOSEDLY
LEADING AND- A LOT OF DIFFERENT
AREAS WHEN IT COMES TO. CLIMATE
SO. AS A LEGISLATOR I'M TRYING
TO BALANCE OUT. DO IS THE
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE TO DO THE
JOB THAT WE WANT TO GET DONE.
AND OUT OF AND THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO- MAKE SURE THAT SOMEBODY
CAN AFFORD TO MAKE IT HAPPEN AT
THE SAME TIME SO WE DON'T DIVERT
OUR- INDUSTRIES AWAY FROM
CALIFORNIA WE ACTUALLY. MAKE IT
SO THAT LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND-
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
CAN ACTUALLY STAY ON
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A IN THIS CASE
. A REFRIGERATOR A REFRIGERATOR
IN THEIR LOCAL STORE THAT
ACTUALLY DOESN'T DRIVE THE COST
OF THEIR FOOD UP SO THOSE ARE
THE BALANCES THAT ARE REALLY
DIFFICULT IN THIS LEGISLATURE
AND QUITE FRANKLY I'M FRUSTRATED
AT THE FACT THAT WE ALWAYS LOOK
AT LIKE A WE JUST HAVE TO FORCE
THEM TO DO IT. THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS GOING TO DO AND THE
OTHER BILLS THAT WE SEE TODAY IS
FORCING THEM TO DO IT AT THE
SAME TIME THE TECHNOLOGY IS NOT
THERE IT WOULD HAVE THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY. WE DON'T HAVE THE
REGULATIONS FOR THE BUILDING
FOLKS ON THE SAME TO AND ALL
THAT DOES IS DRIVE THE COST OF
HOMES AND FOOD AND THINGS THAT
WE NEED EVERY DAY UP WITHOUT I
THINK WE'RE MOVING TOO FAST AND
WE NEED TO STEP BACK SO FOR
TODAY I'M GONNA NOT BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL. INTEL WEEK
MAYBE SLOW DOWN A LITTLE BIT AND
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT SEE HOW IT'S
GONNA WORK AT THE END AND WHAT
THE COST IS TO THE CONSUMER FOR.
THE REDUCTION IN GHG ARE WE
REALLY GETTING OUR VALUE THERE.
THANK YOU. YEAH OKAY. SENATE
BILL I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE ON THAT
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND IN
PARTICULAR THOSE IN THE
EXTREMELY HARD AREAS OF- IN LAND
ORANGE COUNTY- THEY THINK THAT
THEY COULDN'T RUN THEIR AIR
CONDITIONERS BECAUSE THESE
PRODUCTS ARE AVAILABLE YEAH
THAT. WOULD BE DEVASTATING AND
SO THOSE ARE THE CONCERNS- NOBLE
GOAL FINE NO QUESTION ON THAT
BUT I THINK IT IS MOVING AWFULLY
FAST AND TWO WE HAVE SCIENCE
THEY'RE TELLING US THAT WE CAN
GET THERE IN ODD I GUESS TO
RECYCLE REFRIGERANTS. ARE REALLY
GOING TO BE READILY AVAILABLE
WITHOUT HAVING TO PURCHASE THEM
OUT OF STATE FOR YOU KNOW VERY
HIGH COST YOUR STARTING HIT HIT
THE WHOLE ENERGY AREA AGAIN AND
THAT IS PROBABLY THE HIGHEST
COST. ALL RIGHT NOW FOR PEOPLE
IN LOW INCOME AREAS SO- I JUST
CIRCLE THAT TO A LITTLE MORE
TIME IS NEEDED BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE GOAL ABSOLUTELY
BUT TODAY I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
AFFORD. IT HOPE YOU LICK IT AND
MEHMET PERHAPS WHERE WE WOULD BE
ABLE- HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FRANKLY TO ALLOW. EXISTING IF
THE BE RECYCLED REFRIGERANTS ARE
AVAILABLE TO ALLOW SOME OF THOSE
OLDER HOMES WITH THESE OLDER
APPLIANCES TO ACTUALLY HAVE THE
EXISTING ONES FOR A CERTAIN
PERIOD OF TIME IF THERE'S
EVIDENCE THAT THE- RECYCLED ONES
ARE NOT AVAILABLE FUNDING TO
THAT EFFECT. THAT COULD BE
MONITORED. OKAY YES SIR I'M LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME BUT I ALSO WANT
TO- THANK THE AUTHOR AND I KNOW
WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT- ALTERNATIVE REFRIGERANTS
. BUT THE WAY I UNDERSTAND YOUR
BILL IS HE- THE DEFINITION OF
NEW VERY LOW GWP REFRIGERANT
TECHNOLOGY ALSO INCLUDES THINGS
LIKE HEAT PUMPS A DON'T ACTUALLY
REQUIRE THAT REFRIGERANT AT ALL
AND SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A
BURGEONING MARKET PLACE RIGHT
NOW IN THAT SPACE TO PROVIDE
BOTH COOLING AND HEATING SO
PERHAPS IN YOUR CLOTHES YOU
COULD. TALK ABOUT IT SEEMS LIKE-
THEY'RE THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOESN'T
NEED TO BE THAT MUCH MORE-
STUDYING OR- OR- DELAY TO THINK
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT COOLEY
POSSIBLY REPLACE OUR BROKEN OLD
COOLING SYSTEMS WITH BECAUSE-
WE'RE DEPLOYING THE CDC
RECOMMENDS I THINK SIX MILLION.
HE COMES BEING AND INSTALLED IN
CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY THIRTY. IF
YOU LOOK AT IF THE CECE'S PLAN
TAKES EFFECT AT THE SAME TIME
THAT YOUR BILL TIMELINE IS
STARTING TO TAKE EFFECT IN
THEORY WE CAN HAVE- SOME REALLY
EXCITING MARKET TRANSFORMATION
SO. THE ONLY THING I WOULD JUST
CAUTION IS- I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'VE BEEN. TRYING TO NEGOTIATE
AND WORK THROUGH- TIMELINES AND
I SAW IN SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS
FROM FROM COMMITTEE OR MAYBE
FROM THE AUTHOR THAT- THERE'S
GOING TO BE. DISCUSS ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION DELAY AND A FEW
OTHER SORT OF- DELAYED DELAYS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ALIGNMENT
WITH FEDERAL ACTION I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT- WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE NORTH I
THINK WE CAN'T AFFORD TO WAIT-
TO GET THIS GOING I DON'T WANT
TO SEE IS WAITING OUT TILL
TWENTY THIRTY IN TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE TO. DRAMATICALLY TRANSFORM
HEATING COOLING SPACE IN THE
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR IN RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMERCIAL SECTORS NEED THIS
BILL AND NEED SOME CHANGE SO-
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FORTH IN
CUSTODY I JUST I AM. ALL IN ON
HOW TO FLIRT CARBON GAS
REDUCTIONS APPLIED THE OTHER
AUTHOR PICKING UP ON WHAT CENTER
STERNA SAID I'M WONDERING IF THE
AIRPORT IS THE RIGHT AGENCY TO
BE TO BE- PROMULGATING
REGULATIONS ON THE TECHNOLOGY
VERSUS THE C. E. C. AND I WOULD
JUST ASK YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT- BECAUSE IT MAY BE. QUICKER
THREE POINT. B. SO. YES THE
SHIP- IN YOUR CLOTHES SHE HAS AN
AFFECT ON THE BUILDING CODE
ANYWAY COOL WE- FOR AGENCIES
RESPOND AS APPROPRIATELY SO
NUMBER THINGS UNLIKE SOME OF MY
BILLS WHICH WERE AMBITIOUS IN
NATURE INCLUDING GOALS FOR WHICH
WE DID NOT YET HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGIES IN COMMERCIAL
APPLICATION IN THIS CASE THOSE
LOADS THE W. P. REFRIGERANTS ARE
IN USE THEY ARE NOT AS IN USE IN
THE US BUT THEY ARE IN USE IN
EUROPE. AND THE THIRD IN OUR DC
ALEX- COULD HAVE. DONE SOME OF
THE TECHNICAL EXPLANATIONS OF
THAT STYLE BUT WE'LL JUST LEAVE
IT AT THAT WE CAN ALWAYS GET YOU
THAT- IF NEEDED ADDITIONALLY THE
MOVING UPDATE IS STILL TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE THAT IS THIRTEEN
YEARS FROM NOW SO WHILE THAT MAY
SEEM SHORT IT'S NOT SHORTEN WE
THINK ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE THE LINK
YOU KNOW WHEN THIS GOT
INTRODUCED IN HOW YOU BIG TO IS
IT IS OR THAT WE LOOK AT HOW-
YOU KNOW VARIETY OF THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES. NEW- YOUR IT AND
SINCE WE SINCE THE WHOLE WORLD
IS FOCUSED ON THIS CLAIM IT
CRISIS AND THERE IS MUCH.
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT AND
INNOVATION UNDERWAY I AM
CONFIDENT THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
MEET THIS- ADDITIONALLY THE IT
DOES NOT REQUIRE ANYONE WHO HAS
A CURRENT AIR CONDITIONER IN
THEIR HOME TO GET RID OF THAT
AIR CONDITIONER. OR YOU KNOW.
NOT BE ABLE TO- REPLACE IF IT'S
IF IT'S REFRIGERANT NEEDS
REPLACEMENT FOR A GOOD WHILE AND
BY THAT POINT. THE SHOULD BE
VERY AVAILABLE NOW OR AT LEAST
THEIR BE RECLAIMED MARKET SHOULD
BE MUCH MORE VIBRANT- I WANTED
TO JUST HIGHLIGHT THE AMENDMENTS
ANSWER SEEMS TO BE A QUESTION.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE IN
BOLD SO IN NUMBER FOUR IT'S THE
REPLACING THE REFERENCES TO
NATURAL ALTERNATIVES WITH ULTRA
LOW GWP ALTERNATIVES THAT HAVE A
GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL OF LESS
THAN TEN. IT IS THE- REMOVING
THE SECTOR SPECIFIC REFERENCES-
THE SUIT WOULD BE ALL SECTORS
RATHER IN THAT SECTOR SPECIFIC
REFERENCES. AND THEN THE
REMOVING THE REQUIREMENT FOR THE
P. YOU SEE TO DEVELOP THE
STRATEGY FOR INCLUDING LOW GWP.
AND NOW TO REFRIGERANTS IN
EQUIPMENT FUNDED BY THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM. SO THOSE ARE
THE AMENDMENTS. AND WITH THAT
FAST ZERO VOTE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT I'LL MOVE BY
CENTER STERN THANK YOU FOR THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
WE'RE GONNA FIGURE A BETTER WAY
OF SIGNIFYING COMMITTEE MEN'S
VERSUS OTHER MEN'S IN THE
ANALYSIS GOING FORWARD. SO YOU
ALSO INSPIRED CHANGE IN THAT
RESPECT SENATOR. ASSERTED HIS
FELLOW. I THE NUMBER THIRTEEN SB
TWELVE OH SIX BY SENATOR SKINNER
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN ALL RIGHT ALAN I BATES.
BATES NO DALI DALI NO GOOD
pSOLID. THE DALLAS AYE SKINNER
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN STERN
HIGHWAY CASKEY MY CASKEY AYE.
OKAY SO THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU
. MAYBE I HAVE A MOTION ON
THOSE. THAT DON'T. SORRY THAT I
MOVED UP BILL CENTER STRANDED
OKAY YES AND STERN- CITY MOVIE
WHEN APPROPRIATE OKAY LET'S GO
TO CINEMA CASKEY WHO'S GOING TO
PRESENT SB TWELVE FIFTY SIX. SO
MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS A
HALF OF. POUND CANISTER THAT'S-
GIVE YOU GUYS OFFICIALS THIS MY
BILL DEALS WITH THE SCEPTER
CAMPING CANISTERS THAT FOLKS
WILL DEAL WITH IN S. B. TWELVE-
FIFTY SIX. JUST LIKE LATE LAST
WEEK- WORTHINGTON INDUSTRIES
WHOSE A LARGE PRODUCER OF
PROPANE CANISTERS REACHED OUT TO
MY OFFICE AT WITH THE POTENTIAL
ALTERNATIVE TO THIS. BAND BILL
WITHIN THAT EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY BILL- I HAVE HAD
SOME INITIAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEM IT'S AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
BILL- THAT THEY'RE PROPOSING IT
DOES I THINK IT'S ME TO THE
PROMISED LAND OR TWO IT'S ALL OF
US TO WE WANT TO. BE IS THAT
THESE ARE NOT THROWN INTO A
GARBAGE AND AS SUCH AS STAFF
REPORTS. NOTES CAN CAUSE A
DAMAGE FIRES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT SO I WILL BE HAPPY TO HAVE
TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEM- AND WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
COMMITTEE INSULT CONSULTANT AS
THOSE THINGS GO ON. YOU HAVE A
DIFFERENT BILL IN FRONT OF YOU
RIGHT NOW- THAT I WOULD ASK FOR
YOU GUYS TO VOTE. FOR ON S. B.
AT. TWELVE FIFTY FOUR BECAUSE
THIS BILL DOES- BANNED THE USE
OF THESE- PROPANE CYLINDERS. IT
THE DESIGN IS TO HELP CALIFORNIA
TRANSITION TO- YOU KNOW SAVE
CONSUMERS MONEY IMPROVE OUR
ENVIRONMENT- THERE'S- I THINK IN
THE ABUNDANCE OF TIME- MISTER
CHAIR I WON'T PASS. THE MY
WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE TO-
SPEAKING SUPPORT- AS THE
COMMITTEE AS A SPECIAL MOVES
THROUGH THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AS I SAID I WILL CONTINUE TO
KEEP YOU IN MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ABREAST OF ANY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES THAT THE
BILL MIGHT TAKE I HAVE-
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL HERE- PRISCILLA. HI
QUIROS TO A TEST TRANSPORT. MORE
INJURE MEMBERS PERSECUTOR
SOMETHING WHICH I YOUR INTEREST
WILL CERTAINLY HERE ON BEHALF OF
HEALTHCARE PRODUCTS WHICH
COUNCIL WHO ARE PROUD SPONSORS
OF SB TWELVE FIFTY SIX. I TWELVE
FIFTY SIX WOULD BAN THE SALE OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO POUND PROPANE
CYLINDERS TO ENSURE THAT THE
EXIT AND WILL TAKE EFFECT UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT TO ENSURE
THAT THE EXISTING REFILLING AND
EXCHANGE INFRASTRUCTURE
MARKETPLACE KINETICALLY MEET
DEMAND. BEFORE DISPOSABLES ARE
COMPLETELY BANNED APPROX EVERY
YEAR POSSIBLY FORTY MILLION A
SINGLE USE TO POUND PRESLEY
PROPANE CYLINDERSARE
MANUFACTURED IN THE U. S. AND
SOLD AN ESTIMATED. FOUR MILLION
ARE IN CALIFORIA ALONE. AS ARE
SUPPOSED MANAGED AS- HAZARDOUS
WAY AND SO THEY'RE EMPTY.
DISPOSED IMPROVEMENTS OR GARBAGE
CANS OR THROWN AWAY AT LOCAL
STATE PARKS AND FEDERAL PARKS
AND BEACHES. IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT NGUYEN IT COULD BE
DESCRIBED IN THE TRASH ORIENT
RECYCLING BUT IT'S DECEPTIVE.
SINCE THERE'S NO BLEEDER OR
BALLOTS TO COMPLETELY HOW THE
CONSUMER OR THE WASTE OR
RECYCLING FACILITIES JUST ENSURE
THAT COMPLETELY. AND THIS MEANS
THE TANKS OFTEN CONTAIN A SMALL
AMOUNT OF GAS WHICH POSE A
DANGER TO SANITATION WORKERS TO
THE RISK OF EXPLOSIONS AND
RESULTING IN FIRES. A NUMBER
YEARS AGO AN EXPLOSION HAPPENED
IN SUNNYVALE AS A RESULT OF ONE
OF THESE CANISTERS- ALTHOUGH THE
PROCEDURES DO POSE A FIRE HAZARD
WE BELIEVE THE RISK IS MINIMAL-
ARE STILL A WAYS. YOUR SYSTEMS
ARE. LEGALLY OBLIGATED D'HIVER
AND PROPERLY HANDLE THESE
DISPOSABLE TANKS WHEN THEY'RE
DETECTED THE COST OF DIVERTING
PROPERLY AND BANISHING AND
RECYCLING IS DISPOSABLE PROPANE
TANKS. VERY CROSS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SOLID WASTE
RECYCLING OPERATION CON-
CONTRACTS ARE COMPLEX IT'S NOT
APPLES TO APPLES. COMPARISON BUT
SOME JURISDICTIONS PAY AS LITTLE
AS TWO DOLLARS PER TANK AND SOME
AS HIGH AS TWENTY FIVE. BUT
OVERALL IT'S APPROXIMATELY THREE
THREE DOLLARS PER TANK THESE
DISPOSABLE PROPANE CYLINDERS
HAVE HAD SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
OUR PARKS YOSEMITE CONSERVANCY
HAS BEEN TRACKING THE NUMBER OF.
AND TYPE OF SIZE OF THESE FUEL
TANKS I COLLECTED THE STATE
PARKS AND INTO A TWENTY NINETEEN
ARTICLE FROM WASTE THREE SIXTY.
THE CLAIM THAT THE PARK HAD
COLLECTED FROM TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND TANKS PER YEAR. AS
ONE OF ASSEMBLY SUSTAINABILITY
INITIATIVES. AND FOCUS ON
REDUCING IMPROPER DISPOSAL
PROPANE TANKS. ARE IS THEY ARE
PROMOTING THE USE OF REFILLABLE
TANK SO WHEN YOU GO TO THESE
NASH ASSEMBLY NATIONAL PARKS.
YOU CAN ONLY PURCHASE A
REFILLABLE PROPANE TANK AT THE
PARK OF BANNING THE SALE THE
PROPANE DISPOSABLE TANKS ARE
WILL MOVE CONSUMERS TO MORE
SUSTAINABILITY OPTION. FROM A
WICKS PERSPECTIVE THIS BILL
PROVIDES ACTUAL SOURCE
REDUCTIONS. AND THEN FROM A
FINANCE PERSPECTIVE THE BILL
WILL SAVE LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL MONEY GOVERNMENT MONEY.
BECAUSE THEY WON'T HAVE TO SPEND
MILLIONS DISPOSABLE CONTAIN AND
- DISPOSING CONTAIN THESE. OF
WASTE. UP IN THE WASTE. AS A
CENTERS STATED WE DIDN'T WITH
THE WERE. LAW WEEK AND WE'RE
OPEN TO HAVING A COME. OF WHAT
EPR PROGRAM TO LOOK FOR THE FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AN
ADULT CLUB HERE WITH A
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS YOUR SHIP
COUNSELORS HERE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. TRADE YEAH
THAT KNOWS ABOUT THE PEER
PROGRAMS OKAY. GOOD EXCELLENT I
THANK YOU HOW ABOUT ANYONE ELSE
WANTS TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. YES OPPOSITION YEAH ME TOO
YEAH THE KOREAN REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT AWESOME THANK YOU. HI
OKAY- PHONE LINES SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL THIS IS A THIS IS SB
TWELVE FIFTY SIX- PUBLIC ON THE
PHONE. FOR THE FIRST. ONE ZERO
FIVE. AFTER. THE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF
OF RETHINK WASTE IN SUPPORT.
NEXT ONE ONE NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN
ONE ONE ONE FIVE IT'S GOING TO.
BY MICHAEL RATIGAN WILL BE AFTER
THAT BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WE HAVE TO WORK GIVING MY
NUMBERS TO ONE MOMENT STRUCTURE
. AB ONE NUMBER FIFTY SIX GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
pABOUT BUT THEY'RE PRAYING MY
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC
SERVICES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
UNLESS WE ALIGN ONE OH GROUP IS
GOING. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHANGE ALTER ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN PLASTER WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY NATIONAL
STORAGE ACTION COUNCIL AND TELL
ME TO STOP WASTE THANK YOU. AND
THE SECURITY WAS CLEAR THANK YOU
OKAY I HAVE I SEE MAKES BEEN
WAITING HERE ALL MORNING TO
VOICE OPPOSITION CONCERNS. YOU
MAY PROCEED OKAY I THINK YOU
MICROBES HERE ON BEHALF OF
WORTHINGTON INDUSTRIES AND-
APPRECIATE CENTER WHITE HOUSE
NEEDS- IT OPENING- AND- OF
COURSE I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED
THOUGH BECAUSE THE IF WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO A BILL TO DEAL
WITH THE PR YOU KNOW ALL THE ALL
THE SUPPORTERS IN THE SPONSOR
TESTIFY ON A BILL TO BAN. SO I
DON'T KNOW IF I'M TESTIFYING ON
A BILL TO BAN OR IF I'M
TESTIFYING ABOUT WORKING ON ANY
PR BILL I WOULD MAKE A
SUGGESTIN TO THE COMMITTEE. AND
KINDA JUST FOLLOW CENTER I CAST
HE'S LEAD FROM EARLIER THIS
MORNING AND REALLY JUST DON'T
VOTE ON THIS BILL TODAY YOU
DON'T HAVE TO VOTE ON IT IF YOU
WANT TO GO TO AN EPR BILL. JUST
GOT THESE BILLS BUT IT'S LIKE
THREE SENTENCES TAKE THE PAN OUT
OF THE BILL AND SAY WE'RE GONNA
DO OF A DE PR VILLE HE DOESN'T
HAVE TO GO TO JUDICIARY THEN.
ONLY GONNA JUDICIARY TO DEAL
WITH THE CIVIL PENALTY FOR IN
THE CURRENT BAND BILL IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO HAVE A BAND BILL
DON'T HAVE A BAND BILL MAKING
ANY PR BILL TODAY REFER BACK
YOURSELF. IN HERE IN TWO WEEKS
AND ACTUALLY LISTEN VOTE ON
ACTUALLY P. R. BILL IF THAT'S
THE GOAL IF IT'S NOT THE GOAL I
COULD TESTIFY IN A BAND BILL.
AND IN TALK ABOUT WHY IT'S NOT
RIGHT BUT I KIND OF IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME. JUST TELL ME
WHICH WAY I SHOULD GO. THANK
YOU. I WILL. WE WILL WE WILL.
I'M RATHER ENJOY. THIS AND- THAT
LIVE IN. SENATE YOU WHENEVER.
THAT. OKAY ON THE BOTTLE IS
STILL BIT MORE. THAN THAN AND-
IS THE MY TEST WHAT WOULD BE THE
RECEPTACLES AND WE'RE WITH WERE
THAT BE SET UP WHAT WOULD THAT
PROCESS WOULD BE OTHER THAN
GIVING AUTHORITY. TO THE FIFTH
FIFTH PRODUCERS- YOU KNOW I'M
INTRIGUED BY IT I THINK IT
SOUNDS LIKE- THE RIGHT EVENT BUT
I WASN'T WILLING TO MAKE THE
DECISION. AND TO GET THE BILL.
THIS OVER THE WEEKEND- YOU KNOW
I. I SHARE THE ENTHUSIASM OF THE
EPR BELL- AND I'VE MET WITH MY-
THE SPONSORS AND THEIR- WILLING
TO SIT DOWN WORTHINGTON FIND OUT
EXACTLY WHAT THE DETAILS WE CAN
MODIFY THEM SO YEAH I WOULD MIKE
MY PREFERENCE WOULD BE. TO MOVE
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT I
WILL COME BACK TO IT- THE
COMMITTEE INTERFERE WITH AND
WORK WITH DIGNITY AND WITH
INCREDIBLE RESPECT YOUR CLIENT
HIRED YOU ON THURSDAY NO I. NO
AND YOU'RE A I'M NOT SAYING THAT
YOUR ARGUMENTS AREN'T THAT DON'T
DON'T HOW ARE YOU KNOW DON'T
DON'T HAVE SOME VALIDITY AYE I
GUESS ON MY THOUGHT HERE AND
CERTAINLY IF THE COMMITTEE
DISAGREES WE CAN GO A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION BUT MY THOUGHT HERE IS
THAT WE- MOVE FOR WITH THE BILL.
BUT IT'S A V. AS THE VEHICLE FOR
CONTINUED NEGOTIATIONS- AND IF
IT IS DRAMATICALLY CHANGE WE CAN
ALWAYS BRING IT BACK BUT- BUT
BUT ULTIMATELY. HE'S HE'S TRYING
TO ADDRESS OF. OF A PHENOMENON.
AT WELL A LOT. OF I CAN TESTIFY
AT THE BAN THEN I MEAN IT IT IT
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S A
PHENOMENON I THINK NOW SAYS.
RIGHTLY FRAME SYSTEM THAT IT'S
OF. IT'S POSSIBLY A PROBLEMATIC
WASTE- YOU KNOW WASTE PRODUCTS.
PRODUCT IN IN WHEN HE ENTERS THE
WASTE STREAM. I THINK IT'S BEEN
MANAGED PRETTY WELL TODAY TO BE
HONEST- I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S ANY SOLID EVIDENCE THAT
IT AT. THAT THAT ONE POUND
SOLDIERS BECAUSE BUYERS MEAN.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT PROPANE
CYLINDERS MAYBE THE TWENTY
POUNDERS ME THEY CAUSE FIRES.
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER AEROSOL
CANS A LOT OF A LOT OF. OTHER
CYLINDERS I SHOULD. I SEEN.
BROKEN YOU. AND THERE'S- THINGS
THAT ARE IN THE WASTE STREAM
THAT CAN BE PUNCTURED AND CAUSE
FIRES BUT- AND WE CAN DEAL WITH
ALL THOSE IN THE PR BUT WHAT I
CAN SAY FOR WORTHINGTON'S AT
WORTHINGTON. IS ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN THE STORESHIP
PROGRAM IN ONTARIO CANADA THAT I
KNOW YOU BOTH HAVE SEEN OR
YOU'VE BEEN UP THERE AT LEAST I
AM. AND THEY ARE THAT THEY ARE
THEY ARE- THERE'S A- BILL IN THE
CONNECTICUT LEGISLATURE THAT'S
RUNNING THROUGH. THEY'VE BEEN
ACTIVELY SUPPORTING THAT'S GOING
THROUGH WITH ALL THE STORESHIP
PEOPLE AND ALL THE- AND THEY
SPEND A LOT OF TIME A LOT OF
EXPERTS THEY HAVE. THEY HAVE.
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IS AN EXPERT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT THEY
DIDN'T RUN. THIS BILL IS A
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP BILL THEY
RAN A VAN. INTO IF THEY WERE IF
THEY WERE SERIOUS ABOUT. PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP THEY WOULD'VE WOULD
REACHED OUT TO WORTHINGTON WHO
IS THE INDUSTRY LEADER IN THIS
SPACE. I WOULD HAVE SAID HEY. WE
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU ONE
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP INSTANTLY
THROUGH NOT BEING AND THEY THEY-
GET REALLY QUESTION. WHAT THE
REAL MOTIVATION BY THEIR OWN
SERVICES. THEY DIDN'T COME WITH
PRODUCTS YOU SHOULD BEGIN WITH
THE BEAR. THANKS TO GAIN MARKET
SHARE FOR SOMEBODY. AND SO WE-
THINK ABOUT THAT OKAY. LET'S
LET'S CONTINUE WITH THE
TESTIMONY BUT WE'RE GONNA ASK
THE SENATOR DIRECTLY RESPOND TO
THAT THAT ISSUE- SO ANYONE ELSE
WANTS TO WHAT WAS CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL WHO ARE HERE PRESENT
ANYONE. ON THE PHONE LINES YOU
WANT TO VOICE THE CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE BILL'S SB TWELVE FIFTY
SIX. HE WAS ARTICLE PUBLISHED
FOR THE- FROM. ONE ZERO. THE
STRUCTURE WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY GREAT ALL RIGHT SO LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WHAT WHAT'S ASK THE SENATOR-
FIRST OF ALL TO DIRECTLY RESPOND
TO THE CONCERNS AND I WILL GO TO
SENATE ALTHOUGH EIGHT MEAN THAT
THAT THAT THE SIMPLE ANSWERS
SEVENTY. ON THE- IN THE MARKET
RIGHT NOW ARE THESE REFILLABLE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND
THEY'RE- THEY'RE BEING USED IN.
THEIR ADOPTING SO WE THOUGHT
THAT THE ALTERNATIVE. THE
PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE WOULD BE
TO MOVE TO A WHOLE. HAVE
WORTHINGTON CHANGE THEIR PRODUCT
LINE AND HAVE THE RICH REFILL
PULLS- PRODUCTS IN AND- NOT
WORRY ABOUT THAT THE COST OF-
THAT. HITS MUNICIPALITIES OR
PEOPLE THAT JUST DON'T-
PARTICIPATE IN THE AND APR
PROGRAM IS THE ONLY PR FIRMS IN
A PERFECT SO THAT WAS THAT WAS
THINKING FREDDIE I MEAN DO YOU
DO YOU ULTIMATELY ENVISION THIS
AS ANY PR BILL. YEAH I MEAN I
THINK IF IT'S AGAIN WE WILL HAVE
TO SIT BACK WITH THE PEOPLE SO
WHY DID YOU INITIALLY PROPOSED
AS A BAND AS OPPOSED IN PURE AND
SPIRIT YES. I MEAN SPIRIT YES IT
SOUNDS IT SOUNDS GOOD I HAVEN'T
SAT DOWN WITH THE RENEWABLE
ADDICTS OF REFILLABLE PEOPLE AND
SEE WHAT THEY THINK ABOUT THAT
THAT- STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM. HI
HELP BOTH OF THOSE WITH YOU
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SOME THAT ARE
ALREADY USING REPORT FILLABLE
HOW WOULD THEY FIT INTO THAT AND
HOW WOULD PEOPLE BE CONFUSED OF
SAYING I'M GONNA DROP IT INTO
THE- PROGRAM OR NOT. I DON'T
KNOW RIGHT NOW AS A SENIOR
RESEARCHER- I'M INTRIGUED BY IT
I'M- CLEAR CLEARLY- INTRIGUED BY
IT AND THINKS IT MAY GET A CITY
TO THE F. THIRTY DOLLARS. SO AS
SOMEBODY WHO. USES THESE
PRODUCTS A LOT ACTUALLY. AND YET
THAT YOU CAN GO A MEAN. I CAN
REVEAL THAT BALL RIGHT THERE FOR
IF YOU LIKE ME TO I DON'T
THERE'S A- A CONVERTER THAT YOU
CAN PUT ON YOUR PROPANE TANK
THERE WILL RECHARGE THAT. THAT
ACTUAL THING EITHER THAT'S NOT
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT SO THERE
IS THE ABILITY TO REFILL THOSE
IF YOU WANT TO SAVE MONEY THAT'S
WHY DO IT- AND THERE'S A LOT OF.
OPPORTUNITIES AFTER BUT FOR THIS
BILL. WHY DON'T WE TAKE THE TIME
AND JUST DO IT RIGHT WHAT WHAT'S
THE URGENCY TODAY. TO SHELVE
THIS THROUGH AND- AND DO A BAND
WHEN WE CAN DO IT RIGHT AND
ACTUALLY HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE.
THAT IS JUST LIKE THE- TWENTY
FIVE POUND. PROPANE TANK THAT
YOU USE ON YOUR R. V. THAT YOU
GO YOU CAN GO TO. WALMART OR
WHEREVER YOU CAN JUST EXCHANGE
IT. AND IT'S FILLED AND IT'S
THERE'S NO PROBLEM WHY DON'T WE
DO IT THE RIGHT WAY INSTEAD OF
JUST. CAUSING ALL THIS AND I
KNOW THAT WE CAN WE WEEK FOR
SOME REASON. THE LEGISLATURE. IS
WORRIED ABOUT. OR THE
LEGISLATORS WORRY ABOUT THEIR
SEVENTEEN BILLS ON THE FILE AND
WHAT THAT'S OUR JOB IS TO. TAKE
THE TIME AND DO STUFF RIGHT WE
DON'T EVER DO THAT AROUND WHAT
WE DO IS WE TO SHOP STEP
THROUGH. BECAUSE TODAY WE GOT TO
GET IT DONE FOR SOME WHATEVER
REASON. AND IT'S NOT FAIR TO.
THE MANUFACTURERS NOT FAIR TO
THE IN CONSUMER WHO DRIVES THE
PRICE OF ALL THESE THINGS UP SO
I WOULD ASK. THAT YOU. ALL THE
BILL TODAY. AND GO BACK AND FIX
THE BILL WE HAVE TIME TO DO IT.
AND MAKE A GOOD BILL SO WE CAN
ALL OF A SUPPORT IT AND DO
SOMETHING GOOD FOR CALIFORNIANS.
AND THE ENVIRONMENT THE SAME
TIME. MISTER CHAIR. I FIVE. I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH
THAT. THAT ALTERNATIVE I MEAN
I'M- YOU KNOW I BROUGHT THIS
BILL FOR BECAUSE I WAS CONCERNED
WITH- CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
RIGHT AND I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THE THAT THESE PRODUCTS
ARE. DEALT WITH IN
ENVIRONMENTALLY PROPER WAY. THE
BAND DOES DO THAT. I'M JUST. THE
QUESTION IS THAT THE IS THE EPR
ALTERNATIVE. MEET THE SAME GOALS
THAT WE HAVE AND I'M- YOU KNOW I
THINK IT DOES. BUT DO I KNOW FOR
SURE FOR SURE THAT I HAVEN'T.
YOU KNOW THAT SOME OF THE OTHER
ADVOCATES WILL SAY WELL WE
PREFERRED THAT. AND THEN IT'S A
DECISION THAT I HAVE TO MAKE IS
THE AUTHOR. RIGHT IN THIS
WILDERNESS CALLED ME. TO SEVENTY
TWO HOURS AGO WITH THIS
ALTERNATIVE. THAT THE DEBT YOU
KNOW IT'S GREAT IT'S GREAT THE
COOPERATION BUT- I DON'T THINK
THAT AUTHORS. HAVE TO PIVOT IN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS. AND SAY OH
LET'S GO THIS WAY. NORMALLY THE
ANALYSIS WAS ALREADY DONE. THEN
CALL IT FOR WHAT IT IS IT'S A
BAND IT'S NOT A FIX FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S WHAT YOU
NEED. WE NEED TO DO IS BE HONEST
ABOUT WHAT IS THE BILL DO IT
BANS. SINGLE USE. TWO POUND.
THEN CALLED IT IS IN RUN YOUR-
THIS IS THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
PLACE RIGHT HERE. IS THAT WE
DON'T DO GOOD WORK ON OUR BILLS
BUT WE JUST SHUFFLING THROUGH
BECAUSE- PROBABLY BEHIND IT IS
SOME. ONE MANUFACTURER THAT'S
GOING TO PROFIT FROM IT THAT'S
THE REAL GOAL. WELL THAT'S-
THAT'S NOT HER REAL GOAL AND IT
IN THE IN. IN THE- IN THIS BODY
OR IN THIS FIELD WE'RE TRYING TO
REDUCE SEIZE ONE USE OPTIONS
THIS IS YOU KNOW REGARDLESS OF
WHAT YOU DO THIS LABEL SAYS DO
NOT REFILL THIS IS USE IT ONCE
AND THROW IT AWAY. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE CAME HERE FOR THAT'S
WHAT THE STAFF ANALYSIS HAS DONE
THAT WAS PRETTY PREPARED FOR US.
AND I WILL CLOSE AN **** AND
URGENT HI FOLKS. IF IT DOESN'T
GET OUT THEN I WILL OBVIOUSLY
WE- WILL WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
TO A- TO IMPROVE IT. OKAY I MEAN
I'M I'M I'M GONNA SUPPORT YOU
MISTER MISTER AT TERMINUS BUT I
GUESS I GUESS IT AND ANYONE
ENGINE BE FAIRLY I MEAN MAKES
DOING ITS JOB BUT- YOU KNOW THIS
IS A- IS A- COMPANY THAT'S
LISTED ON THE NYSE IN EITHER
SOPHISTICATED FOLKS THIS BILLS
AND- I'M OUT THERE FOR IT FOR
SOME TIME THE ONLY JUST CAME IN-
AND I DO SYMPATHIZE WITH THE
AUTHOR- YOU KNOW. WE INCOMES
OPPOSITION VERY LATE- AND HE'S
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO HOW
TO PROCEED I GUESS WHAT I WOULD
ASK IF YOU KNOW YOU ARE LOOKING
TO MAKE A MAJOR CHANGE WE WOULD
WANT TO. NOT ONLY WE WOULD
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO PLAY A BIG
ROLE IN HELPING TO WORK WITH
YOUR STAFF AS YOU'VE DEVISED THE
BILL BUT I ALSO ASK THAT YOU.
REACH OUT TO AND CONSULT WITH
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- WE
CAN ALWAYS OF COURSE BRING IT
BACK UP I THOUGHT I THOUGHT I
SAID IN MY OPENING COMMENTS I
WOULD BE FREE TO TALK TO.
EVERYBODY HERE THE QUESTION IS
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE LIMITATIONS
BECAUSE OF THE COVR PROTOCOLS WE
HAVE IS THAT IF I DON'T MOVE IT
TO JUDICIARY AND WE DECIDED NO
WE WANT TO KEEP IT AS A BAND. WE
DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO BACK TO
THE SECOND COMING RIGHT RESEARCH
AND I'M IN MY AND MY ONE PUSHED
BACK SENATE DOLLY IS IF YOU IF
WE WERE TO. OPERATE IN A WAY
WHERE OPPOSITION TO COME IN VERY
LATE AND BRING A BRAND NEW IDEAS
REALLY IN THE BILLS. AND THAT
WOULD DELAY EVERY BILL THE PLACE
TO BREAK DOWN EVERY EVERY- EVERY
OPPOSITION GROUP WILL BE DEBT
WILL BE USING THAT. WOULD BE
UTILIZING THAT- THAT TECHNIQUE
YOU ONCE AGAIN THIS IS NO
DISRESPECT TO THE- TO THE.
ADVOCATE HERE WELL I GUESS IF
YOU'RE- OF BRIGHT PARTY I GET. I
GET. OFF AS- DAVE. MY BILL COMES
IN AND GETS KILLED SO. I THINK
IT'S- I THINK IT'S LEGIT THEY'RE
USING OPPOSITION WHATEVER YOU'D
OPPOSITION. THE IDEA IS TO DO
LIKE OUR JOB THAT'S WHAT MY
POINT WAS. AND IF THE FATHER
DOESN'T WANT TO DO IT FINE YES
YES NO RUN A BAND. ALL OF THIS.
HER CHEN AYE VOTE. YEAH I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY THE PARTY DATE IT'S
RUNNING THE SHOW KIND OF AGREES
WITH EACH OTHER ABOUT POLICY
ISSUES AND YEAH SO THE FOLKS WHO
VOTED FOR SO I MEAN THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE ANYWAY I WITHOUT AYE
AYE AYE- AYE A VOTE I AND- YEAH
SENATE ALWAYS POINTS ARE WELL
TAKEN. A SEARCH OF HIS KALRA. I
DON'T NUMBER FIFTEEN SB TWELVE
FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR Y. CASKEY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY ALAN HI. ALAN I BATES.
DOLLY DALY NO GONZALEZ. AND
SALAS I SKINNER. KERN HI STERN I
Y. CASKEY HI I. CASKEY I. OKAY
THANK YOU LET'S THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA PASSED
THE GAVEL TO. CENTER WITH CASKEY
- I THINK
-
THE- FIRST STEP IS THE SB.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN. FOR CENTER
ALLEN THIS IS THE STATE REGIONAL
COLLABORATIVES FOR CLIMATE
EQUITY AND RESILIENCE. I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IT IS
MEMBERS ACCORDING TO A CAR BUT
THE STATE WILL NOT ACHIEVE ITS
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS.
UNANSWERED TO MEET THE MANDATES
FOR TWENTY THIRTY AND BEYOND
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT YOU JUST HOW
COMMUNITIES AND TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS ARE PLANNED FUNDED AND
BUILT. I AM FOLKS MAY REMEMBER
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR APPROVED SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE THAT WAS SENT
HER- STEINBERG SPELL THAT
REQUIRED CARP TO SET ADDITIONAL-
THIS IS A REGIONAL JET SHE
REDUCTION TARGETS FOR ALL OF OUR
NPOS MATCH ONE PLANNING.
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE THEY
CREATE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY STRATEGIES WITHIN
THEIR TRANSPORTATION PLAN THAT
ARTICULATES TACTICS FOR REDUCING
EMISSIONS THROUGH CHANGES IN
LAND USE HOUSING TRANSPORTATION
PATTERNS BUT OF COURSE YOU SEE
THAT EMISSIONS ARE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR CONTINUE
TO RISE DESPITE INCREASES IN
FUEL EFFICIENCY DECREASES. IN
THE CARBON CONTENT OF FUEL CELL
AT THE NPOS HAVE DEVOTE DEVELOPS
INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES BUT
THEY'RE PLANNING DOCUMENTS ALONE
OR NOT CHANGING DEVELOPMENT
LOCAL LEVELS. THIS SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. I YOU KNOW
IT HAS T. GO FIRST EXPLORING. IF
AND HOW WE CAN SIMPLIFY THIS S.
YES DEVELOPMENT APPROVAL PROCESS
IMPROVING ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE
STATE REGIONAL AND LOCAL LEVELS.
AND ADDRESSING THE DID THE CLEAR
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE LOCAL
DECISIONS KEEPING REGIONAL
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT AT THE
STATE GOALS RELATED TO HEALTH.
HOUSING CLIMATE EQUITY THE
ENVIRONMENT ECONOMY. THE BILL'S
WORK IN PROGRESS WE'VE CONVENE.
STAKEHOLDERS IN AN EFFORT TO
FIND SOLUTIONS TO IMPROVE THIS
PROGRAM I'M CERTAINLY GRATEFUL
TO MANY FOLKS HAVE TO DEDICATE A
LOT OF TIME TO THIS PROCESS
INCLUDING MY- STAFF- THEY'VE
THEY'VE COME TO WITH CREATIVITY
AND OPENNESS THERE'S A- VERY
INTENSE STICKLE IN APPRECIATION
PROCESS THE TEAM IS A PART OF-
BUT- THIS IS WHAT'S GONNA TAKE
TO MAKE PROGRESS IN THESE
SECTORS I'M I'M CERTAINLY
HOPEFUL WE CAN GET SOMETHING
DONE. ON THESE ARE MEDIA ISSUES
THAT YOU TAKE TIME THE TECHNICAL
ISSUES AND- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. FOR GOOD I
DON'T SEE ANY FORMAL WITNESSES
IS THERE ANYBODY. HERE IN ROOM.
THIS IS TWENTY ONE. HUNDRED
BERMAN HEARD LIKE TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTEEN NOT MODERATOR LET'S GO
TO LINES DO YOU HAVE ANYBODY
ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF. SB TWELVE
SEVENTEEN. THE COMMON IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE SEVENTEEN PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE MOMENT
HERE WE WILL HAVE A COUPLE FEET
UP SHORTLY. WE'RE GOING OFFLINE
NUMBER NINETY ONE NINETY TWO IS
GOING ON. NINETY ONE NINETY ONE
NINETEEN NINETY RELIABLE. THE
TERM MEMBERS DON'T LUGGED YOU
GREEN BUILDING IN LOS LEAD INS.
THANK YOU NEXT. THANKS IS LINE
SIXTY THREE THINGS GOING ON. ONE
SIXTY THREE. SIX YES IT IS
NICORETTE YES THIS IS NICK BROKE
. IT IN THE GROUND UP IN BEHALF
OF THREE FIFTY BAY AREA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY THREE IS GONNA. HELLO MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE- FERRARI
HAVE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE'RE WE'RE
ACTUALLY IN THE TWEENER POSITION
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION RIGHT
NOW BUT- DO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
COMMENTS OF THE SENATOR ABOUT
THE ROBUST STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
AND ALL THAT GOOD WORK THAT'S
GOING ON SO. FORTH BEING PART OF
THAT- HOPING HE CAN LAND THIS
THING THANK YOU. NEXT NEXT IS
LINE ONE SEVENTEEN ONE ONE ONE
SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. AND
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ROGER DICKINSON ON
BEHALF OF CIVIC WELL PREVIOUSLY
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
AND WARRANT SUPPORT IN CONCERT
ON THE BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR AND
STAFF AND OTHER MEMBERS. TO GET
A GOOD PRODUCT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT. MAX IS ONE NUMBER
SIXTEEN NINE SIXTY NINE ONE OF
THESE. AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. NEXT ONE
ONE SIXTEEN GONNA. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND I THINK
CHRISTIANITY'S RAPID LEARNING
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS WHAT
THAT DOES NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE CLOTHES AND THE
KING AT THE MOMENT WE WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR SINCERE THANKS TO
SENATOR ALLEN FOR HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION SCALP RELIEF THAT
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING THE
REGION'S ATTAINABLE COMMITTEE
TAIJI SB THREE GP GREENHOUSE
GAS. REDUCTION THAT WE NEED AND
WANT IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR THAT COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH YOU YOUR EXCELLENT STAFF
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN
IMPROVING THE ACTUALLY SEVENTY
THREE SEVENTY FIVE PROCESS AND
EXPEDITING IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PLAN THANK YOU THANK. YOU NEXT.
MISTER WAS QUICKER ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN TOP. I DON'T HAVE. OF
FORMAL WHAT AND- BETTER
OPPOSITION IS IN A HERE AND ROOM
TO ONE HOW. THAT THIS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION THEN LET'S
GO TO THE SICK THESE THIS IS
OPPOSITE TO S. B. R. TWELVE
SEVENTEEN GO AHEAD MODERATOR. ON
THE PHONE TROUBLES PRESS ONE
ZERO PLEASE. MISTER SHARE WITH
NO ONE IN QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION
ALL RIGHT LET'S SUB CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENT BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS IS THERE ANY QUESTIONS THAT
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE.
OF A CENTER OUR- THERE'S A
MOTION AND THIS WILL BE A MOTION
TO PASS. WE'LL TALK. TO C.
RECOGNIZE CENTER DALIO. SO I
JUST WAS READING THE BILL AND
THERE'S TEN GROUPS AND THERE'S I
DON'T SEE BUILDERS ACTUALLY LIKE
CBA OR SOMEBODY THAT WOULD BE
REPRESENT WAS HAVE A
CONVERSATION GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND OUT OF
THANK YOU CENTER SO IF YOU GO TO
IF YOU GO TO THE FINAL PAGE OF
THE BILL YOU'LL NOTICE THAT
THERE'S DIFFERENT GROUPS WILL BE
APPOINTED TO THIS COLLABORATIVE-
IN IN THE BUILDINGS ARE UNDER
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND CIA IS AT THE
TABLE WITH US NEGOTIATION WE
COULD CERTAINLY. WORK ON THIS
LANGUAGE AT ANOTHER LINE IF YOU
WANT TO BE MORE SPECIFIC- BUT
THEY ARE VERY MUCH OF THE TABLE
AND I JUST INVITE ANYONE TO
REACH OUT TO CASSIE- OR ANY OF
YOUR COLLEAGUES OR FRIENDS AT
CBI- BUT THEY ARE AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF OUR- OF OUR TO GO HERE
AND THERE TECH WHICH I
ABSOLUTELY SENATORS IN BOTH.
THAT'S BECAUSE WE JUST MADE WE
WOULD HAVE PRIVATELY ABOUT THE
FOLKS ARE ACTUALLY DOING THE
BUILDING TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION. THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL. ARTIST THIS IS. WITH. THREE B. L. ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX YEP AND SEVEN WILL BE
THE A HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS ALL RIGHT. SEE NO
OTHER QUESTIONS- YOU MAY CLOSE
YEAH. RESEARCHERS HAVE A- PLEASE
CALL THE LAW. I THE NUMBER
SIXTEEN S. B. TWELVE SEVENTEEN
BY SENATOR ALAN THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION ALLEN AYE ALLEN
AYE BATES. DOLLY DALY NOT VOTING
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ FIVE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN HI MY
COUNTY HI KELSEY I'D- I WE HAVE-
ONE FIVE FOLKS IF YOU'RE
SPEEDING UP FOR KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
LET'S MOVE TO THE LAST ITEM ON
OUR CALENDAR S. B. TWELVE THIRTY
TWO WHICH IS SOLID WASTE.
PRODUCT'S LABELING BIODEGRADABLE
BILITY CENTER GO AHEAD WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD A NUMBER OF BILLS
ON THE ON THE PLANT AND WASTE
ISSUES I'M ALREADY EVEN THIS
MORNING AND FOLKS KNOW THAT I'VE
BEEN. WORKING ON THIS- AS WELL
I'M- WE KNOW THAT IT'S
HEARTENING STATISTICS RIGHT
HUMANS HAVE CREATED EIGHT POINT
THREE BILLION TONS OF PLASTIC IN
THE WORLD TODAY IT'S THE
EQUIVALENT OF FIFTY FIVE MILLION
JUMBO JETS. I ROUGHLY EIGHT
MILLION METRIC TONS OF THIS
WASTE ENDS UP IN OUR OCEANS EACH
YEAR LESS THAN TEN PERCENT. OF
PLASTIC PRODUCED EACH YEAR IS
RECYCLED. IN MOST CASES THE
MATERIAL THAT IS RECYCLED
ACTUALLY DOWN CYCLE SO IT ENDS
UP IN A LESS. HIGHER USE. I WALK
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE MORE TO
PROMOTE THE RECYCLABILITY OF
SINGLE USE PLASTICS IN RECENT
YEARS WE KNOW THE RECYCLING IS.
NOT A CURE ALL NOT ONLY IS
STRICTLY WITH IN SCOPE WITH WITH
ONE AND FOR OF THE MOST RECYCLED
ITEMS. WATER BOTTLES OF MANY OF
US HAVE. AND SO MANY OF THESE
ARE STILL IN JUST OF THE- OF THE
HI- SO I. WE DO NEED TO PUSH. TO
ENSURE THAT NOT. USING FOR A
PACK. WHICH DESTINED FOR THE
LANDFILL WE ALSO NEED TO OTHER
OPTIONS WELL. SO WE USE AND
REFILL. AS PERHAPS OF THE CAN. I
BECOMING MORE POPULAR IN ITS THE
BEST APPROACH FOR MANY- STAR FOR
EXAMPLE. I JUST ANNOUNCE A MOVE
TO REUSABLE CUPS WHICH IS VERY
EXCITING AND BY SHIFTING ALL
SINGLE USE ITEMS TO REVIEW WOULD
BE- YOU THAT THAT THAT REALLY
WOULD BE A CHALLENGE- BUT I
TRANSITION TO WERE USED TO
REFILL- AS- YOU KNOW WE KNOW IS
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN. OVERNIGHT
SO THIS BILL TAKES A LONGER VIEW
OF THE PLASTICS CRISIS AND
BEGINS TO CONTEMPLATE HOW TO
MOVE TOWARDS. RENEWABLE
SUSTAINABLE ALTERNATIVES FOR
SINGLE USE ITEMS THE BILL SEEKS
TO SET A STANDARD. FOR MATERIAL
THAT CAN TRULY BREAK DOWN IN THE
ENVIRONMENT FULLY AND QUICKLY AS
OPPOSED TO FAMILY PERSISTENT
FOSSIL FUEL BASED PLASTICS. THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT INNOVATIVE
COMPANIES WORKING ON
ALTERNATIVES TO SYNTHETIC.
PLASTIC PRODUCTS ARE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE THEIR BENEFITS
DIRECTLY TO ENVIRONMENTALLY
MINDED CALIFORNIANS WHO WON AND
OR IS IT RELIANCE ON SINGLE USE
ITEMS THAT ARE. USED FOR JUST
MINUTES BUT THEY LOST HUNDREDS
IF NOT THOUSANDS OF YEARS ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT NOT TO MENTION THE
FACT THAT THESE ITMS ARE
PRODUCTS. OF THE FOSSIL FUELS
INDUSTRY IN THE THEIR PAYER NOT
CONTRIBUTING TO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND THEIR PRODUCTION.
TO THE BILL- IS ONCE AGAIN A
WORK IN PROGRESS THERE'S NO
STANDARD THAT WE CAN SIMPLY
POINT TO. THAT WOULD ALLOW
PRODUCERS TO ADVERTISE THEIR
PRODUCT AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
SYNTHETIC PLASTIC. I IN FACT OUR
VERNACULAR HIGHS NOT EVEN MATURE
ENOUGH TO DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
FOSSIL FUEL BASED. EVER
PERSISTENT PLASTIC AND OTHER
RENEWABLE MATERIAL TYPES AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT. IF YOU
ANYONE SINCE OUR VOLLEYBALL
ABOUT PALMER FOLKS IN THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE WORKING IN
THAT SPACE. THE BILL. TALK YOUR
EAR OFF ABOUT THAT. SO WE CAN
SIMPLY RELY ON A COMPOSED. STAY
FOR- FOR A FEW REASONS FOR ALL
SUMMIT. ARE ARE- TECH. AND
COMPOSTABLE. BUT THEY DID BIG
THEY JUST COULDN'T MEET A HOME
COMPOSTING. FOR BIODEGRADABLE
STANDARD. IN FACT A MATERIAL
THAT IS HOME COMPOSTABLE MAY NOT
EVEN NEED TO STAND FOR
SOMETHING. THE MOST BREAKDOWN IN
MARINE ENVIRONMENTS- SO YOU KNOW
I'M I'M BIG GIVE YOU GIVE YOU
RIGHT AROUND YOURSELF AND
THERE'S CERTAIN PRODUCTS THAT
MAY BE TECHNICALLY COMPOSABLE
YOU'D NEVER LEAVE. ON YOUR ON
YOUR- ON YOUR RANCH OUT THERE. I
STRUGGLE THIS MYSELF WHEN I'M
LOOKING AT MY ITEMS WHICH I PUT
IN THE GREEN BIN WHAT I WHAT I
USE IN OUR OWN HOME COMPOSTING.
WHAT I THROW IN THE TRASH WHEN I
PUT RECYCLING SENATORS
INCREDIBLY CONFUSING SO WE'RE-
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO GET THIS RIGHT.
THIS MEANS GETTING STANDARD
RIGHT ALSO MEANS ENSURING THAT
PROPER LABELING. SO THE
CONSUMERS KNOW HOW THIS MATERIAL
SHOULD BE HANDLED- AT THE END OF
ITS USEFUL LIFE SO WITH ME TODAY
I HAVE BEEN KOGAN FROM COVE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE LEADING
COMPANIES IN THIS SPACE IT
CALIFORNIA NEVADA COMPANIES.
IT'S WORKING IN THIS SPACE- AND-
HE WANTS TO COME IN BEFORE WE
GET TO MISTER COVANCE THAT
TESTIMONY- I WANT TO BE SURE IF
I HEARD. YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED
IN SECTION FIVE THE SIX. OF US
ACTUALLY COMMITTEE ANALYSIS YES.
ABSOLUTELY EXCELLENT. WITH THE
CODE. THEY YOU GERMAN AND OF
THIS COMMITTEE. I'M COOKING WITH
CO WITH. A WATER BOTTLE MADE FOR
NATURAL MATERIALS PH. WHICH IS
FILED WITH AND EVERY NOT OF OUR
WHERE SPONSOR OF SB FOUR. TO
THERE'S A FLOATER GARBAGE PATCH
FOR LARGER THE STATE. OFF COAST
DEPENDENT AS COUNTRY TO STAND
INCREASE IMPLY. LITTER WELL LAST
WEEK EIGHTY PER OF INTO THE
SAMPLE TO THE STUDY WERE TO
HAVE. T. PAY. POLICY OF.
CIRCULATE IN THEIR BLOOD.
INDIVIDUALS ARE SOMETIMES BLAME
FOR THIS MESS BUT THEY DID NOT
DESIGNED NOR MANUFACTURER SINGLE
USE PRODUCTS KNOWING THAT THEY
ARE INDESTRUCTIBLE. NEARLY HALF
THE PLASTIC WE PRODUCE A SINGLE
USE. MEANWHILE RECYCLING
STRUGGLES TO KEEP UP. IMAGINE
THEY SET OUT TO REPLACE THESE
PRODUCTS WITH SOMETHING BETTER
SOMETHING NATURAL THAT WOULD
LEAVE AN INDELIBLE MARK ON OUR
PLANET. IMAGINE THEY DIVE DEEP
INTO THE SCIENTIFIC LITERATURE-
AND REALIZE THAT THERE A LARGE
NUMBER OF NATIONAL HEROES THEY
CAN BE HARNESSED. TO REPLACE
PLASTIC CELLULOSE CHITIN PUBLIC
ADDRESS THE- CANDIDATES OR PJ
FOR SHORT. AND OTHERS. IMAGINE
THAT YOU FIND THE SCIENTIFIC
LITERATURE ON THESE NATIONAL
MATERIAL STRETCHES BACK MANY
DECADES THAT THEY ARE TO USE THE
WORDS OF REPORT PUBLISHED BY CAL
RECYCLE. QUOTE EXCELLENT
MATERIALS FOR PASSING
APPLICATIONS THAT THEY ARE
BIODEGRADABLE BOTH HOT
INDUSTRIAL COMPOSTING CALLED
MARINE ENVIRONMENTS. AS WELL AS
IN OTHER ARABIC OR ANAEROBIC
ENVIRONMENTS UNDER HOT OR COLD
TEMPERATURES. THEY ARE SO
BIODEGRADABLE THE MARINE
BIODEGRADABLE EXTENDS THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST USE THESE
MATERIALS AS POSITIVE CONTROLS.
FOR LABORATORY AND FIELD TESTS.
IMAGINE THAT. PUTTING WILL TEAM
OF. IN CALIFORNIA FUNDED BY
FORWARD LOOKING INVESTORS WANT
TO SEE BETTER LESS POLLUTED
WORLD. TO LEARN HOW TO PROCESS
THE NATURAL MATERIALS INTO
FINISHED GOODS SO WE CAN START
TO UNDO THE HARM CAUSED BY
PLASTICS. IMAGINE THAT YOU
MANUFACTURE THESE MATERIALS BY
USING WASTE BYPRODUCTS OF
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY GREENHOUSE
GASES USED COOKING OIL. WASTE
WATER DISCARDED TRENCHES AND SO
ON AND SO FORTH. CALIFORNIA IS
HOME T SOME OF THE MOST CUTTING
EDGE INNOVATORS AND TECHNOLOGY
IN THIS SPACE. IMAGINE THAT YOU
SUCCEED IN MAKING PRODUCTS FROM
THESE NATURAL MATERIALS BOTTLES
STRAWS CUTLERY PACKAGING FROM
ETCETERA. WELL A LARGE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO WANT A MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND HEALTHY FUTURE
CLAMOR FOR ALTERNATIVES TO
PLASTIC. NOW IMAGINE BEING TOLD
IT IS ILLEGAL IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE THE MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY
FOR LOOKING STATES IN THIS
COUNTRY. FREE LABEL YOUR PRODUCT
WITH AN EXPLANATION OF BENEFITS.
IN A WAY IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THE
TERM BIODEGRADABLE HAS BEEN
MISUSED AND ABUSED BY
UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS. NONETHELESS
NOT ONLY CAN YOU NOT SAY THEIR
PRODUCT IS BIODEGRADABLE. NATURE
EVEN IF IT IS 1100% TRUE
DEMONSTRABLE AND KNOWN TO
SCIENTIFIC EXPERTS THE WORLD
OVER. SB TWELVE THIRTY TO SIXTY
CORRECT THIS. THIS BILL PROPOSES
TO ALLOW REPLACEMENT TO PLASTIC
PRODUCTS TO MARKET THEMSELVES ON
THEIR MERITS. MORE SPECIFICALLY
IT SEEKS TO ALLOW PRODUCTS TO
PROVE THAT THEY ARE
BIODEGRADABLE BY REQUIRING
SPECIFIC EVIDENCE. THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE USING NATURAL
NONTOXIC AND MARINE DEGRADABLE
MATERIALS INCLUDING ANY FILLERS
AND ADDITIVES. WE ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE EXPERTS TO
ENSURE THIS LEGISLATION LEAVES
NO LOOPHOLES. NO OPEN DOOR AND
GREENWASHING. WE ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH COMPOSTERS TO
ENSURE THAT SUCH PRODUCTS ARE
BIOLOGICALLY RECYCLED. AFTER
THEY HAVE BEEN USED AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH EVERY
OTHER STAKEHOLDER. IN CALIFORNIA
TO ENTER THIS LEGISLATION SERVE
THE PUBLIC INTEREST. BUT WE NEED
TO GET THIS DONE IT'S TIME FOR
THE LAW TO CATCH UP TO THE
SCIENCE. SB TWELVE THIRTY TWO IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
SET A GOLD STANDARD FOR THE TERM
BIODEGRADABLE. AND IN SO DOING
INCENTIVIZE THE GROWTH OF
INDUSTRIES AND INNOVATIONS THAT
ARE CRUCIAL TO ACHIEVING
CIRCULAR ECONOMY. THANK YOU
THANKS THANK YOU ARE THERE
OTHERS HERE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED IN SUPPORT OF. S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY TWO. SEEING NONE
MODERATE LET'S GO TO THE- PHONE
LINES ANYONE. IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWELVE THIRTY TWO. THE COMMON
SUPPORT OF PROPERTY TO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SIGN LOCUSTS
SURE WE GET THE FIRST COUPLE OF
IN CUBA. YEAH I'M GOING
CRYSTALLINE NUMBER FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY SIX
LINES OPEN WANNA. ONE FIFTY SIX
CHECK MAKE SURE NOT NEEDED ON
YOUR AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
YOU TO ADDRESS MANY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOING ON THE LINE NUMBER
ONE EIGHTEEN ONE ONE EIGHTEEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS
REBECCA AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY SILICON
VALLEY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY TWO WITH THE AMENDMENT
THAT THE RESPONSIBILITY SHIFTED
FROM CAL RECYCLE TO THE OFFICE
OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT TO DETERMINE IF A
PRODUCT CONTAINS INGREDIENTS
HOWEVER TO HUMAN HEALTH. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT. MOST WILL GO
TRY AGAIN FOR LINE FIFTY SIX
YOUR ONE DOUBLE AGAIN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. AFTERNOON MICHAEL
BAFFERT THE BRAND MIKKELI ON
BEHALF REPUBLIC SERVICES WHAT IT
. THANK YOU MAX. MISTER CHEROKEE
WAS CLEAR OKAY LET'S SAID TURN
TO OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE BRUCE MCCARTY. ON THE PHONE
IS THERE ANYBODY HERE. COULD
RESTRICT NINETY FIRST IS MISS
MCCARTY ON THE PHONE. MODERATOR
BRIGALOW A LOT OF OBJECT YEAH
CHECKING NOW- ONE MOMENT WE'LL
SEE. DO NOT SEE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINES AS THE HOST ONLY
LISTENERS. OKAY ARE ANYBODY HERE
IN THE TWEENER SO OKAY WANT TO
COME FORWARD. GNASHING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NICK OFFICE OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE. WE
DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL AS WRITTEN AND THAT IS
LARGELY DUE TO THE AUTHORS
COMMITMENT TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE
AND TO WORK OUT THE DETAILS. WE
WOULD HAVE CONCERNS WITH WITH-
THE STANDARDS REFERENCED IN THE
BILL BEING PUT BACK INTO
STATUTE. THEY WERE TAKEN OUT OF
STATUTE A COUPLE YEARS AGO-
BECAUSE THEY WERE WITHDRAWN FROM
ASTM AND THEY WERE WITHDRAWN
FROM ACM. BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
REPRESENT REAL WORLD CONDITIONS.
AND THIS LEGISLATURE HAS DONE A
LOT OVER THE LAST FEW DECADES TO
REALLY LEAD ON GREENWASHING.
CLAIMS AND MARK ENVIRONMENTAL
MARKETING CLAIMS. AND THIS IS
ONE OF THE AREAS WHERE
CALIFORNIA'S LIED OR WE HAVE
ADOPTED I BELIEVE A HALF DOZEN
BILLS LIMITING WHAT CAN BE
CALLED. COMPOSTABLE
BIODEGRADABLE MARINE
BIODEGRADABLE AND THE SPECIFIC
STANDARD WAS WITHDRAWN AND
LEGISLATION A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
FOR THAT REASON. I'M YOU KNOW
THIS IS NOT. THIS IS NOT EIGHT
EIGHT EASY ISSUE BECAUSE AS THE
SPONSORS I MENTIONED- THERE IS A
NEED FOR SOME- STANDARDS HERE.
THE PROBLEM IS WE'RE NOT AWARE
OF ANY STANDARDS THAT REALLY
REFLECT REAL LIFE CONDITIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WHEN CONSUMERS
SEE THAT SOMETHING'S LABELS BY
TWO GREAT OF ALL. THEY NOT ONLY
INTERPRET AS A CHARACTERISTIC OF
THE PRODUCT THEY ALSO INTERPRET
AS INSTRUCTION FOR WHAT BEEN TO
PUT THE PRODUCT IN. AND
CALIFORNIA COMPOSTERS DO NOT
ACCEPT THESE MATERIALS
CURRENTLY- BUT EVEN IF THEY DID
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ANY
STANDARD IS NARROW IN SCOPE. TO-
NOT ALLOW OTHER PRODUCTS THAT
ARE NOT PHD PRODUCTS FOR
INSTANCE- TO BE LABELED WITH
THESE TERMS. AND THEN BEYOND THE
DIRECTION CONSUMERS IT'S ALSO
MARKETING CLAIM RIGHT AT PEOPLE
CHOOSE SOMETHING BECAUSE THEY
THINK IT'S BETTER FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. IF THERE'S NO
ACTIVE STANDARD THAT YOU CAN GO
PASS OR FAIL. IT OPENS A HUGE
LOOPHOLE FOR OTHER FOLKS ALSO
USE THE SAME TERMINOLOGY. AND
NOT A AND COMPETE WITH THE FOLKS
FOR MAKING TRULY DEGRADABLE
PRODUCTS. BUT I GIVEN THE
SANDERS LEADERSHIP ON BOTH THE
ENVIRONMENT- MARKETING AND
PLASTICS ISSUES WE'RE SURE WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER. THANK YOU.
OKAY I'M MODERATELY LET'S GO
BACK TO THE PHONE LINES AND SEE
IF MR MCCARTY HAS. RECKLESSLY
APPEARED OR IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE THAT WOULD LIST. WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY TWO. I MISS
REGARDLESS SO AS NOT BERLIN OF
THE SPEAKER LINE UNFORTUNATELY
MISSED SHARE. OTHER OTHER OLD.
OVER THE PHONE SHOULD BE WILL
NOT SPEAK ON COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE DO HAVE LINE SEVENTY ONE IS
FIRST IS GOING TO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THIS IS BRUCE MANY
ANI ON BEHALF OF THE
BIODEGRADABLE PRODUCTS INSTITUTE
. API HAS OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MEMBERS AND CERTIFIED
COMPOSTABLE PRODUCTS IN THE
THIRD OF OCTOBER THIRTEEN
THOUSAND. ITEMS THE NUMBER
DANDER AND WITH THE LARGEST
CERTIFIER IN NORTH AMERICA- AND
IT'S PART OF THE BACKGROUND BPI
WITH THE ORIGINAL SPONSORING TWO
THOUSAND FOUR THAT THAT
DETERMINES THE USE BIODEGRADABLE
ONES GREENWASHING I HAVE WORKED
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO BAN THE
USE OF THAT. OF THAT TERM
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T TECHNICALLY
MEAN ANYTHING WHEN YOU APPLY
SCIENCE TO. SO WITH THAT
BACKGROUND THE WAY THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. IT REFERENCES
AS WHAT CA DEBBIE TALK TO A
WITHDRAWN STANDARD IN A IN A
TEST METHOD. BUT NOT A
SPECIFICATION. AND THE
DIFFERENCE IS A SPECIFICATION
GIVE YOU PASS FAIL- THE
WITHDRAWN OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T
EXIST ANYMORE AND A TEST MESSAGE
ASSEMBLY TELLS YOU HOW TO CAST
SOMETHING BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE
ANY PERFORMANCE CRITERIA
ASSOCIATED WITH IT. AND THIS IS
THE REASON WHY BIODEGRADABLE WAS
TAKEN OUT AS A AS A MARKETING
TERM BECAUSE IT DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING SCIENTIFICALLY. SPONSOR
SAID THEY THEY BELIEVE THEY HAVE
A PRODUCT THAT WILL BIODEGRADE
IN ANY ENVIRONMENT BUT IT WILL
BIODEGRADE DIFFERENTLY IN A
MARINE ENVIRONMENT VERSUS AN
ARID DESERT ENVIRONMENT PERSONS
YOU KNOW FORCING VIOLENT WITH
WITH MOISTURE- AND SO WHAT THE
BIO DEGRADABLE MEAN AND THAT'S-
THAT'S WHAT BPI'S CONCERNED
WITH. WE'VE. TRIED TO MAKE-
SCIENTIFIC'S IN ANY AND USED
TIME INTO PLAY. AFTER THE EIGHTH
. THROUGH THE YEAR UNION OR
THROUGH. OSCAR THAT IT'S
ESTABLISHED THE WHOLE COMPOSE
SCARE. WE HAVE ONE WHAT. TO
ALLOW THE USE OF THOSE TERMS
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE. SO IN ITS
CURRENT FORM UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAVE TO OPPOSE. OPPOSE THE BILL
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT SENATOR-
IS ALWAYS WORKING TO IMPROVE THE
AREA. AND WE HAVE A GREAT
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
SENATOR AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM IN THE FUTURE
IN ALL THESE AREAS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY. IN ITS CURRENT
FORM WE MUST OPPOSE. VERY GOOD.
MODERATE ELSE ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. TO TWELVE THIRTY
TWO. YES SIR MR NATIONAL LINE
NUMBER ONE TWELVE ONE ONE TWELVE
GROUP THIS. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS ROB SPIEGEL AGAIN
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION NOT-
EXECUTIVE OPPOSED- BUT ONE OF
THE TWEETER WE'RE CONTINUING TO
EXAMINE THE LEGISLATION DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION AT THE
TIME BUT WE HAVE HEARD THE NEED.
FOR OUR MEMBERSHIP- FURTHER
CLARIFICATIONS I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
NEXT THANKS IS ONE NUMBER NINETY
TWO IS GOING ON. MEMBERS DR
MILIND CAREFULLY CALIFORNIA
COMPOST COLLECTION IN AN
UNENVIABLE POSITION OF HAVING
LOST BILL AND- AND CHAIRS BILL
TO OPPOSE- BUT AGAIN IT'S THE
OTHERS HAVE BEEN ALLUDED WE HAVE
WORKED VERY SUCCESSFULLY WITH
THE CHAIR. AND WE ARE CONFIDENT
THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS- JUST TO STRESS OUT THE
REASONS THAT THE COMPOST
COALITION OPPOSED TO THE BILL
ARE REFERRED TO KNOWLEDGE OF
FROM THE TWENTY FIRST OF THIS
MONTH IT WAS A PRETTY REFERRED
TO IN THE ANALYSIS. BUT IF THE
FOLKS WANT TO READ THAT
FUNDAMENTALLY WE AGREED THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CASE METHOD IT'S
A TESTAMENT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ANY FROM STANDARDS THOSE
STANDARDS HAVE BEEN- IT'S DEBBIE
FOR A LONG TIME AND WE WILL
ALSO. SPONSOR OFFER AB TWELVE R.
ONE KING LAST YEAR BUT SEEKS TO
DO PRETTY MUCH THE SAME THING
HOLD COMPOSED ABILITY STANDARDS
TO THE HIGHEST POSSIBLE
STANDARDS ARE SO WE DON'T
CONTAMINATE A COMPOST DON'T
CONTAMINATE OUR SOILS AND WE
REMAIN CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL-
EFFECTIVELY CIRCUMVENTS A 12-1
PRODUCTS WHICH IS STILL UNDERWAY
THANK YOU THOSE THINGS YOU
MISTER ALONG WITH MOST OF THE-
NEXT. MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
QUICKER VERY GOOD LET'S CLOSE
THE PUBLIC CARE. GET BACK DIES
CENTER DA YOU WRECK. THANK YOU
MISTER FIRST I WANT TO THE BILL
AND SO I WANT TO SAY THAT- THIS
IS THIS. THIRD THEY'RE WRITTEN.
DEFINITELY NEED TO BE. SOME
CLARITY IN THIS IN THIS AREA AND
I WANT TO JUST THIS. THE CENTER
HAS WORKED DILIGENTLY IN THIS
EARLY AND BROUGHT. MY FAMILY
BROUGHT ME ALONG AND IN THE
PROCESS AND I I'M JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE IN CALIFORNIA I'M
CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT GOES WHERE
AND WHY BUT I'VE LEARNED A LOT.
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
BEING ON THIS COMMITTEE- BECAUSE
OF YOUR EFFORTS TO TRY TO
ACTUALLY MAKE THIS- MORE
UNDERSTANDABLE FOR CALIFORNIA
AND ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING GOOD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT I HAPPEN TO
REPRESENT- CRYSTAL GEYSER WHICH
IS IN MY DISTRICT IT DOES
BOTTLED WATER AND I TOWARD THEIR
PLAN AND- AND- MET MET WITH THE
FRUSTRATIONS THEY HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO MEET THE DEFINITIONS.
AND THEY WANT TO BE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND THERE THEY
HAVE A GREAT PRODUCT THEY'RE
GOOD. IN THE AREA SO- I'LL BE
WATCH I'LL BE WORKING WITH YOU
ON THE BILL HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
THERE TO WHERE WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
STANDARD THAT APPLIES ACROSS ALL
BOARDS SO I COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR
WORKON THIS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO. HELPING YOU ALONG THE WAY TO
GET IT DONE. FARE IS SEEING THE
WEATHER- CENTERS WHETHER IT'S OP
OPTION A OPTION B. OR A NEW
OPTION C. YOU MAY CLOSE CENTER.
THERE'S A MOTION BY CENTER STERN
. OH SORRY SENATOR OF A SKINNER
I DO NOT- SENATE ALLEN YOU
ADDRESS THIS A LITTLE BIT IN THE
OPENING BUT- GIVEN THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERN THAT WE-
KNOW INTERVAL IN THE FACT
ELIMINATED. THIS NOTION OF
BIODEGRADE ABILITY BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE A STANDARD- AND I
SEE THAT YOU'VE GOT YOU KNOW THE
TWO OPTIONS BUT WHAT GIVE ME
SOME SENSE YOUR CONFIDENCE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO- I MEAN OBVIOUSLY
WE DO NOT WANT SOMETHING CALLED
BIODEGRADABLE THAT JUST BREAKS
DOWN INTO LITTLE PIECES RIGHT
RIGHT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT BUT I
MEAN IN A WEIRD WAY LARGE PIECES
OF PLASTIC IS TERRIBLE IN THE
MARINE ENVIRONMENT. IT'S AWFUL
AND YET IT IT HAS LESS IMPACT ON
THE- THE MARINE LIFE BECAUSE
IT'S THE TINY PIECES OF PLASTIC
THAT. THE MARINE ANIMALS INGEST
IN THAT ARE- YOU KNOW SO
DANGEROUS BUT IT'S ALSO NOW WE
FOUND. THAT INCREASINGLY HUMANS
WE ARE WE HAVE THESE-
MICROPARTICLES ALL THROUGH US IN
THE- SO I GUESS- I NEED A LITTLE
MORE SHIRTS FOR ME TO HAVE A
COMPATIBILITY ON- I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO BUT I
WANT TO. SEE THAT. IT'S NOT CAN
HAVE THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. RIGHT I MEAN
REMEMBER WHAT WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSING ON OUR THE- NON FOSSIL
FUEL BASED- PRODUCTS WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A GREAT ABILITY SO
THESE ARE THESE ARE BIO BASED.
PRODUCTS THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SAME KIND OF MICROPLASTICS
PROBLEMS THAT YOU'RE-
REFERENCING OKAY. BUT BUT BUT
BUT CERTAINLY YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE THE PROBLEM I
THINK IT'S BEEN DISCUSSES THAT
WE JUST DON'T HAVE A GOOD
STANDARD- YOU KNOW AND WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ALL SORTS OF A
PERSPECTIVES THAT WE CAN GET
SOME FOR ME YOUR VOICE CONCERN
ABOUT THE BILL RIGHT TO FIND A
BETTER CENTER. AND WE'RE SEEKING
TO SET THE STANDARD HERE- IT'S
HARD IT'S TECHNICAL- YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF SCIENCE AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT THE VOTE
NUMBER NOW TO BE ABLE TO TURN TO
THE DIDN'T EXIST EVEN YOU KNOW
TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS AGO-
THAT WILL HELP TO GUIDE. IT IS
HELPING A GUY THIS THIS THIS
NEGOTIATION. BUT ONCE AGAIN
WELCOME WELCOME YOUR
PARTICIPATION. I KNOW YOU WORK
IN THE SPACE TO. RIGHT SO I WHEN
I READ THE THINGS ABOUT THE- THE
SPECIFICS IN THE BILL SO IT DOES
EXPLICITLY- PROHIBITS. A FOR
EXAMPLE A PETROLEUM BASED
PRODUCTS FROM BEING LABELED AS
BIODEGRADABLE. THAT'S THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THAT'S-
YEAH THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT'S
REALLY WHERE I WANT TO GO WITH
THIS. K. F. WITH THAT MADE SOME
OF THOSE CLARIFICATIONS MAY BE
NEEDED FOR THAT. YEAH THE FOCUS
HERE IS ON THE BIOBASED. VERY.
YEAH I KNOW PARA MEDIR OF
PETROLEUM BASED PRODUCT WOULD
NOT QUALIFY ABOUT MY BEST
ANDERSON YEAH RIGHT OKAY YEAH
OKAY- UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCE.
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT GREAT OKAY I
VAST MAJORITY SUBTERRANEAN BUT
IT WOULD BE. IT ARE YOU CAN BE
ABLE TO CLAIM BIODEGRADE ABILITY
SO. SEEING NO OTHER HANDS UP
CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE. BRIDGET
THIS QUESTION PRECIP. YOUR YOUR
MOTION FOR SENATE ON THE AND
STARTS RIGHT UP. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY TWO. BY SENATOR
ALAN THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN ALLEN FIVE
EIGHT. EIGHT HI DAWALY ALLEY I
GONZALEZ SALAS I SKINNER SKINNER
AYE STERN EXTERN HIGHLIGHT
CASKEY HI I. CASKEY I'D CLOSE
ROLE TELLY DEVOTES THE HIGHS
HAVE IT'S SEVEN ZERO THAT
MEASURES APPROVED NOW LET'S GO
BACK THEN- TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IF THE CLERK WILL CALL
THEM THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR JUSTICE ITEMS.
ONE TWO AND THREE. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS SIXTY ZERO GONZALEZ. THE
DALLAS FIVE SEVEN ZERO CLOSE
ROLLED TELEVOTES I SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO MR SURE YOU HAVE YOUR CHAIR
BACK OKAY. I WILL GO WILL GO OUT
OVER THE ROLE IN SB NINE TWO TWO
WIENER. I AM NUMBER FOUR SB
NINETY TO WIENER THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
VOTE IS FOUR TWO ZERO WITH CARE
VOTING I AM THE VICE YOU'RE NOT
VOTING AND SALAS. AND SALAS HI.
LOTUS FIVE WE WILL CLOSE AROUND
THAT WAS GOOD SB NINE FORTY TWO
BY NEWMAN. UNDER FIVE S. B.
FIFTY NINE FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
NEWMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOR TO RUN WITH
THE- CEREMONY I AM VICE CHAIR
VOTING I. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ FIVE
SKINNER. INNER I'D. LET'S GO TO
A SENATORS EGGMAN SPILLED TEN
FORTY SIX. EITHER SIX SB TEN
FORTY SIX BY CENTER EGGMAN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED HER VOTE IS
TWO TWO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING II. GONZALEZ AND SALAS I
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE STERN-
STERN I'D KEEP US ABOUT DOLLARS
CANNELLA. EXCUSE ME AS SENATOR
DOLLY. DALY I OKAY OKAY BECAUSE
RON THAT SB TEN SEVENTY SIX
ARCHULETA. I NUMBER SEVEN SB TEN
SEVENTY SIX BY SENATOR TO LETTER
TE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY THE
CURRENT POTUS FIVE TO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I. BATES IT'S
NOT VOTING STERN FIVE STERN HI
OKAY AROUND THAT SB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED ME REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER THE CURRENT LOTUS
FORTY ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING. I STERN. HI STERN I.
OKAY WILL CLOSE ROLL NOW SB TEN
NINETY FIVE. I DID NUMBER NINE
SB TEN NINETY FIVE BY CENTER
DRAWS SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT
VOTERS TO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I AM THE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO
GONZALEZ. AND SALAS I SKINNER
SKINNER FIVE. PERCENT FORTY TWO-
THAT BILLS OUT LET'S GO TO
CULTURAL SB TWELVE FIFTY FOUR
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB TWELVE FIFTY
FOUR BY SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY THE CURRENT POTUS FIVE
TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
AND IF I STERN VOTING BY. DALI
DALI AYE STERN AYE STERN AYE
SAYS HUMANA SEVEN ZERO AND.
THAT'S OUT TWELVE FIFTY TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE. ITEM NUMBER S. B.
TWELVE FIVE SENATOR. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
THE CURRENT VOTER SUPPORT TWO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I AM
THE VICE YOU'RE VOTING I'D DOLLY
. DALY NOT VOTING. SKINNER ALL%
RIGHT SKINNER AYE STERN- STERN
HI I SAID SIX ZERO THAT'S CLOSED
AT TWELVE NINETY SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE SB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN SEVEN BY SENATOR CORTESE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
COMMENDED THAT FIRST AMEND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER. THE
CURRENT LOTUS FIVE TO ONE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I AM VERY SURE
VOTING NO DALI DALI NO LICENSE
FIVE TO TWO THAT'S CLOSE THE
SCHOOL TWELVE A SIX ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SB TWELVE OH SIX BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTERS FIVE TO SELL WITH
THAT ONE IS ALREADY DISPATCHED
OKAY SO NINE OH FIVE YEAH THAT
DONE NINE OH FIVE IS ALSO DONE
OKAY AND THEN TWELVE FIFTY SIX.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN S. B.
TWELVE FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE ROUTE RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY-
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE
WITH THIS AND- THE CHAIR VOTING
II- BATES WELL BATES. NO SKINNER
. INNER MYSELF FOR TO TWO THAT'S
THAT'S- TWELVE. AS WE NEED TO
VOTE ON THAT YEAH ITEM NUMBER SO
AS BETWEEN SEVENTY BY SENATOR
ALAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION- THE
CURRENT VOTED FIVE TO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I'D- BATES.
BATES NOW. FIVE TO ONE THAT'S
CLOSED AT TWELVE THIRTY TWO
FINAL BILL. BY TEN AM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN SB TWELVE THIRTY TWO
BY SENATOR ALAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
TO BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS- THAT ONCE
ALREADY SEVEN. SORRY OKAY SO WE
WILL HER HOLD WE WILL NOW
ADJOURN THIS MEETING WHAT WE'RE
NOT COMING BACK UNTIL. APRIL
TWENTIETH.